Scholastic audio presents Wings of Fire.
Book 12, The Hive Queen, by 2ET
Sutherland.
Read by Shannon McManus.
The Lost Continent Prophecy.
Turn your eyes, your wings, your fire, to
the land across the sea.
Where dragons are poisoned, and dragons
are dying, and no one can ever be free.
A secret lurks inside their eggs.
A secret hides within their book.
A secret buried far below May save those
brave enough to look.
Open your hearts, your mind, your wings
to the dragons who flee from the hive.
Face a great evil with talent united, or
none of the tribes will survive.
Prologue.
The ocean swept across Moon's claws, as
dark and speckled with stars as our own
scales.
She'd always thought of the sea as the
edge of the world.
Once you got there, that was it.
You couldn't go any farther.
But now she knew that wasn't true.
A dragon had been blown ashore.
All the way from across the ocean.
A dragon from a tribe nobody in Pyria had
ever seen before.
A dragon with 4 wings instead of two.
A dragon with long furling antennae, and
scales like sliced gems, and the ability
to spin silk that burned.
Luna was proof that there was a continent
far on the other side of the sea, filled
with strange dragons.
Dragons who need my help, she says.
Moon shivered.
That couldn't be right.
They didn't need her of all dragons.
It was Moon's fault. that Dark Stalker
had nearly taken over all of Pyria.
Her fault that he'd killed so many ice
wings, including their queen.
She'd seen too much good in him, and not
enough of the bad.
It was too soon for her to trust another
dragon with a story of persecution.
She wanted to use her visions to help the
world.
But she was not ready to have the fate of
any more tribes in her talons.
But Luna wanted moon to save all the silk
wings.
Luna thought Moon was the 2nd coming of
Clearsight, who was apparently the number
one beloved ancient goddess of Pentala.
So, no pressure there.
She can tell us what's going to happen
next, Luna's brain saying, she can see
everything the hive wings will do.
She can predict Queen Wasp's next move
and then the chrysalis will know how to
stop her.
It was like that all day long.
Luna had extremely grand ideas of Moon's
abilities, and shining dreams of how they
would change everything.
She was so wound up, in fact, about
Moon's ability to see the future, that
Moon hadn't quite found the courage yet
to tell her she could also read minds.
It was really awkward, hearing all of
Luna's thoughts about her and Kibli and
Jerboa.
And honestly, it was getting more awkward
every moment that Moon didn't tell her.
If she'd had any extra Skyfire, she would
have slipped it to Luna somehow to
silence the pile up of expectations.
But she didn't have any.
So telling her wouldn't help much
anyway.
I should, though.
It's wrong not to.
Moonside.
She sang the future right now, came a
thought, loud and clear from right behind
her.
Moon winced, and turned around to find
Luna bounding over the sand, well, trying
to bound over the sand.
The sand had a way of sinking out
suddenly from under one's talons, so it
was impossible to get any sort of
bounding rhythm.
Those were partly Luna's thoughts.
Moon sometimes got tangled up with them
when they were too close to her own.
She wasn't sure why, but there was
something more entangling about Luna's
mind than other dragons.
Why are you out here by yourself?
Una asked, settling next to moon in a
spray of sand.
I like to look at the moons sometimes
Moon answered, and then laughed.
That's my whole name, actually.
Moon watcher.
My name means moon in the old language.
Did you know that?
Luna asked.
Now it's a kind of moth.
She dug a tiny hole in the sand in front
of her. and dropped a thread of flame
silk into it.
The glow warmed moon's talons.
I didn't know that.
Moon said, but she liked hearing it.
It made her feel a little closer to Luna
who could be a bit intense sometimes
What's the old language?
Luna shrugged.
I don't know.
The language everyone spoke in Pantala
before Claire's side arrived.
Clearsight, changed your language?
Moon said, surprised.
I think so.
I heard a story once anyway, that we all
speak dragon because of her.
That explained why the Pentalons and
Pyreans could understand each other.
But Moon was still puzzled.
Why didn't Clearsight learn their
language instead?
Maybe she foresaw that we'd need to
communicate with each other one day.
Or maybe she just hoped for it.
Are you having a vision?
Luna asked hopefully.
No, Moon said.
Sorry.
No, nothing yet.
Luna's wings slid down into the sand, and
she picked up a seashell, fiddling with
it as though focusing on it would keep
her from crying.
I am really sorry, Luna.
Moon said.
I don't know how to get you back to
Pantala.
Nothing in my visions has shown me that.
I'm worried about my little brother, Luna
said, throwing the seashell into the
ocean.
And sore tail.
He must be losing his mind.
Kibley will think of something.
Moon said.
He usually does.
She hesitated.
Luna.
I don't know if it's a good idea to tell
you this, but I've been hearing a
prophecy in my head.
A prophecy?
Luna echoed.
It started with my vision of you, in
Jerboa's hut.
I could hear a few words, and now
whenever I'm with you, it gets clearer
and clearer, I don't completely
understand it, and I'm afraid it might
scare you.
I'm not easily scared, Luna said.
Please tell me.
Moon sensed movement behind her, and then
a few stray grumbling thoughts in a voice
she recognized.
Kibley had returned successful then.
Well, he could hear this, and so could
the 2 dragons with him.
She took Luna's talents between her own
closed her eyes, and let her mind clear
so the words of the prophecy could flow
through her.
She did not love this bit.
Cryptic rhyming prophecies were not as
useful as visions, in her opinion, and
the last one had gone to a pretty
terrifying place.
But the last one had also saved her and
her friends, so she couldn't ignore
them.
Turn your eyes, your wings, your fire, she
whispered.
To the land across the sea.
She felt Loon as it shiver all through
her own scales.
Where dragons are poisoned, and dragons
are dying, and no one can ever be free.
A secret lurks inside their eggs.
A secret hides within their book, a
secret buried far below, may save those
brave enough to look.
Open your hearts, your minds, your wings
to the dragons who flee from the hive
face a great evil with talent united, or
none of the tribes will survive.
Silence fell.
Moon took a few deep breaths.
I know this secret in the book, Luna said
thoughtfully.
But what's the secret in the eggs?
And the buried one?
Maybe that's the flame silks.
No one can ever be free.
That's definitely true.
A great evil.
Hmm.
Maybe the hive wings are the great evil?
Yeesh, Kidley said. coming up and nudging
one of Moon's wings with his.
Didn't we just face a great evil?
That should count, I say. if anyone asks
me.
Great evil, faced, done.
Take it off the to-do list.
She opened her eyes and smiled at him.
Sounds like a new great evil.
Their friend Turtles said nervously from
beside him.
Can I vote no on any more great evils in
our lifetime?
Hey, turtle, Moon said.
Hey, tsunami.
The tall blue sea wing founder of Jade
Mountain Academy gave her an exasperated
face.
Moon, she said.
I feel like I was really clear about not
having anything to do with any more
prophecies.
They just happened to me, Moon
protested.
I'm sorry.
Moon?
Luna whispered, poking her
surreptitiously with her tail.
Who are these dragons?
Oh, sorry, of course, Moon said.
Luna, this is our friend Hurtle and his
sister Tsunami.
They're from the Sea Wing tribe.
Thank you for going to get them, Kibli.
Well, I thought that maybe turtle here
could make us something, Kibley said
carefully, which would perhaps take us
across the ocean so that Luna can get
home.
Oh, Luna said, squinting at turtle.
Like my silk sail?
But one we can steer, or something like
that, Moon said.
She and Kibley had agreed that they
should wait to tell Luna about animus
magic.
If she got this excited and full of
glorious vengeful plans over Moon's
future seeing, Goodness knows how she
would feel about real magic. and all the
things it could do to her enemy tribe.
Things we can't let her do.
Kibli and Moon agreed.
Animus magic was too dangerous.
But something made by animus magic that
could get her home.
That wouldn't hurt anyone.
Kimberley had offered to ask Turtle if
he'd be willing to do that.
Right, Turtle said.
Make something.
So here's the thing.
I can't.
Oh, Moon said.
That's all right, Turtle.
We understand.
Your soul?
No, no, Turtle said, looking worried.
That's not it.
I mean, I actually tried and I can't.
Kibling made a face at Moon like, It's
true.
I have no idea why.
Luna, Moon said.
Can you give us a moment?
Sure.
The 4 winged dragon turned and trudged
slowly back to Jaboa's hut, limping on
her injured ankle.
I knew I shouldn't have gotten my hopes
up.
Her mind thought sadly, and Moon felt
awful for her.
Poor lost dragon, tsunami said.
It must be so weird for her to be here
surrounded by strangers, with no way to
get home.
So, what's wrong, turtle?
Moon asked, as soon as Luna was out of
earshot.
I don't know, Turtles said, flinging up
his wings, I can't do any animus spells
all of a sudden.
I've tried all kinds of little things and
nothing works.
Three moons, she said. blinking in
confusion and alarm.
Here's the really weird part.
I don't think anemone can either.
He said.
Right before Kibley came to get us.
She was telling me about a spell she
tried to restore Tamarin's site.
I'd been thinking of trying one for
Starflights, so we were comparing notes.
But she said, it didn't work, and she
couldn't figure out why.
Turtle turned to give Kibli a severe
look.
I suspect, he said, that Kibley broke
animus magic.
Me?
Kibley cried.
What did I do?
The soul spells, Turtle said.
Remember how you carefully planned them
out with us to protect our souls and make
sure we can only do magic that doesn't
affect another dragon's free will?
And no magic that's selfishly motivated
Kibley said.
Right.
We all agreed safeguards would be
helpful.
Except I think it ruled out everything
Turtle said.
Maybe everything we do could be
considered selfishly motivated or affect
someone's free will in some way.
So now, none of our spells work.
Oh my goodness, said Moon.
That is, no, that's, that's ridiculous.
Kibli protested.
I did not break animus magic.
I do not think I broke animus magic.
That makes no.
Let me think about this.
Did you try taking off your soul spell
objects to see if it would work without
them?
Moon asked.
Anemone didn't want to.
Turtle said.
But I did, just to try a small spell, and
it still didn't work.
He pointed at Kibley.
Broken.
If it still didn't work without the sole
spell, then it's not the sole spell
Kibley said, and therefore, not me, who
broke animus magic.
It really feels like it is you, though
Turtle said.
Maybe something else is going on, Moon
said. worried.
Dark Stalker flashed through her mind
making plans, tinkering with dragon's
powers.
She knew he was gone now.
He'd been turned into a dragonette, with
no powers, and no memory of his past, but
sometimes, in her nightmares.
He still managed to mess with her
friends.
What if someone else did this to you?
Or left something behind that did this to
you.
Some kind of safeguard?
He could have done that, couldn't he?
So if he ever lost his powers, so would
everyone else.
There isn't anyone who could do that
Kibley said gently.
He'd had to wake her up from some of
those nightmares.
So he knew what she was thinking, as
clearly as though he had mind reading
abilities too.
This is just a glitch, not a sinister
plan.
We'll fix it.
What about Jerboa?
Tsunami asked.
Is her magic working?
She's an animus dragon too, right?
Sort of.
But she's an animus dragon who won't
touch her magic.
Moon said.
We can't ask her for help with this.
Well, all right, then let's not.
Tsunami said.
You guys, we don't need animus magic.
We don't?
Turtle tipped his head up to look at our
tsunami grin with all her teeth.
My friends and I solved plenty of
problems without animus magic.
Thank you very much.
It's called being resourceful, and smart
and totally heroic, no prophecies
required.
All right, smarty McSquid.
Turtle said.
So how would you endure resourceful
heroic friends solve this problem?
Well, step one is, we need more
information, right?
Tsunami said, we want to go over there to
see if Luna's stories are all true, to
find out what's really going on, and
whether we should get involved.
I think she's telling the truth, from
what I can see in her mind, Moon said.
But it is hard to get a full picture of
the situation.
I wish we could go scout it out and see
if there is a way we can help her.
Maybe also what the great evil is, Kibley
suggested.
A heads up about that would be super.
So, we need to get to the other continent
tsunami said.
We don't need a magic flying sail thing
to do that.
Oh, uh, Kibley said.
Well, I mean, I did think of this.
It's why I got you too specifically.
Just so we're clear that I thought of
this first.
Thought of what?
Turtle asked.
To get to the lost continent turtle?
Tsunami said, sweeping one wing out
toward the ocean.
All you and I have to do is swim there.
Part one.
The glittering hive.
Chapter one.
For most of her life, Crickets best
friends were books.
Books accepted you the way you were, and
shared all their secrets with you.
Books never told you to stop asking
questions or accused you of being nosy
and annoying.
Books never said cricket.
You don't need to know that.
Mind your own business.
In books, everything had an explanation.
She especially liked nonfiction.
Lots of facts and things had to make
sense.
If a question came up, eventually you got
the answer.
Every mystery was solved by the end. facts
fit together.
When you wanted something explained, there
it was, with no whispering or cold stares
or slammed doors.
Another thing she liked about books was
the fact that one of them had probably
saved her life.
It was a giant book called The
Architecture of the Hives, expanded
edition.
Now, with sections on hydroponics and
silk bridges, which technically belonged
to her mother, and therefore, technically
was off limits to tiny grubby dragonette
talons.
Which was why two-year-old cricket was
hiding in a cupboard with it.
The 1st time everyone lost their minds.
Why is this book so in love with itself?
Little cricket muttered.
All she'd wanted to know is how to get
from her home in Cicada hives to the
Temple of Clearsight in wasp hives
preferably in some clever, really fast
way, where she could be home that same
night, and nobody would notice she'd been
gone.
She just wanted to see it again, even if
only for a moment.
But every sentence in this book was miles
too long.
And the author kept repeating himself
over and over.
Not to mention the never ending rapturous
paragraphs about every tiny curve and
window and detail that exemplified Queen
Wasps' exquisite mental quality, and I
for visual balance, or some such
nonsense.
This is not a book of answers.
Cricket grumbled, flipping ahead.
This is a book of groveling.
She paused on a full page drawing of wasp
pives.
The book was nearly as big as she was, so
the artist had lots of space to draw the
temple at the heart of the hive.
She rested her chin on her talons, and
stared dreamily at the perfect columns
the perfect dome on the roof, the perfect
library, and quiet pools all around the
temple of Clearsight.
She'd visited it for the 1st time only a
few days earlier, when her sister, Katie
did, took her as a treat for her 2nd
birthday.
It was the most beautiful place cricket
had ever seen.
Imagine being the librarian and living
there forever.
Imagine being in charge of the book of
Clear Sight, the most important book in
the world, and being one of the only 2
dragons who ever got to read it.
Now that was a book with answers.
Hundreds of years ago, Clearsight had
written down her prophecies of every
important thing that would happen after
her death, starting in her time and
reaching far into the future.
If cricket read it, she'd really know
everything.
Maybe her brain would finally stop
buzzing with questions all the time.
Maybe she'd finally feel like everything
made sense.
Cricket wanted the world to feel more
like a book.
Here is a question, so here is an
answer.
Here are other mysteries of the
universe.
Now here is everything you want to know
about them.
If her life were a book, she could check
the index and go straight to the page
that would tell her why her parents were
always fighting, or why her mother didn't
love her.
She would read the chapter about how Katy
did was always sad, and then she could
read about how to fix it to make her
sister happy.
Those were the big mysteries of 2 year
old cricket's life.
She had no idea that there was an even
bigger one, hiding below the surface of
her entire tribe, or that she might be
the key to solving it.
A shriek from outside tore through the
hum of cricket's thoughts, startling her
so much, she banged her head on the top
of the cupboard, and nearly knocked over
the little flame silk lamp she'd smuggled
in.
She caught it with a flare of panic and
relief.
If she set her mother's book on fire, she
might as well go ahead and burn the whole
house down to hide the evidence.
She'd be in just as much trouble either
way.
The scream came again, and Cricket nearly
leaped out of the cabinet to investigate
but before she could.
Heavy talons entered the kitchen, and she
covered the lamp quickly with her wings.
There is a traitor in this hive. said her
mother's voice, but not her mother's
voice at all.
Do not let him escape.
Cricket held her breath, more terrified
than she even understood.
Who was her mother talking to?
Why did she sound all wrong?
More talon steps entered the room.
This had to be Katy did.
The only other dragon at home.
But without any further conversation.
The 2 of them ran out the front door.
Cricket pushed the cupboard door open a
crack and peeked out.
The kitchen was deserted, although she
could hear a lot of commotion on the
street outside.
Curiosity and fear went to war within
her.
And as often happened in cricket's life
curiosity won.
She left the book hidden, took the lamp
with her, and slipped out of the cabinet
hurrying upstairs to her mother's office
which had a window with a view of the
street.
It was the same street she flew down
every day.
Houses built of tree stuff, turquoise
mosaic tiles glittering in the light of
the flame silk lamps, neatly tended
gardens here and there, a line of black
stones inlaid in the ground, to show
young dragonettes the way to school.
But instead of her polite, peaceful
neighbors, and the usual strolling
dragons.
The street was now bristling with
marching rows of teeth and claws.
Cricket had never heard the word mob, but
when she did, years later, she thought it
was almost right for what she'd seen.
But not quite.
The dragons below her weren't enraged or
in chaos.
They moved in eerie unison, and near
complete silence, as they surrounded the
one dragon who was out of sync with the
rest, cutting off all his possible escape
routes.
He cowered in the center of the glaring
circle.
His red and black striped wings folded in
tightly, He looked quite old.
Bolder than most dragons cricket knew
maybe 60 or 100?
She didn't really know how to guess the
ages of grown up dragons.
But he was quite big, and his scales were
a little dull, and he moved in a tired
aching bones kind of way.
Please, just let me go.
He shouted at the crowd.
His eyes flickered white for a moment, and
then dark again.
I promise I'm not a threat to you.
I don't want to be like them.
That is not an option.
The surrounding dragon said, in one
voice.
It wasn't just the voice that was wrong.
Their eyes.
Their eyes were all wrong too.
Cricket felt a spasm of fear.
Throughout the crowd.
The dragon's eyes were all white, like
pure, glassy marbles.
Like empty snakeskins, like dead blood
sucked grubs.
Three of them stepped forward, with their
claws or tails raised, to point menacing
stingers of their prey.
Their faces were blank.
Cold, and merciless.
They looked ready to kill without a
flicker of emotion.
And one of them was Katy did.
Cricket ducked below the window frame, her
heart beating frantically.
What is happening?
What is wrong with my sister?
What's wrong with all of them?
She heard another scream from below, and
forced herself to peek out again.
The old dragon was being marched away
down the street, struggling weakly
surrounded by a phalanx of dragons, who
were almost all crickets, friends and
neighbors.
Except now, they had been transformed
into something else, something dark, and
no longer dragon.
And cricket wasn't sure she'd ever be
able to look at them the same way again.
Her eyes caught on a flutter of blue near
a doorway, and she realized that his silk
wing was there, pressing herself back
into the shadows to stay out of the way.
The silkwings' eyes were normal, but her
expression was fearful and puzzled.
Cricket's gaze flicked across the houses
quickly.
And she spotted 5 more silk wings
watching from doorways and windows.
None of them had the snake skin eyes.
A couple wore resigned expressions, as
though they'd seen this before, but at
least all of them had some emotion on
their faces.
None of them were empty, like the hive
wings down below.
So whatever's happening, it's only
happening to hive wings, it's not
affecting the silk wings.
Or me.
Her mind leaped onto this puzzle.
Preferring it enormously to the other
option of contemplating the horror of
what she'd just seen.
Is it because I'm too young?
But that couldn't be it.
There were little dragonettes everywhere
in the crowd, intoning the same words as
the other hive wings.
Bombardier, the most annoying dragonette
in her class, was among the ones who'd
marched the old dragon away.
Even Midge, the tiniest dragonette on the
block, who had hatched a month ago, was
down there, with her eyes blank, and
teeth bared.
Maybe this was something parents taught
their kids to do.
But because cricket's parent didn't like
her, they'd forgotten or neglected to do
it.
Maybe the other high wings had learned it
in school.
Sometime when cricket was reading under
her desk and not paying attention.
Maybe there were secret meetings for all
the other hive wings except her.
And she wasn't invited, because she asked
too many questions.
But Katie did.
Katydid would have told her of all the
hive wings did something together that
cricket should know about.
She would have taught her how to blank
out her eyes, and march with the others
and threaten old dragons and look totally
scary.
More important, Katy did would never
actually do any of those things.
Except she did.
I just saw her.
A door slammed downstairs.
Cricket glanced outside and saw the hive
wings dispersing.
The ones who had marched the old dragon
away were still visible in the distance
but everyone else was blinking and
yawning and heading back indoors.
Uh-oh.
If Katy did was one of the ones marching
off, that meant the dragon who'd just
come into the house would be mother.
Cricket ran out of her mother's office
and dove into the nearest closet just in
time.
Through the crack in the door, she saw
her mother stomp past the closet and into
her office in a blur of orange and black
scales, her wings buzzing slightly, the
way they did when she was annoyed.
Usually at cricket.
Come to think of it, it was really
strange for Cricket's mother to leave her
office during her morning work hours.
Cricket and Katy did weren't allowed to
make even the slightest noise before noon
in case they disturbed her.
The office door slid shut, and Cricket
let out the breath she'd been holding.
A part of her desperately wanted to burst
in and ask her mother all the questions
swarming in her head, starting with, would
Katy did come back?
How soon?
And of course, things like, so what in
the hive was that?
But some deeper instinct protected her.
This once, she didn't let her curiosity
win.
Instead, she crept up to Katy Did's room
on the top floor and curled herself under
her sister's dark blue silk blankets.
She closed her eyes, and tried not to cry
and waited.
It was late that night when Katie did
finally returned, exhausted and wind
blown.
Cricket's father had come home earlier
and Cricket had listened to both her
parents eating dinner and hissing at each
other.
Neither one had looked for her, or called
to ask her to join them.
But that was normal.
Katie did was the only one in the house
who tried to organize family meals.
She was the one who made sure cricket was
fed and got to school on time in a year.
She'd be the one who finally took cricket
to an eye doctor to get her glasses.
She was the only dragon cricket loved.
Her heart lit up as Katydid came through
the door.
Cricket bounded out of the blankets
grabbed her sister's shoulders, and
stared into her face.
Her eyes were back to normal.
Wow.
Gentle, Katie did scolded, but kindly.
She removed Cricket's claws, and rolled
her shoulders as though they were sore.
I had to fly to wasp high than back today
so take it easy on me.
Why?
Cricket demanded.
Why did you have to?
What did you do to that old dragon?
What happened to your eyes this morning?
Why was everyone acting so awful and
weird?
All the questions she'd been bottling up
all day spilled out of her, along with
the tears she thought she'd beaten.
What was that voice?
Why did you look so mean?
Katie did, what happened to you?
Katie did, was opposed to say something
reassuring.
She was supposed to shrug and laugh, and
explain how it was a hive wing game, and
cricket would learn it next week.
Not to worry, nothing important.
But instead, Katy did stared at her.
With the least reassuring expression
possible on her face.
What happened to me, she said.
Didn't it happen to you too?
No, Cricket cried.
I mean, I don't know what it was, but I
sure didn't get all super possessed and
freaky looking and mean like everyone
else I could see.
Your eyes were totally white, Katie did.
And you were growling at that old
dragon.
Couldn't you see how scared he was?
But that was a whole hive of command?
Katy did said.
All talons out.
Every dragon in the hive was included.
There's no way you could have been left
out.
Her kind orange yellow face was all
worry.
Cricket had never seen her sister look so
anxious.
Left out of what?
Cricket asked nervously.
Katy did rubbed her forehead, and sidled
over to close the door.
Although their parents were probably both
asleep already, and usually never came up
to the sisters rooms anyway.
It doesn't happen often, she said softly
but sometimes, Queen Wasp controls
dragons.
I mean, not just with orders and soldiers
I mean, she gets into your brain and
makes you do, um, anything she wants you
to.
What?
Cricket said.
How?
That's, What?
It's very efficient, Katy did pointed
out.
Like today, when there was a trader who'd
run away from her and was trying to hide
out in our hive, Queen Wasp can take over
all the dragons in the hive at once and
find him immediately.
Then we catch him, and she releases most
everybody while a few of us escort him
back to her.
But, do you want to?
Cricket asked.
Can she do it anytime she wants from
anywhere?
What if you're busy?
Or what if you don't want to do what she
says?
Her sister shook her head.
You do want to.
She said.
She is the queen cricket.
If she were standing next to you giving
an order, you'd do it no matter what.
Of course.
This is basically the same, except she
doesn't have to be everywhere at once.
It's not the same at all, Cricket thought
rebelliously.
So, your talons move, and your voice
speaks, and your wings fly, and there's
nothing you can do to stop it?
she asked.
You can't even say, no thank you, not
today?
Katie did threw out her wings.
Of course not.
Cricket, you wouldn't really ever say
that to the queen, surely.
Be serious.
If she ordered me to stab someone, I
would, Cricket thought.
If she asked me to drag away an elderly
dragon who was crying, I would say no.
She thought.
She hoped.
She wasn't sure.
There was a difference between being
brave in a book, and brave in real life.
So there certainly might be a difference
between the cricket in her head, and a
real cricket, standing in front of the
actual terrifying queen.
But how does it work?
Cricket asked.
I've never seen anything like that in any
science book.
I have no idea.
Katy did said tiredly, which was how a
lot of conversations between the sisters
ended.
Cricket wasn't ready to let this one go
yet, though.
And why doesn't it work on me?
She pressed.
Is mother right?
There's something wrong with me?
No.
Katy did protested.
Of course not.
I don't know why.
But why doesn't matter?
What matters is how to protect you so no
one realizes it doesn't work on you.
You'll have to stay alert for when it
happens.
We'll find places for you to hide.
The good news is she doesn't do it very
often.
I'll keep you safe, cricket, I promise.
You think I'll be in trouble if Queen
Wasp finds out?
Cricket said, in a small voice.
I'm afraid maybe, Katy did admitted.
She put her wings around cricket, and
they leaned into each other.
But, if she takes over your brain, won't
she know about me?
Now that you know?
Cricket asked.
No, it doesn't work like that.
Katie did said.
She doesn't get into our thoughts and
secrets and everything we know.
She just controls what our bodies are
doing for a little while.
Cricket shuddered.
That sounded completely horrible.
Plus, also, it was extremely weird and
unsettling that Katy did didn't think it
sounded completely horrible.
But Katy did kept her promise.
For the next 4 years, Katie did covered
for her, and Cricket learned to be
careful in how to hide quickly until the
commands passed.
The question of why did matter to her, and
she did all the research she could, but
with no luck.
Still, she kept the secret, and she was
clever, and safe, and as cautious, as an
impulsive, curious little dragonette
could be.
Until the most beautiful dragon cricket
had ever seen, fell over a wall into her
school courtyard, and all her caution
through itself out the window.
She couldn't exactly say why she'd helped
Blue hide or why she'd told him her
secret.
Or why she'd left the safety of her hive
to fly across the savannah with him on a
hazardous rescue mission.
Maybe those were all answers she'd find
at the end of her own book.
For now.
All she had were consequences.
She was a fugitive, wanted for stealing
the book of Clearsight, and helping flame
silks escape the queen.
The book of Clearsight had not, contained
all the answers to the universe after
all.
Worse, cricket's secret hive mind
immunity had been exposed in the temple.
And now the queen knew that she was
different, that the mind control didn't
work on her.
Cricket would never be able to go home
again.
But on the other talon, now she had blue
in her life, and as she sat by his softly
glowing cocoon in an underground cave
deep below Pantala, she decided she had
no regrets about what she'd done.
Except maybe one.
She really?
Really?
Really wished she'd brought a book with
her.
Cricket sighed and stretched out her
wings. 4 more days of sitting in a cave
with nothing to read?
She was seriously going to lose her
mind.
It had been very dramatic and romantic.
When Blue's golden flame silk had begun
spiraling from his wrists, and they'd
come running down into this secret cave
and she'd knelt beside him, and pledged
to be there when he woke up, and to stay
beside him always.
But now, he was peacefully snoozing away
growing his wings, and she was so bored.
She stood up and circled his cocoon.
It was a beautiful silvery gold color, but
she missed the blue and purple of blues
scales.
She wished she could see even a hint of
them through the silk.
She knew that when she did, that would be
a sign he was almost ready to come out.
She hoped his friends would be back by
then.
She hoped Luna and Swordtail and Sundew
were safe.
How long had she been down here?
Her sense of time seemed muffled by the
caves, but she thought a whole day might
have passed.
Had Luna been blown out to sea, or
recaptured by the hive wings.
Had Swordtell followed her?
Was Sundew all right?
It felt a little odd to worry about
Sundew, who had been her captor only a
few days earlier.
Sundew.
Well, really, Sundu's parents, had forced
Cricket to help steal the book of
Clearsight, which led to this whole
mess.
But then Sundu had helped her rescue Blue
and Luna, so that more than balanced the
scales in cricket's opinion.
And the truth was, she kind of liked the
fierce leaf wing.
Sundu let herself be mad, and always said
what she really thought. and made all her
own decisions, even when her parents
didn't like it, and Cricket didn't know
any high wings like that.
Prickly opinions that stuck out in the
hives tended to get smashed down fairly
quickly.
Are all leaf wings like that?
Brave enough to do their own thing, no
matter what anyone else thinks?
Sundu's parents, Belladonna and Hemlock
would have preferred to keep cricket and
swordtail under their wings until they
found another use for them.
It was Sundoo who had insisted on helping
them free the flame silks instead.
And she'd kept the book of Clear Sight
instead of giving it to them.
Cricket's parents would never have agreed
to that, or trusted her with something so
important.
Belladonna and Hemlock had grumbled, but
when Sundew put her talons down, they
accepted it.
She didn't have to help fight the hive
wings who spotted Luna and Sortell either
Cricket thought.
But she didn't even hesitate.
Cricket wished she could ever be that
sure of herself.
Sundoom moved like a dragon who'd already
found all the answers to her questions.
It was really quiet in the caves this far
under the earth.
If she sat still and concentrated, she
could hear water trickling in the
distance.
And every once in a while, she heard
weird little squeaky echoes, which she
suspected, all right, she hoped.
Where more of those little reading
monkeys, like the ones she in blue had
seen at the bottom of a stinkhole on the
savannah?
If I could find them?
Maybe I could borrow one of their books
she thought wistfully, which made her
laugh at herself.
Of course she wouldn't be able to
understand a little reading monkey
language, if that's what it was.
Plus, her claws would be too big for
their tiny books.
But imagine holding a book by another
species in her talons.
What if she could translate it?
What would it say?
What did monkeys think about?
What were their stories about?
What did they know that dragons didn't?
It felt as if her head might explode?
thinking about everything she might
discover?
In another life, where studying them
could have been my destiny.
A noise sounded from the stone passages
beyond the cave.
Cricket froze, all senses on alert.
It came again.
The scratch of claws on rock, the sound
of a tail slithering along the floor.
Someone else was in the caves.
Chapter 2.
Cricket held her breath.
Her mind frantically darting through her
options.
Could she pretend she was guarding the
cocoon?
That maybe Queen Wasp had given her a
secret mission?
Not if the dragon who is coming had white
eyes.
If Queen Wasp was inside this dragon's
brain, she'd recognize cricket as the
dragon who'd stolen the book of
Clearsight, and 2 of her flame silks.
She'd be able to raise the entire
continent to descend on this cave in a
heartbeat.
And there was no way cricket could hide
blue before they arrived.
She stepped in front of his cocoon anyway
and tried to make her face look
menacing.
But the dragon who appeared in the
doorway was the green and gold of summer
leaves, with 2 wings instead of four.
Cricket had never been so relieved to see
a scowl that fierce.
Sundew, she cried, leaping toward her.
You're all right.
No thanks to any of you, Sundew
grumbled.
She winced as she stepped into the cave.
And cricket spotted a trickle of blood
running down her shoulder.
What happened?
Cricket asked, catching sundew's pouches
as the leaf wing threw them off and
setting them against the wall.
Have you seen Sortell and Luna?
I'm so sorry I couldn't fly up and help
you.
Not that I'm much use in a fight anyway
but Blue's metamorphosis started and I
had to get him somewhere safe.
She waved her wings at the glowing lump
behind her.
What did you do to the hive wings?
Do they know where we are?
She felt the shape of the book of
Clearsight in the last pouch, and laid it
carefully, reverently, on the stone
floor.
The queen had lied to everyone about the
book, but it was still very old, and
pretty sacred, and most important, a book
something to read, at last.
I led them away, sundew said, shaking
raindrops off her wings.
I flew south, though smug, moss brained
monsters chased me all the way to Lake
Scorpion, and then I lost them and came
back the very annoyingly long way around
Dragonfly Bay.
It's pouring outside.
Easy to lose a dragon in a storm.
She shook her head.
Didn't see Luna anywhere.
But I did find this bedraggled, unhelpful
mess.
Sundew ducked out into the passageway and
cricket followed her.
Swordtail lay sprawled on the cave floor
unconscious.
He seemed much wetter than sundew, as
though she had just dredged him up from
the bottom of the ocean.
Long strands of seaweed were tangled
through his horns and his talons, and
wrapped around his dark blue wings.
By the book.
Where has he been?
Cricket asked, crouching beside him to
study his face.
Is he all right?
Sundew shrugged, disinterestedly.
He's alive.
I found him like this on a rock in the
bay.
He's lucky I found him instead of a hive
wing.
Although I was pretty tempted to leave
him there.
She grabbed one of his back talons and
started dragging him into Blue's cave.
Cricket followed, trying to hold
Swordtail's head above the bumpy rocks.
That he was alone?
She asked.
A sundew dropped the silk wing in a heap
beside the flame silk cocoon.
My guess is Luna got blown out to sea, and
he tried to follow her.
Sundoo said.
She stretched her wings again, and shook
out her talons as though her shoulder
hurt.
But the storm chucked him into a boulder
instead, which he deserved, if you ask
me.
Did you see him fly off and leave me
fighting 2 hive wings alone?
I mean, sure.
Luna is great, and I know he just got her
back and all, and I get it.
I have a one true love too.
You do?
Cricket said.
Fascinated.
Who?
But on the other talent?
Hive wings?
Sundew went on, ignoring her.
With pointy stabby bits.
Plus, he left you guys in danger too
which he apparently didn't even think
about.
He probably thinks you could take on 9
times that many high wings by yourself
and be all right, Cricket admitted.
I mean, that's what I think.
She was still wrapping her mind around
the last revelation.
Sundew has a one true love?
Another leaf wing, I guess.
What kind of dragon would Sundoo fall in
love with?
Is it someone equally terrifying?
Hmm, Sundew said, looking a little
mollified.
Well, that would be the 1st sign of life
from his brain, that's for sure.
I guess he never found Luna.
And you didn't see where she went?
Cricket glanced worriedly a blues
cocoon.
Could he hear anything through the layers
of silk?
Probably not.
She was pretty sure metamorphosis was
kind of a long, dreamless sleep.
But how would he react when he came out
and discovered that the sister he'd
worked so hard to rescue was gone.
No, but I got a survivor vibe from her.
That one can take care of herself, I
think.
Sundew picked up one of Sordell's wings
and dropped it, with a wet, wapping
sound.
Moon faced, self aggrandizing opinions to
the contrary.
But wait, how did you get him back here?
Cricket asked wonderingly.
Sundew was about the same size as
swordtail, maybe a little smaller.
There was no way the leaf wing could have
carried him across the bay and into the
cave, especially in the storm, and
especially if she was trying not to be
noticed.
Has anyone ever told you that you ask a
lot of questions?
Sundew snapped.
Oh yes, Cricket said, all the time.
Sundew crinkled her nose, which cricket
hoped was her trying not to laugh
expression.
Well, stop for a few heartbeats while I
catch my breath.
All right, cricket said.
Although wanting to know so many things
and not being able to find them out, felt
like small creatures buzzing under her
scales.
Can I get you some water for that?
She pointed to sundew's injury?
If you stay with Blue, I can go find the
underground river.
It can't be far if we can hear it so well
from here.
Maybe, she'd have a better chance of
getting answers if she did something
helpful first.
Yes, all right.
Sundew said.
At least it'll be quiet while you're
gone.
She pointed to one of her pouches.
There's a moss in there that can absorb
nearly a whole pond.
Take some of that with you.
Cricket dug out a talon full of moss and
bounded off into the caves.
It wasn't hard to make a mental map in
her head as she followed the sound of
water through the tunnels.
The river she found was more of a stream
although she guessed it would get
stronger if she kept walking down it
toward the sound of rapids.
But a little bit of water was all she
needed, so she dipped the clump of moss
in until it was well soaked, then headed
back to Blue's cave.
Sundew muttered, thank you.
As she took the moss and pressed it to
the cut on her shoulder.
Cricket hovered for a moment, wondering
if she could help more, but the green
dragon looked extra scowly and prone to
biting, so Cricket decided it would be
safer to back away for a little while.
I hope Luna's all right, she said
circling sword tail.
I wonder if she can swim.
At least Sortell was unconscious, and
therefore unlikely to snap at her.
Cricket started untangling the seaweed
from his wings, piling it up nearby, there
was a lot of it.
Was it edible?
She hadn't eaten in.
Hmm.
She wasn't sure, but it seemed like a
very long time.
She'd probably have to starve for another
day or 2 before she'd find gloppy, wet
seaweed at all appetizing, though.
How long ago did you find him?
she asked.
The pile of seaweed oozed and squished as
she added more to it.
Squelp, the work splaff.
Do you think he'll wake up soon?
I wonder if he'll stay to watch Blue come
out, or go off looking for Luna again.
Maybe she's stranded on another island in
the bay, so maybe she'll come back and
find us?
Should we leave a message in the beach
cave so she'll come down here?
But no, then Queen Wasps Scouts might see
it.
We sure don't want them finding us.
Hey, how did you find me?
Sundu growled.
You don't even know that you're doing
it.
Here, wake him up so you can bother
someone else.
She grabbed one of her pouches and threw
it to cricket.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, cricket said.
She had, in fact, forgotten about not
asking Sundo any more questions during
her trip back and forth to the river.
What's in here?
I mean, um, I'll figure it out.
She flipped open the pouch, which was
woven out of large, shiny waterproof
leaves, and found 3 neat compartments
with different bundles in each.
She hoped none of them contained alarming
insects, like the ones she'd seen sundew
fight dragons with.
Middle section, sundew said.
Crush one under his nose.
She threw a few berries in her mouth, and
lay down with her back to cricket, sword
tail, and blew.
Inside the middle compartment of the
pouch, wrapped in a soft covering of
cobwebs, cricket found a trio of weird
looking plants, each with shiny red
modeled with yellow streaks, and curved
in around itself.
So there was a hollow in the middle and a
point at one end.
Cricket carefully took one out, held it
under SwordTail's snout, and squished it
between our claws.
The scent that came out was unexpectedly
horrible, and strong enough to make her
own eyes water.
Sortail grunted, his face twitching in
distress.
Cricket held the plant in place as long
as she could, then ran across the cave to
throw it out into the passageway.
When she came back, Sortell was blinking
and trying to sit up, rubbing his eyes.
He unraveled a long strand of seaweed
from his legs, and managed to roll
upright.
His bewildered gaze took in the flame
silk cocoon, and then cricket.
Cricket wanted to help, but the truth was
Sortell made her a little nervous.
She knew he was Blue's best friend, and
Blue trusted him, but he was kind of loud
and mad, and she got the feeling he
didn't like her very much.
There had always been dragons in her
classes who didn't like her, because she
got the right answer, or made the class
run long with her questions, or because
she'd rather be reading a book than
playing one of their recess games.
Or because she understood equations
better than she understood other dragons
and sometimes she was just awkward and
out of step with everyone else.
And you know what?
Normal conversations were hard.
Didn't anyone else find them hard?
But Sortell disliked her entirely because
she was a hive wing.
She couldn't argue with that.
She couldn't help being a hive wing, and
she couldn't defend anything her tribe
had done, and it wasn't useful to keep
saying, but I'm not like them over and
over.
She just had to hope that eventually
she'd do enough to prove she could be
trusted.
Cricket glanced over at the resting leaf
wing, wishing she could talk to her
instead.
Sundew hated hive wings even more than
Swordtail did.
But she seemed okay with cricket, in her
own ferocious way.
Cricket suspected there was someone
almost as kind as blue under all sundew's
layers of thorns, although so far, she'd
only caught glimpses of her.
The leaf wing was also really smart, and
knew a 1000000 things about plants and
insects, that cricket had never learned
in school.
Cricket kind of wished she could open up
sundew's brain and read it like a book.
Especially all the parts about leaf wings
and where they'd gone, and how they'd
survived.
Sundew wouldn't answer any of those
questions, except with growling.
Where's Luna?
Sortell asked right away, raking another
talon full of seaweed off his neck.
I don't know, Cricket said.
I saw her silk get caught in the wind and
carry her out to sea, but Blue's
metamorphosis was starting, so I had to
bring him down here.
I don't know what happened next.
What did you see?
What happened to you?
Sortell rubbed his forehead as if it
hurt.
I tried to follow her, but the storm.
He took a step toward the corridor and
stumbled over a trailing piece of
seaweed.
I have to go find her.
Shouldn't you rest for a bit first?
Cricket suggested.
Sundew says it's pouring outside, and you
are just unconscious.
I'll be fine, he insisted.
Luna needs me.
He took another staggering step toward
the door.
Don't be a skunk cabbage, Sundew said
grumpily, turning her head to frown at
him.
You're entirely useless to any dragon in
the state you're in.
But he paused, struggling for words, and
then slumped, perhaps feeling the extent
of the battering the storm had given
him.
Look for her tomorrow, Cricket
suggested.
Or as soon as you're dry, or after you
sleep or whatever you want, but you'll be
much more likely to find her with well
rested wings and a clear head.
Don't you think?
Maybe we can do some calculations about
wind, speed, and currents, and figure out
where she might be.
It would help if I had some books
though.
I've never studied the ocean on this side
of the continent.
I wonder how buoyant Flame Soak is.
Do you know anything about it?
Swordtail sighed.
Although Cricket couldn't tell if it was
an exasperated sigh or a resigned sigh, or
just exhaustion.
Not much, he said.
He turned away from the door, limped over
to Blue's cocoon, and touched it lightly
with his talons.
Poor Blue.
Was he, did he seem scared?
Maybe a little, Cricket said, but he was
very brave.
He was mostly worried about you and
Luna.
Sortow rubbed at his eyes.
That sucks.
I wish we'd been here for him.
She guessed they were both thinking the
same thing, that they hoped Luna would be
here when Blue woke up.
The glow of Blue's cocoon lit Swordtell's
face as he leaned down to study the
silken strands.
So I guess this means blues of flame sold
too, he said.
It looks like it.
Cricket agreed.
Good, said Sundew.
They both turned and blinked at her.
Good?
Why?
What does that mean?
Cricket asked.
It's useful, Sundu answered.
Our cause doesn't need another normal
boring, timid silk wing, but a flame
silk?
That's fantastic.
You think blue is going to be useful?
For the leaf wings?
Swartell said, in a dangerous voice.
How?
Cricket took an instinctive step closer
to the cocoon.
As though Blue might sense her protection
through the silk.
What do you think he could do?
Sundew flicked her wings back and tipped
her head.
A few 100 awesome, fiery things, she said
starting with the most obvious.
He's going to burn down all the hives for
us.
Chapter 3.
No way, Cricket cried.
Blue would never do that.
Burn down.
All the hives.
Swordtell echoed, sounding a little more
awestruck than cricket was comfortable
with.
Is that really your plan?
Cricket asked Sundoo.
She knew the leaf wings were here for a
reason, and she thought she understood
how angry they were at the hive wings, but
this was so much more violent than she'd
expected.
Did the leaf wings want to restart the
war?
Even after they lost so badly the last
time?
I thought you said you just wanted the
book.
Sundew stabbed the pouch with a book of
clear sight in it.
Yes.
When we thought the stupid thing would
tell us the future, instead, it's
completely useless.
So what else are we supposed to do?
Not burn down the hives?
Cricket suggested.
They're so big, Swartell murmured.
He gazed up at the ceiling, as though he
was imagining an entire city on fire.
Even Luna never suggested destroying a
whole hive.
You'd be starting the tree wars all over
again, Cricket said.
If you try to burn any of the hives, Queen
Wasp will send her whole army after you.
She's not the only one with an army, Sundu
said. scowling.
This time, we'll be ready.
The new tree wars will go very
differently, especially if we start with
burning the hive wings out of their
cities.
Are there that many leaf wings left?
Cricket wondered.
A whole army of them?
Blue won't help you burn cities, Cricket
said to Sundo.
She was sure of that.
He would never do anything to hurt
anyone.
Sordell gave her a strange look.
Excuse me, he said, but you barely know
Blue.
I'm the one who's been his best friend
basically his whole life.
Well, then, do you see him burning down
hives all across Pantala?
Cricket asked.
Maybe, if he had a good enough reason
Swartell muttered.
Exactly.
Sundew nodded, as though she believed any
dragon could be turned into a murderer
with the right motivation.
Cricket didn't believe that.
At least, she couldn't believe it of
blue.
She'd spent almost her whole life
watching her friends and family turn into
cold-eyed tools for the queen, doing
things they'd never do if they had the
choice.
Blue was the absolute opposite of all
that.
He had free will.
And with it, he always chose to be kind
to do the right thing.
Didn't he?
In the 5 days you've known him?
A voice like sword tails whispered in her
head.
You think you know this dragon now?
Because you hid together?
Freed sword tail, broke into the temple
and stole the book?
Does he always do the right thing?
Or could it be that you just think that
the right thing is whatever he chooses to
do?
What if he thinks burning down hives is
the right thing to do to save his tribe?
Is that why you came back here?
Instead of going to your parents?
She asked Sundu, trying to shake off her
doubts.
You came for blue?
Yes?
Sundoo shrugged.
I'd rather have Luna.
She got so excellently mad about the book
of clear sight that I'm sure she'd help
us.
I take her with me to burn the world down
any day, but if we don't have Luna, we
need blue.
We'll have Luna, Sortell blurted.
She's coming back.
I'll find her.
He paced agitatedly from the cocoon to
the door and back again.
Sundu crinkled her nose, and drew her
tail out of the splatter zone from the
seaweed still dangling off him.
Blue will help you, but not by hurting
other dragons.
Cricket said stubbornly.
How would burning down all the hives help
the leaf wings anyway?
Also, there's a problem.
Even if Blue or Luna agreed to help you
Sortell chimed in, one flame silk can't
burn down a whole hive, let alone all 9
of them.
Well, he can try, Sundew said.
Or we start with Wasp Hive, and then use
those buried flame cells to help with the
rest.
We have to do something.
Whatever takes out as many hive wings as
we can.
Sundew, Cricket cried.
How can you say that?
That's my tribe.
I know some of them are terrible, but you
don't really want to kill all of them, do
you?
Now sundew was scowling so ferociously
that cricket could almost see sparks
coming out of her wings.
Her claws dug into the stone below her.
Why not?
That's exactly what they tried to do to
us.
I know, but doesn't that make you see how
wrong it is?
Cricket said.
No, Sundu growled.
We didn't do anything to them.
They deserve it.
They deserve to be wiped out.
Every single hive wing.
She frowned and dropped her gaze to the
pout with a book of clear sight in it.
Except you, but you're different.
What if I'm not the only one who's
different?
Or what about the little dragonettes?
Cricket said desperately.
It's been so long since the tree wars.
So many hive wings weren't even alive
back then, or what about the ones who
refused to fight?
There were protesters.
I know there were.
I read about them.
There were hive wings who tried to say no
to Queen Wasp.
There were some who wanted to help the
leaf wings and save the trees.
What about them?
She stopped suddenly.
Struck by a thought that she couldn't
believe she'd never had before.
How could there have been protesters?
Wouldn't Queen Wasp have shut them down
with her mind control?
She wouldn't have allowed dissent during
her war?
She would never have let anyone disagree
with her?
So, how did they?
Were they like me?
Why couldn't she control them?
Protesters?
Sundu scoffed, shouting enthusiastic
rhymes of the sky while their friends
slaughtered us.
Maybe that would have been useful if
they'd kept it up, but they all vanished
by the end.
Not a single high wing objected when the
last tree was cut down.
Maybe they couldn't.
Cricket's mind was racing now.
Maybe the queen had them all in her power
by then.
Did she get rid of any dragons who
couldn't be controlled?
Or was it possible?
Wasp hadn't been born with her mind
control powers.
Had they come to her sometime during the
war?
Personally?
I vote yes for burning down the hives.
Sortell offered suddenly.
I think Luna will be all for it.
If we can't convince Blue.
Cricket whirled toward him.
Haven't you thought about this at all?
Imagine a hive burning.
Who dies first?
She pushed her glasses up, wishing she
didn't sound so nervous and shaky.
Silkwing dragonette sore tail.
They're the ones who won't be able to fly
to safety.
Innocent, wingless dragonettes in their
eggs and cocoons and schools and parks
and in your webs.
The webs are connected to the hives.
If the cities burn.
So do your homes.
Most of the high wings will escape and be
fine.
But how would you save all the little
silk wings?
SoraTail stared down at his claws, looking
pale.
Killing off all the hive wings, or trying
to, won't solve anything, Cricket said to
Sundo.
It'll just start another war that'll be
even bloodier than the last, and this
time, Queen Wasp will hunt you to the
very end of the continent to make sure
you're gone.
And maybe all the silk wings too, if she
thinks some of you were in on it.
She won't kill us, Swordtell said
bitterly.
She needs our soak and our fire.
We're valuable resources.
She can make your lives worse though.
Cricket pointed out.
Sortell seized a talent full of seaweed
and threw it against the wall with a damp
splat.
He stomped on her neat pile again and
again, flattening it into a dark morass
like crushed eels and bleeding squids.
I just want to hurt them, he said.
I want them to feel what it's like to be
powerless.
I want them to be stabbed with nerve
toxins and have their loved ones ripped
away.
Yes, I want them to watch their homes
burn to the ground.
Sundew growled.
I want them to feel in their souls what
they've done to us.
Sortell turned to the leaf wing.
I'm in, he said.
Whatever you want me to do, I'll follow
you.
Cricket buried her face and her talons.
They were right, but they were also
wrong.
She needed blue.
He was the one who understood Dragon
Hearts.
He'd know how to reach them.
All she knew was chemistry and biology
and math, and botany.
How could she stack a pile of scientific
logic up against their justifiable anger
and hope to convince them?
Wait.
There was something Blue had said.
The queen, she said suddenly, looking
up.
That's it.
She's the problem, just like Blue said, we
have to start with her.
Or end with her. sundew said, or get to
her in the middle. whenever it's most
convenient to set her on fire, or bury
her alive, or feed her to vampire ants.
No, no, that's not what I mean, Cricket
said.
Queen Wasp is the heart of the problem, or
like the brain, I guess.
She controls the whole tribe.
You saw her do it in the temple.
You'll never have a chance as long as
she's out there. inside everyone's
minds.
And more important, you'll never know
which high wings might be on your side if
they could be.
Swordtail snorted, and Sandu gave him a
right as if, look.
They might be, Cricket insisted, like the
librarian.
Remember how she helped us as soon as she
was free of Queen Wasp?
My sister would too, if she had the
choice, but none of them has a choice
right now.
If you can shut down the queen's mind
control, you'll see who they really are.
I think you'll find more allies than you
realized you had.
I hope.
I hope there are good hive wings.
Clear sight.
Please let there be good hive wings
underneath what we can see.
Shut down the mind control.
Sundew said thoughtfully.
That would be useful.
Is there a way to do that?
Cricket side.
I don't know.
I've been looking for an explanation for
it practically my whole life.
Why doesn't it affect me?
Whatever is wrong with me.
Can we do it to other hive wings?
There's nothing wrong with you.
Swartell said.
He sat down by the door, folding his
wings back.
The orange streaks on his scales
reflected the flame silk glow like
distant suns.
We have to figure out what's right with
you and wrong with everyone else in your
tribe.
Oh, wow.
Maybe he doesn't completely hate me after
all.
Can't the leaf wings do that instead?
Cricket asked Sundoo.
Wouldn't it be better to break the mind
control instead of starting a new war?
It's a very sweet and silk wingish plan
but how?
Sundew demanded.
Aren't you the smartest dragon around?
Who else would know if you don't?
Sortail jumped to his feet and stared at
them.
Yes?
Sundew said, when the pause got awkward.
I'm not sure, he said excitedly, but I
think the chrysalis has a committee
working on this.
The what?
Sundu said sharply.
He bounced on his talons for a moment
looking torn.
I'm not supposed to tell anyone about
them, he said at last.
That was the most important rule.
But then Io told Blue, and he told you, he
said to Cricket.
So.
He didn't tell me much, she said
remembering the soft brush of her wings
against blues scales in the dark, the
quiet vibration of his voice whispering
are you with a chrysalis?
The shiver that had gone down her spine
as she wondered what the chrysalis was?
And how many other secrets this beautiful
blue dragon knew, and whether he'd stay
and tell her everything, and be her
friend?
She'd felt as though she'd just found a
new book, something she'd been desperate
to read her whole life, without even
knowing it existed.
I'd really like to know more.
Sortell hesitated, glancing at sundew.
I'm sure they'd want to know about the
leaf wings, but they'd want to know
before I told you about them.
I wish I knew what Luna would do right
now.
She'd tell us everything.
Sundew said promptly.
Cricket laughed, and Sundu gave her a
sideways approving glance.
All right, Swartell said, nodding at
Sundew.
I said I was with you after all.
I think you can change everything for
us.
He took a deep breath.
The chrysalis is a secret organization of
silk wings, who are fighting for our
freedom.
That was exactly the thrilling, stirring
answer cricket had imagined.
Secret freedom fighters in the hives, she
thought.
Dragons who risk their lives to help
others.
But Sundew looked skeptical.
Fighting, she said.
Silk Wings doesn't match.
Some of us can fight, Swartell said
bristling.
Some of us care about what's happened to
our tribe.
What do they do?
Cricket asked.
How do they keep it all secret?
I mean, they must be amazing.
I've never heard anything about silk
wings fighting back or any kind of
underground rebellion.
Hmm, sundew grunted.
Maybe because they don't actually do
anything.
They do.
I'm sure they do.
I don't really know what, though.
Sore towels shifted on his feet.
My sister and I just joined them
recently.
We haven't been given a mission or
anything yet.
They said to wait for further
instructions after Luna got her wings.
Luna was kind of the main contact
person.
She's the one who found them.
But you could find them again?
Sundew demanded.
I think so, Swartell said.
Luna could.
If I find Luna.
Even if you don't, Sundew said.
When Blue comes out of that cocoon, we're
going looking for this chrysalis of
yours.
She turned to cricket.
We'll compare their notes and yours and
see if we can find an answer to the mind
control thing.
Thank you, Cricket said.
Don't get too excited, Sundu warned.
Setting your whole tribe on fire is still
my preferred option.
But she listened to me.
They both did.
There's still a chance I can stop them
from starting a new war and save my
tribe.
Or at least save Katy did, she thought
anxiously.
So, we wait for Blue.
Cricket rested her talons on his cocoon
feeling the warmth spread through her
scales.
I'd better go talk to my parents, Sundu
said with a sigh.
She started looping all the pouches
around herself again, wrinkling her snout
as the dampest ones squished against her
scales.
They're probably wondering where I've
disappeared to with a book, and why I'm
letting you lot interfere with my great
destiny.
Cricket tilted her head at sundew.
What great destiny?
The leaf wing waved her wings
expressively.
You know, saving the world, fiery
vengeance, so on and so forth.
Everything they raised me to do?
They are not going to be excited about
postponing their war so they can sit
around for several days, waiting for a
silk wing to wake up.
Weren't they sitting around in that
greenhouse before they met him?
Cricket pointed out.
I thought leaf wings were supposed to be
good at acting like great patient trees.
I'll tell them that, Sundew said with a
grin, settling the last pouch in place.
I'm sure it'll help.
Cricket noticed, with disappointment, that
Sundew was taking the book of Clearsight
with her.
She could understand why, though.
The leaf wings had gone to a lot of
trouble to get it.
They weren't about to leave it in the
talons of a hive wing again.
Even a hive wing who'd helped them.
And I'll go look for Luna again.
A piece of seaweed slid free from sore
tail's horns as he glanced out at the
stone passageways.
Cricket tried not to look too
disappointed that they were both leaving
her alone again.
After keeping her company for such a
short time, the boredom of the quiet cave
loomed ahead of her once more.
Will you be back soon?
She said to Sundu, hoping she didn't
sound completely pathetic.
Yeah, don't worry, Sundoo said.
What I do is up to me, not my parents.
She hesitated for the briefest moment
like she was about to say something
else.
On this mission anyway.
Cricket wondered what the leaf wing
wasn't saying.
Was there something in her life that her
parents did control?
Maybe Sundew's not as free as she seems
to be.
Can one of you bring back food?
Cricket asked.
I mean, for blue?
He'll be hungry when he comes out, won't
he?
After 5 days in there?
Sortell nodded.
I'd never been so hungry, he said.
I'll find something for him.
What do silk wings eat?
Sundew said, starting toward the
tunnels.
Let me guess.
Rainbows and honey and starlight.
Yes, to honey, I think.
Cricket said.
She raised her voice as sundew's tail
disappeared through the gap.
Oh, and while you're out there, if you
happen to see any books, I would love
something to read.
She wasn't entirely sure.
But something like the sound of sundew
laughing came echoing back from the
walls.
Chapter 4.
Is it now?
Cricket asked.
Is it happening?
Is that a sign?
What does that mean?
If you don't turn off your beehive
brain?
I'm going to stick a sleep flower up your
snout.
Sundew said crossly.
Nothing is happening.
It's looked exactly like that all day.
She scowled down the pouch she'd been
trying to mend, with a strand of sword
tail silk.
No, it hasn't, Cricket protested, circling
Blue's cocoon.
Look, this end is kind of bulging and
crinkling, like it's about to split
open.
Right, sword tail?
Don't you think so?
Sure, he said, sleepily, without lifting
his head or opening his eyes.
She knew he'd spent the last 4 days
flying and searching and scouring every
island in Dragonfly Bay, snatching sleep
only in brief moments back in the cave.
And she knew that not finding Luna was a
huge disappointment, and they should be
very worried, and making grave faces, and
muttering ominously.
But seriously, Blue was about to come out
of his cocoon.
This was an extremely momentous
occasion.
Mostly because she'd get to see his
wonderful face again, but also a little
bit because she'd finally get to leave
this cave.
Hey, Blue, she said, to the shimmering
blue purple shape beneath the silk.
Can you hear me?
We're here.
We can't wait to see your wings.
I have so many questions.
What is it like in there?
Do you remember any of it?
Is it like a really long sleep?
How do your wings feel?
For the love of trees.
Sundew growled.
All right.
I was afraid to share this because I know
you're going to freak out, but if you
promise to be quiet until blue comes out
I'll tell you about how I saw one of your
reading monkeys this morning.
What?
Cricket nearly flew through the ceiling.
You did?
Sundo, really, truly?
And you're just telling me this now?
She'd been so quiet and careful every
time she crept around the caves, hoping
to run into one of the tiny creatures.
She couldn't believe it was Sundew who'd
seen one instead.
Yes, because of that, Sundoo said
pointing at her.
That face you're making, as if I found a
staircase to the moons instead of just
another weird animal, calm down or I
won't tell it.
I'm calm, Cricket said.
She realized she was bouncing on her
front talons and forced herself to sit on
her tail and stay still.
So totally calm.
I already regret this, Sundew said.
All right, but no questions.
Cricket clamped her talons over her snout
and nodded.
Sundew threw the torn leaf pouch across
the cave and picked up a bundle of
berries, which she started sorting as she
talked.
This morning, I went down to the cavern
where my parents and I 1st started
digging to wasp hive. sundew started.
I've been checking it regularly to make
sure the hive wings didn't follow our
tunnel from the flame silk cavern.
I figured I'd blocked it up pretty well
but safer to be sure.
How did you block?
Oops, sorry.
Cricket corrected herself quickly at
Sundew's glare.
Our hole was still completely filled in
but as I scouted the perimeter of the
cave, I found another much smaller hole
in the wall.
I decided to spy on it for a while, in
case anything edible came out.
Cricket wasn't sure why she had been
surprised to discover that leaf wings
were carnivores.
It fit with a bloodthirsty, violent
picture of them that Queen Wasp had
painted over the last half century, and
yet, in her own heart of hearts, and
maybe because of the beautiful drawings
of them in the oldest books, she'd
somehow imagined a tranquil green tribe
sharing sweet potatoes and cranberries
across the treetops.
So the 1st time sundew brought back a
pair of headless pigeons and devoured
hers in 2 bites, Cricket had been rather
startled.
And vegetarian sword tail had been openly
horrified.
Finally, sundew went on, I heard a tip
tap patter kind of noise.
I squinted at the hole and saw a little
head poke out.
It was just like the one you described
from under the savannah, fluffy black for
on its head, scraps of silver, silk, and
gray fur on its body, hairless, long
brown paws.
Perfect for holding books.
Cricket breathed.
This one didn't have a book.
Sundew pointed out, it had a stick with a
bit of fire on the end of it.
Where did...
I mean, um, I wish I knew where that came
from, Cricket said quickly.
The one she'd seen had had a fire too.
Did the reading monkeys have access to
flame silk somehow?
Anyway, it saw me, shrieked like a snake
bit panther, and ran away before I could
eat it, Sundew said grumpily.
But you wouldn't have, Cricket said
right?
You wouldn't eat something that can read
right, sundew?
I'm going to need a little more proof
they can do that before I start giving up
on prey, Sundew said.
But really, I wouldn't eat something
you're so completely obsessed with
because I know I'd never hear the end of
it from you.
Well, if I have to annoy you into
protecting cool new species, then that's
what I have to do, Cricket said nobly.
It's so unfair you saw one instead of
me.
You're so lucky.
Sundew rolled her eyes.
That's me, the luckiest dragon.
A tearing sound came from the cocoon.
Soartell leaped to his feet and joined
Cricket, crouching by the end with a rip
in it.
I was right, she whispered to him.
I knew it was about to happen.
It's happening.
Do you remember your metamorphosis?
Is there anything we should do when he
comes out?
Just give him some space, Sortell said.
His wings twitching, and his eyes fixed
on the shape of claws poking through the
silk.
He'll want to breathe for a moment, and
then eat something.
He swept the pile of fruit they had
gathered closer with his tail.
Cricket wished she had her notebook.
She'd never seen a metamorphosis before
and the books were always frustratingly
vague about silkwing details.
If she could take notes, maybe one day
she could write a paper about what it
looked like, and how it worked, and every
step of the process.
No.
I'll never get to do that.
I'm not going to be a published
scientist.
There's no normal hive wing life ahead
for me.
Unless, what if we defeat Queen Wasp, then
what happens?
Could the hive wings and leaf wings and
silk wings all start living in harmony?
Sharing the hives, planting food
publishing books, going to school
together?
Cricket glanced over at sundew, and felt
like the weight of one of the moons was
settling on her wings.
The leaf wings aren't going to forgive
us.
How can we ever move on?
As though we didn't try to wipe out the
leaf wings or dominate the silk wings.
How can they ever trust us or want to
live alongside us again?
After what we've done.
She couldn't imagine a path from sundew's
anger or her plan to wipe out the hive
wings, to a world in which the 3 tribes
lived in peace.
She'd been trying for days.
But her thoughts kept circling back to
the mind control.
As far as she could see, her only hope
for avoiding a war, was to convince
Sundew that hive wings with free will
would be on the leaf wings side.
Which, if she was honest with herself, she
wasn't at all sure of.
A familiar purple snout burst through the
silk, shaking filaments off his horns.
Cricket held her breath, as Blue wriggled
and shoved and slid out onto the stone
floor, kicking his shredded cocoon away
from him.
He struggled free, and finally stood for
a moment with his head bowed, taking deep
breaths, and then he looked up, met
Cricket's eyes, smiled, and spread his
wings.
Cricket wondered if her smile could lift
her through the ceiling.
Blue's wings were glorious, shimmering
purple and blue like sapphires and
violets tumbled together.
He was glorious.
She knew she loved more than his
beautiful scales. and his lovely face.
She loved his kindness, and his sweetness
and his sense of humor, and the way he
thought about other dragons so deeply, and
the fact that he seemed to have no idea
at all how handsome he was.
But oh my goodness, she also really loved
his lovely face, Cricket, he said, in a
hoarse voice.
You stayed.
Of course I did, she said.
Thank you. he said, and her heart felt as
if it might burst.
I bet that was.
He paused and thought for a moment.
Hmm, boring.
She laughed.
Just a little.
Can he see how much I adore him?
Am I too obvious?
I wish I knew what he feels.
Sortel stepped forward and offered a leaf
cup full of water.
Blue took it gratefully, and drank the
whole thing.
Nice wings, Swartell observed.
Not as handsome as mine, of course, but
pretty cool.
See?
I told you metamorphosis wasn't that
bad.
Blue flicked his friend's tail with his
own.
I can't believe it's over, he said.
After all those years of worrying about
it.
He stretched his wings as wide as they
would go, and wrinkled his snout, as
though he was trying to stop smiling.
Remember how Luna and I were waiting for
you when you came out?
With a giant box of honey drops, and
Luna's weird banana mash cake.
Sortell said, grinning.
You did a really good job of pretending
to like it, Blue said.
He studied his wings, which looked shiny
and damp in a brand new kind of way.
I guess the one upside of being fugitives
she can't make one of those for me.
His eyes searched the cave.
Hey, sundew.
Hey yourself, Silkwing, Sundu said
gruffly.
You sure took your time growing those
flappers.
Cricket wondered whether Blue could tell
that the leaf wing was actually happy to
see him, or whether it was only cricket
who was getting used to the mostly hidden
expressions under sundew scows.
So, are you actually a flame silk?
Can you make fire?
I feel like I can.
Blue held out its talons, and glowing
flame spiraled from each wrist into
smoking curls of light on the floor.
Sundew inspected them, nodded approvingly
and scooped them into a small stone jar
from one of her pouches.
While she did that, Blue took a short
shuddering breath and looked at Sore
Tail.
And by the expression on his face, Cricket
could tell that he'd already guessed the
worst.
Luna, he said anxiously.
I'm sorry, Blue, Sortell said.
His wings drooping.
I can't find her.
I've looked and looked.
Blue was quiet for a long moment.
Cricket took a step closer to those
iridescent wings, and gently twined her
tail around his.
He seemed so much bigger suddenly.
If you haven't found her, Blue said, and
she must still be alive.
We'd feel it if she wasn't, don't you
think?
Maybe she's hiding somewhere and hasn't
made it back yet.
She'll find us again.
I'm sure she will, swordtail.
She's probably out there worrying about
us, twice as much as we're worrying about
her.
Well, she's not finding us here, Sundew
said, standing up.
She dropped her sorted berries into
sections of a leaf bag and put it on, then
started assembling all her other pouches
around her.
In some careful order, Cricket hadn't
mapped out yet.
We've already stayed way too long.
It's a miracle the hive wings searching
the coast haven't found us yet.
It's not a miracle, Swordell said.
It's you.
You hid the entrance to this tunnel
really well.
I've seen high wing guards walk right
past it as they hunt through the cave.
I've gotten lost like 8 times coming back
from the bay because it's so hard to
spot.
He hand a blue, a talon full of kumquats
and sliced yams.
I don't know how she did it.
Wait until you see what she did with the
vines and the moss?
It's kind of amazing.
Sunday made the face.
She always made.
When cricket or sore tail said something
nice about her.
As though her expressions had no practice
reacting to compliments.
So they just threw out a few spasms, and
then went back to scowling.
Well, it won't last forever, she said.
Let's get to a hive and find the
chrysalis.
The chrysalis.
Blue echoed between bites, looking at
sword tail.
We'll explain on the way, cricket
offered.
So what?
Back to Wasp Pive?
Sundew asked.
Blue shuttered.
Um, is that our only option?
It's not the best place to find the
chrysalis.
Swartell said.
I mean, it's the most dangerous hive.
Swarming with soldiers.
I'm not even sure they have any members
there.
Sundew gave him a hard luck.
I thought you said they were in all the
hives.
I think they are, he said, but let's try
another one, just to be safe, is my
suggestion.
Where are we, exactly?
Cricket said.
She took sundew's discarded leaf pouch
flattened out one side of it, and flies
to rough map of Pentala into the thick
pale green surface with her claws.
We came from wasp hives, up here.
She stabbed a little hole in the spot
where a wasp hive would be on the map.
Kind of here.
Swordtail said, pointing to a spot on the
coast of Dragonfly Bay, away south of
Wasp Hive.
So, let's think.
The next closest hives are these three.
Cricket poked 3 holes in the map.
Yellow jacket hive, bloodworm hive.
Or jewel hive.
She hesitated, feeling an old familiar
twist, like thorns around her heart.
What is it?
Blue asked, touching her shoulder.
Why does jewel hive make you sad?
It's nothing really, she said.
Just, that's where my mother moved, when
she left us.
Cricket could remember that day really
clearly.
She'd been 3 years old.
Katy did had been 12.
But still living at home and without a
partner, chosen or assigned.
It had felt completely out of the blue to
her.
Like a hive suddenly collapsing for no
reason.
Mother had been standing with all her
belongings at the door when they returned
from school, her books being loaded into
baskets by a pair of sturdy silk wings.
She looked faintly annoyed that they had
returned before she could disappear.
Katy did had cried, but cricket
couldn't.
It was all too confusing.
She didn't understand why they couldn't
continue as they always did. with her
mother ignoring them all.
Why did she have to go to a whole other
hive to do that?
I didn't know your mother left, Blue said
sympathetically.
That's not an option for silk wings
Sortell pointed out.
At least not by choice.
Nobody gets to leave the partner they're
paired with, unless Queen Wasp tells them
to.
Hive Wings have to get her approval first
Cricket said.
I guess mother really wanted to get away
from us.
If she was willing to go through the
whole separation request process.
When she left, she said, across the
continent still isn't far enough from you
horrible grubs, but it'll have to do.
Whoa.
Sundu hissed through her teeth.
She sounds charming.
Oh, cricket, Blue said.
How could anyone say that to her own
dragonette?
She had been trying to leave for a
while.
It turns out, Cricket said, fiddling with
the edge of the leaf.
But I mean, it doesn't matter.
It's not like we'll run into her.
It's a big hive.
Super busy.
I kind of know my way around from the 2
times we visited her, so maybe that'll be
helpful.
Blue rested one of his wings alongside
hers, like a warm, azure wave of comfort
if she wanted it.
She liked that he didn't push her to talk
about it more.
What's the plan?
She asked Sundu.
How do we get into the hive if everyone's
looking for us?
With punching and biting?
Sortell suggested, hopefully, and maybe
some venomous caterpillars?
I like the way you think, Sundew said.
But they're centipedes, dingbat.
Or Blue interjected.
Is there a way to sneak in where nobody
gets hurt?
And nobody gets caught by hive wing
guards?
Cricket agreed.
She looked down at her map again.
Jewel Hive.
Hmm.
What, what, what?
Sundew demanded.
Lady Jewel is a little different from the
other hive rulers, cricket explained.
Do you guys know anything about her?
She's Wasp's cousin, not her sister, for
one thing, and she's famous for her.
I guess love of art is the best way to
describe it.
Oh, right, Swordtail said, lighting up.
Luna was always talking about how she
wanted to move to Jewel Hive if we
could.
She kept going on about the art scene and
the glitter bazaar.
The light went out of his eyes, and he
looked down at his claws.
She would love to see the glitter
bizarre.
Maybe the chrysalis will know something.
Blue said to him, maybe she found her way
to them.
Or maybe they'd know if she's back in the
Flameso Cavern.
Sortell looked hopeful for the 1st time
in days.
That's true.
If she ended up in a hive, that's who
she'd look for.
He flicked his tail back and forth.
We should go ask them.
Let's do that.
Let's go now.
Hang on.
What in Pantale is a glitter bazaar?
Sundu asked.
If it involves sparkles, the answer is
no.
I do not do sparkles.
Which was funny, Cricket thought.
Coming from a dragon with gold flex all
across her green scales.
Only a few sparkles, Cricket said, and I
think it might be our way in.
Chapter 5.
Cricket hadn't realized how nerve
wracking it must have been, for sore tail
and sun do to creep out of the cave onto
the beach every day.
You couldn't get a full view of the sky
until you were already exposed on the
sand.
If High Wings had been watching from the
cliffs, they would have spotted her
friends easily, even at night, with the
moons lighting up the ocean.
Raindrops pattered against her scales and
blurred her glasses as she stepped into
the open air for the 1st time in days
keeping her body close to the towering
cliff face.
They were lucky tonight.
Dark clouds covered most of the 3 moons
driving rain obscured at the sky, and the
fierce thunderstorm was probably keeping
most high wing scouts at home.
Of course, it meant flying to Jewel Hive
in that very thunderstorm.
But cricket, for one, would rather battle
the rain than another dragon.
Blech, poof, ugh.
Swordell muttered, shaking wet sand off
his talons and snout.
Sorry your 1st flying experience has to
be in this weather blue.
It's amazing.
Blue said.
I mean, from down here.
He lifted his face up to the rain and
held out his faintly glowing wrists.
Skittering rivulets ran like melted
amethysts along his wings.
She wasn't imagining it.
His wings were decidedly larger than
crickets.
It was a little intimidating, until he
turned and smiled at cricket.
His smile was still the same.
It still took up just as much space in
her heart.
I'm such a moon moth.
Didn't I laugh at dragons who said things
like that in my books?
You don't even know if he likes you back
because he seems to be just that sweet to
everybody.
Seriously cricket, snap to it.
You're trying to save your tribe and
avoid all out war right now.
And if Sortail is right about the
chrysalis, you could be this close to
solving your brain chemistry mystery.
Lead the way, Sundu said.
Nudging cricket.
I'll watch for hive wings, Sortail, you
keep an eye on Blue and his new wings.
Will do, Swartell said solemnly.
It was a shaky flight, punctuated by ear
splitting thunder and crackling bolts of
lightning overhead.
The rain battered Crickets wings and
blurred her glasses, and flew into her
eyes, so she could hardly keep track of
the coastline below her.
She was very, very glad they didn't have
far to go.
She knew her job was to lead the way to
Jewel Hive.
But she couldn't help twisting around to
keep an eye on Blue every few
heartbeats.
It was hard enough flying for the 1st
time, let alone doing it in a
thunderstorm.
The 1st time she'd flown in the rain, it
had been a training exercise at Terrarium
Academy, and it had been very annoying
not because of the weather, but because
of her classmate bombardier.
He was completely convinced that cricket
had a crush on him, and was always trying
to let her down gently.
When, in fact, cricket would have very
much liked to throw him through a wall.
She remembered trying to figure out how
to flick raindrops off her back wings.
Bombardier kept hovering around her
offering unnecessary suggestions.
I can figure it out myself.
She finally snapped at him.
You don't need to act self-confident with
me, he'd answered condescendingly.
It won't make me like you more, cricket.
I keep telling you, I'm not interested in
you in that way.
Neither am I. She tried to protest, like
she always did.
Of course.
He'd soothed her insincerely, and then
smug faced away while she wished she had
any cool hive wing powers to poison him
with.
Blue was the furthest opposite dragon
from bombardier that cricket had ever
met.
He had no idea how wonderful he was, and
he would never assume that somebody liked
him.
He always really wanted to know what
other dragons were feeling, no matter who
they were.
He seemed to have less trouble with a
storm than she'd feared.
His wings looked so new and shimmering
that she kept thinking the wind would
tear them right in half.
The blue beat them strongly and smoothly
as though he'd been flying forever.
Every time she turned to look at him, he
gave her his shy smile.
As though she had something to do with
the wind that lifted his wings.
Oh, Blue.
I won't let them use you to hurt any
dragons.
We'll figure out the mind control and
stop Queen Wasp, and then you can use
your flame silk to make the world a
better place instead of worse.
Soon, she could see the glowing lights of
Dual Hive up ahead.
Flame silk lanterns lit many of the
windows, and as they flew closer, she
caught glimpses of a bright party taking
place on one of the upper levels.
Dragons laughed and danced and whirled
orange gold scales and green jewels
flashing through a ballroom, hung with
vibrant scarlet, and cobalt silk
tapestries.
Cricket remembered hiding on the edges of
that ballroom while her mother danced.
At a party, neither she nor Katy did had
wanted to be dragged to.
But her mother never missed one of Lady
Jewel's parties.
Her best chance to get closer to the
ruler of her new hive.
Katydid had found a bubbly drink for them
to share that tasted like limes, and made
cricket sleepy.
The wasps on the tapestries had been dyed
a gold so bright, it hurt her eyes.
She missed Katy did.
When cricket flew off with blue, she
hadn't expected to be gone for so long
she hadn't thought about the possibility
that she'd never be able to go home again
that she might never see her sister again
but I'd still have gone, even knowing all
that.
I think I had to.
They arced around Jewel Hive and landed a
fair distance away, farther out on the
peninsula, at the top of a cliff, where
they could hear the sound of waves
roaring below, even through the storm.
Somehow, standing out in the rain felt
even harder than flying, as though
raindrops were trying to beat cricket
into the earth.
So there's the hive, Sundew shouted to
SwordTail.
Where do we go to find the chrysalis?
Cricket wasn't great at reading Dragon's
expressions, but she thought Swordell
looked decidedly nervous as he answered.
Well, we don't exactly find them.
We leave them a message, and they find
us.
Leave them a message how?
Cricket asked.
Where?
Um, he shook his wings and tail.
So, I'm kind of guessing?
I mean, I sort of know, but I wasn't
going to be the one who, I mean, I'm just
saying, this will be a lot easier if Luna
were here.
But she's not.
Sundew said.
Not yet, she amended, at the look on his
face.
You have to figure this out, Silkwing.
We can't wait for her.
Wait, why not?
Blue asked.
Can't we go hide somewhere new for a few
days, until we find her, and then decide
what to do?
The grass was soggy, and felt like dense
wet carpet under cricket's claws.
She blinked away raindrops and looked at
sundew.
No, Sundew said.
We've been waiting for you, you snoozy
silk wing.
She turned to Cricket.
My parents can't put their plans on hold
forever.
Lightning flickered deep in the clouds
reflecting waves of green fire in the
ocean.
Cricket felt the tremor of thunder rumble
through her bones.
What does that mean?
Cricket asked.
What plans?
How long do you think they'll wait?
Sundew huffed, and ripped up a muddy tuft
of grass, then carefully tucked it back
into the divot she'd made, and covered it
with her claws.
All right, she said.
Two days.
Two days?
Cricket cried.
That's it?
That's all the time we have to solve the
entire mystery of Queen Wasp's mind
control?
Or what?
Blue asked anxiously.
What happens in 2 days?
That's all I could get?
Sundew shouted back at cricket.
I tried, all right?
It was almost impossible.
It was like trying to push a tree back up
when it's already started falling.
Belladonna and hemlock don't think you
can do it.
So I'm sorry, but if I don't have some
kind of results for them by sunset in 2
days, they're going to the next phase of
their plan.
What are they going to do?
Cricket asked.
Blue looked paler and paler with each of
her questions.
Are they going to attack a hive?
Will it restart the tree wars?
What plan, sundo?
The leaf wing plan that is not for hive
wings to know about?
Sundew said sternly.
But it involves violence, and you're not
going to like it as much as this plan, so
we should get moving on this plan in
order to make sure that it's the one that
works.
Understand?
Sortell nodded.
Restart the tree wars?
Blue whispered, nearly drowned out by the
storm.
Cricket's heart was beating very fast.
She wanted to know the leaf wing plan.
She wanted to know how many leaf wings
were out there, and where they would
attack, and whether Katie did would be in
danger.
But the only thing she did know was she
wouldn't get those answers out of sundo
by asking for them now.
And at least she had a chance.
Two days, 2 days to find the answers and
stop the leaf wings.
All right, she said, trying to study her
breathing.
We can do this.
Let's think.
Soretail.
Where do you need to get to so you can
leave a message for the chrysalis?
A central feature. he said.
In Cicada Hive, it was the Salvation
Mosaic in the mosaic garden.
Does Jewel Hive have a salvation mosaic?
No.
Cricket shook her head.
He looked worried.
Does it have anything like that?
Cricket bowed her head and tried to
think.
Her visits to her mother hadn't exactly
involved fun tours of awesome hive
monuments, but maybe there was an answer
in something she'd read.
Her mind started ticking through books
about other hives, monuments to the
salvation, architecture and unifying
features, the history of hive building
Wasps, Sisters, and Lady Jewel.
There's the statue in the center of the
glitter bazaar, she said slowly.
That's a tribute to the salvation.
Or there's a garden at the top of the
hive, like the mosaic garden.
It doesn't have mosaics or historical
monuments, but it has a waiting pool and
a shrine to clear sight.
The garden, Swordtail said.
The statue, Sundew said at the same
time.
Really?
he said to her.
I think it would be in roughly the same
place.
Like geographically, don't you?
No, my revolution would be organized
around the symbolism, she said.
If it's in a meaningful place in one hive
I'd guess the chrysalis in the next hive
would choose a place with the same
meaning.
Hmm.
Sorte rubbed his face, trying
unsuccessfully to dry it.
I don't know.
I wish.
Luna we're here.
Yes, we know, Sundew said.
Okay, here's what we do.
Leave a message in both places.
Hope the chrysalis finds one of them.
And the hive wings don't, Blue said.
It'll be easiest to go to the Glitter
Bazaar first, Cricket suggested.
She pointed down toward Jewel Hive, at
the dark shapes that sprawled in a
scattered tangle around the bottom of
it.
We start on the outskirts, get our
disguises, and work our way in.
And pray to clear sight that we can do
this in 2 days.
Chapter 6.
The next morning dawned gray and
drizzly.
But at least the pouring rain had moved
out, along with the apocalyptic thunder.
One half of cricket was cold and damp
when she woke up, but the sigh that had
been pressed to blue while they slept was
warm.
He was still asleep, like a small sunlit
ocean between her and sword tail.
She put on her glasses, and looked up at
the thick silk web over them, and then
around for Sundew, who was gone.
Carefully Cricket disentangled her tail
from blues, and slid away from his
wings.
He murmured a sleepy complaint and rolled
closer to swordtail, who grunted and
flung one wing over him.
The silk web overhead was part of a vast
canopy that covered all the stalls of the
outer bazaar.
The lowlier shops that had spilled out of
the hive, when the glitter bazaar got too
big.
It wasn't great to have your stall
outside the hive during the rainy season
but at least the canopy helped keep the
wares mostly dry.
They'd hidden overnight in the musty
smelling back corners of a curtain shop
burrowing in between rolls of aquamarine
and silver silk.
Cricket crawled out of the fabric pile
and ducked into the main stall.
A web hung over the doorway, keeping out
most of the dim morning light, but a
flame silk lamp glowed softly in one
corner.
Sundew was stretching in the tiny space.
Morning, Cricket said.
She sidled up and joined Sundew's series
of exercises, like she had each morning
in the cave.
It was a little harder here, trying to
keep her wings from colliding with
sundews.
When did the dragons come?
Sundew asked, finishing her last
stretch.
She peeked out through the door web at
the hive, looming in the mist.
Jewel hive sleeps late, Cricket said
apologetically.
The balls sometimes go all night.
We won't see many hive wings before
midday.
Are all leaf wings early risers like
you?
Some of them.
This market must open sooner, though.
Sundew checked back in the other
direction, along the path through the
stalls.
Aren't some of these places run by Silk
Wings?
Most of the ones on the outside are
Cricket said, nodding.
We should find what we need now, and then
blend in with the crowd once it's busy
enough.
Sundew cast a wicked smile at the back of
the shop.
I'll wake the others, she volunteered
bounding away.
A moment later, Cricket heard Swordtell
Yelp.
Ow, unnecessary.
Followed by the unusual sound of sundew
laughing.
Cricket took a moment to peer out into
the market as well.
She'd walked through it with Katy did
once, but she didn't know the layout at
all.
Was there an order to the stalls?
Were they organized together by category
of items they sold, or scattered wherever
they'd happened to land?
From what she knew of Jewel Hive, she'd
guess scattered.
And she'd also guess that there wasn't a
map anywhere in the market, if one had
ever even been made.
Lady Jewel wasn't exactly known for
keeping her subjects organized.
Which is good for us.
This is probably the hive where we have
the best chance of going unnoticed
between the chaos of the dragons who live
here, and the undisciplined guards.
Then again, there wasn't really anywhere
they could go unnoticed.
If Queen Wasp decided to take over the
eyes of every dragon in Pantala.
But it had been 5 days since Luna and
Blue escaped the Flame Hill Cavern.
Cricket was hoping the search for them
might have quieted down, at least a
little bit.
Blue and Sore Tail emerged from the back
of the stall, yawning, with sundew behind
them, looking mischievously pleased.
You really take an unholy amount of
pleasure in ripping happy dragons out of
their peaceful slumbers.
Swartell said to her.
It's the best part of my day, she said.
A little tiny bit of vengeance every
morning.
Blue's expression was slightly trance
like, as though he'd slipped into a cloud
of trying to imagine what it was like to
be sundew.
We should hurry, Cricket whispered.
I'm not sure how long we have before the
1st silk wings arrive, and I don't know
how long it'll take to find what we want
in this place.
It's bigger than I remember.
They ducked under the door web, and
cricket led the way along the narrow
cluttered paths of the market.
All the stalls had their door webs or
curtains lowered, but it was easy to tell
what they sold by the merchandise that
spilled over the edges and hung from the
frames.
The group passed an instrument stall with
zebra hide drums and curved black metal
harps.
The next had a sign listing a selection
of fruit juices, and the one after that
featured curious flame silk lanterns
without the flame silk, shaped like
snails, or leopards, or birds in flight.
Totally disorganized, Cricket thought.
Each stall dropped wherever the shop
owner could grab a space under the
canopy.
It was unhelpful for their search.
But also kind of wonderfully free.
Everything in Cicada Hive was regimented
and orderly, in a way that cricket had
never quite fit into.
She wondered if her life would have been
easier growing up in Jewel Hive.
She also wondered how her inflexible
mother could stand it.
Oh, there, she cried, spotting a flare of
bright silk poking out under a curtain.
They hurried over, and she pushed through
into the dark stall, her eyes adjusted
slowly.
There were no flame silk lamps in here, or
at least, if there were, they were
empty.
Cricket squinted at the silk, draped and
folded on the shelves.
It was hard to see any colors or details
with the outer stall curtains down.
Here, Blue whispered.
He held out one talon, and a small twist
of silk spiraled out of his wrist onto
his palm.
It glowed there, like a miniature comet
caught in his claws, lighting up the
room.
So cool.
Thortail leaned toward it, and Blue moved
it out of his reach.
Careful, this will burn.
I'm the only one who can touch it
safely.
Flame silk doesn't burn you?
Cricket asked, surprised.
Even the kind in the lanterns?
How had she missed that in her reading?
My dad said it wouldn't.
After my metamorphosis.
Blue lifted the light toward the
ceiling.
So it illuminated all the colors around
them.
And this is the kind in the lanterns.
So be careful with it.
Sundew said, or else you'll set this
whole place on fire.
And maybe the hive too, she added
thoughtfully.
On 2nd thought, go ahead and wave it
around.
Cricket realized, a few moments later
that she should have been appalled by
that joke, but she was distracted by the
thought of how much she didn't know about
Flame Silk.
She wished she could stop for a day to
investigate all the different kinds of
flame silk blue could make now, and what
they could each do.
But we only have until sunset tomorrow to
stop a new war.
Fascinating scientific experiments would
have to wait.
I think this is what we want, she said
tugging a waterfall of sunflower yellow
silk off the wall.
She flung it over sundew's shoulders.
The leaf wing was the one who'd stand out
the most of all of them.
Her forest green scales might pass for a
silk wings at a glance, but those 2 wings
screamed, Leaf wing, arrest me.
The silk draped along sundew's back and
halfway down her tail. covering her wings
and most of her body.
Sundew twisted her neck to give it a
suspicious look.
What is this?
she asked.
What self-respecting dragon would wear
something that would tangle up their
wings like this?
It's a cape, Cricket said patiently, tying
the ribbons around Sundew's neck and
arranging the folds to cover her
shoulders.
My mother thought they were very
fashionable last time I saw her.
Oh, good.
A dragon we already know has excellent
judgment, Sundew muttered.
If you keep your wings folded in close
sore tail said. squinting at her.
And nobody accidentally pulls it off or
peaks underneath?
I'm still not sure it'll work.
Could a silkwing afford something like
this?
Blue asked, touching one of the garments
with his free talent.
And she doesn't have antennae.
Also, it's a little bright, Sundew said.
If I must wear something ridiculous, I'd
prefer it in black or dark green, or
midnight blue if absolutely necessary.
Nope, Cricket said.
Swatting sundoes talons away from the
nearest dark colored silk.
In Jewel Hive, everyone is devoted to
bright colors, lots of jewels, accessories
everywhere.
That's the only reason I think we have a
chance of sneaking in.
It's hard to notice anyone if everyone is
trying to stand out.
Unless we slink around in black, looking
boring, we have to match the glamour
around us.
Even the silk wings?
Blue asked.
Yes, Cricket said.
There's an ongoing competition here for
who can hire the prettiest silkwing.
Some of them don't even have to do
anything, except sit in parlors and
windows and porches and balconies, being
beautiful.
Sortail growled softly.
Dragons as decoration.
Maybe some of them like it, Blue
offered.
It sounds easier than smashing and
remolding tree stuff all day.
It sounds mind numbing, Sundew snorted.
You couldn't pay me to have a bunch of
hive wings stare at me all day long.
Cricket privately agreed with her.
She could only imagine sitting still for
that long if she had a really interesting
book to read.
Well, sorry, that's what you have to be
for today.
Cricket said, a very fancy silk wing.
She turned back to the other silks
wishing she knew how much detail Queen
Wasp had given out in the search for
them.
Did they all have to wear wing covering
capes?
Were veils still in fashion?
Cricket knew almost nothing about
accessories?
They were frowned upon at Terrarium
Academy.
She found 2 smaller capes for sword tail
and blue, in matching shades of rose gold
with sparkling indigo beetles embroidered
all over them.
Her hope was to have them all look so
bright and busy, that no one's eyes would
be able to completely land on them, or
notice the scales underneath.
These are kind of cool, Blue said
fighting a basket over to her.
Inside were several translucent scarves
and arm sheets woven with glittering
black markings.
Oh, wow, Cricket said. pulling one over
her forearm.
It looked like the glittering markings
were part of her scales.
As though she had extra lines and zigzags
of black over and around her natural ink
block patches.
If she wore several of these on her legs
tail, and neck, she would look more like
a black dragon with spots of yellow and
orange, then vice versa, which would
hopefully make it harder to recognize
her.
She pulled out a few more and started
putting them on.
How are we going to pay for all this?
Blue asked.
You eternally sweet idiot.
Swordtail said, poking him in the side.
We're already on the run from the law
remember?
So who cares if we steal a few capes?
We can't get in any more trouble than we
already are.
Blue winced.
I know, but that's not.
It's just, some dragon worked hard on all
this, and they probably need the money
for their family.
It's wrong to steal from them.
Oh, that, Swartell said with a sigh.
Well, I hope someone's hiding a small
fortune under one of your wings then.
Sundew said wryly.
I guess we could leave those 2 yams I dug
up yesterday.
Sordell said, with a wistful expression.
Your cape is probably worth a 100 yams
Cricket admitted.
What?
SwordTell protested.
This silly thing?
It doesn't even do anything.
Why is it so expensive?
Is it edible?
How much is flame silk worth?
Blue asked.
Could I leave them this?
He held out the strand of fire.
Cricket hesitated.
Yes.
Flame Silk is pretty expensive.
That would cover all of this, I think
especially since it's brand new, and
should last them a whole moon cycle, but
blue, someone will figure out it had to
be you who left it, don't you think?
Who else would have bright new flame silk
like that?
Maybe somebody ordered it from WASPI.
Like your school librarian does, Blue
said.
It feels like the right thing to do.
Arrr!
You are such a silk wing, Sundu groaned.
This is the worst idea.
It's basically leaving evidence behind.
No one will guess it's from the little
dragonette, who ran away from cicada
hive.
Blue said.
He slipped the strand into the lantern on
the ceiling, and light filled the stall.
It could have come from an early morning
customer.
He paused and rubbed his wrists with a
small smile.
It's kind of awesome, knowing I have
something everyone needs.
I could give it away to anyone, anytime I
want.
Or Thordell observed, you could set your
enemies on fire anytime you want.
Sundew pointed one claw at sword tail.
You, she said, are growing on me.
Blue shook his head and met Cricket's
eyes with a faintly sick expression.
She guessed he was trying to imagine
being a dragon who could set another
living creature on fire, and that it was
beyond his abilities.
She brushed one of his wings with hers.
I like you as you are.
The dragon who gifts fire to those who
need it.
This doll is just silk, Cricket said
glancing around.
Come on, we need some jewelry too.
Jewelry?
Sundu complained.
But even she had to admit, a little while
later, in a shrouded jewelry stall, that
the long necklaces of little gold leaves
cricket found were kind of cool, and
she'd maybe be all right with wearing
just one of them.
She was less pleased with cricket's other
discovery, the thing cricket had really
been looking for.
A gold and jade headdress with so many
points and squiggles and sparkles that it
hid the fact that sundew had no
antennae.
The leaf wing carried on, as though
cricket was attaching actual snakes to
her head, but the end result was quite
dazzling and entirely distracting.
This is the worst, Sundew grumbled
glaring into a mirror.
Well, my tribe would fall over laughing
at me right now.
I'm sure they'd understand, that
sometimes you have to sacrifice your
dignity for a higher purpose.
Sortell joked.
Sundew swatted at him, and he darted out
of the way.
In the same stall, they found bejeweled
head coverings for blue and sword tail
that hung like masks of dewdrops around
their eyes, and a bright blue veil shawl
tiara thing, that mostly hid cricket's
face and glasses, plus was also gaudy
enough that sundew was a little
mollified.
At least I'm not the only one who looks
like an exploding peony. she said
surveying the others.
I'm surprised these are allowed, Blue
said to Cricket.
Trailing his claws along the dangling
leaves that ornamented a row of
bracelets.
I would have thought leaves fit under the
rules against trees.
Maybe in cicada hive.
Lady Jewel allows her dragons to fly a
little closer to the edges of the rules
than most hive leaders, Cricket pointed
out.
What rules against trees?
Sundew asked sharply.
We, um, Blue faltered under her outraged
glare.
We are forbidden to put any trees in our
art.
No tree sculptures, no trees in the
background of our paintings, no planting
trees in our terrariums, cricket said
thinking wistfully of her secret little
tree back at school.
Would anyone take care of it now that she
was gone?
Some fruit trees are allowed in the
greenhouses, but only with special
permission, and strictly under
supervision by Queen Wasp, no tree
planting, or anything that might make a
tree grow in the savannah.
Sundew picked up a rope of pearls, wound
it around her front talons, and snapped
the cord with one violent tug.
Pearls flew everywhere, clattering over
the countertops.
Let's go.
She growled at cricket.
With a whirl of her saffron silk cape, she
stalked out into the market.
Whoa, Sortell said, looking up from a
basket of turquoise earrings near the
back of the stall.
Did she just get even angrier?
Or did I imagine that?
Definitely angrier, Cricket said.
I don't know why though.
Do you, Blue?
I think, I think maybe erasing trees, even
from our art, is like Queen Wasp, trying
to wipe out the leaf wings all over
again.
Blue said.
I mean, maybe that's how it feels to sun
do.
I never thought of it like that.
Cricket said.
She'd always thought it was a silly
rule.
Trees were just another plant, and plants
were useful for lots of things, and why
not have more if they could?
She'd never seen them as a symbol of the
long gone leaf wings, but now she
realized that Queen Wasp must think of
them that way.
Blue left 3 little coils of flame silk
and stone vase on the counter and ducked
outside with sword tail.
As cricket started to follow them, she
heard a small clattering sound behind
her.
Probably a mouse, she told herself.
But she edged back toward the counter
with her heart thumping.
If there was another dragon in here, who'd
seen them putting on their disguises, or
blue, creating flame silk from his
wrists?
The baskets of jewelry behind the counter
were still and quiet.
Nobody could possibly be hiding back
there.
There weren't any corners or shadows big
enough for a dragon.
But then something moved.
Something darted from one basket to
another.
Something smaller than a dragon, but
bigger than a mouse, something with dark
fur and swift paws.
A reading monkey.
I really need a better name for them.
Cricket leaned over the counter, staring
at the basket where it had disappeared.
A long moment past, and then a small head
poked out and stared back at her.
Alert brown eyes, a sweet face, narrower
than a monkey's, and furless, except for
the top of its head.
Don't be afraid, Cricket said softly.
I just want to know what you are.
The creature gazed at her.
Was that curiosity in its eyes?
Did it want to understand her too?
Cricket.
Swordell shouted, sticking his head back
into the stall.
The little animal jumped, and vanished
behind the baskets.
Dragons are coming from the hive.
Oh, why couldn't I have found one of you
before all this started happening?
Cricket cast one last longing look at the
creature's hiding spot, and then turned
to hurry outside.
Sortell was right.
Dragons were starting to spill out of the
hives, doors, and flying ledges, swooping
off into the sky, or down toward the
market.
Jewel Hive was waking up for the day.
Or at least its silk wings were.
The tricky part was keeping out of sight
until the market was relatively crowded.
They managed by moving between stalls, and
staying in the corners of the ones
cricket guests were run by hive wings, and
so more likely to open later.
There was a close call with a silk wing
who was sweeping behind the tents, but
soon the narrow pathways were full of
dragons.
Cricket breathed a sigh of relief.
She'd been right about Jewel Hive.
Her memories hadn't failed her.
Everyone wore bright colors and piles of
gemstones.
Capes swirled beside wings everywhere, and
headdresses glittered from half of the
heads around them.
Even the silk wings who swept the streets
had adornments in their ears, or silk
scarves around their necks.
They edged through the crowd, making
their way slowly toward the hive.
Cricket tried to look as though she was
shopping, pausing to examine the
merchandise here and there, smiling
faintly at the stall owners who tried to
lure her inside.
She was the only hive wing in the group.
So most dragons would assume the other 3
were her silk wing servants.
It was weird and uncomfortable to have
them trailing behind her, heads down.
It made her feel guilty to think about
how many times she'd walked past their
own silkwing cook, without saying hello
or taken the silken workers at the market
for granted.
She wished sundew could lead the way.
She wished Blue could walk alongside her
wing to wing, so she could laugh with him
and talk to him, and let everyone know he
was wonderful, and just as important and
interesting and valuable as any hive wing
dragon in Pantala.
But she kept up her part, acting like any
other self-absorbed, fashion obsessed
hive wing in Jewel Hive.
Soon, the main doors of the hive were
ahead of them, swarming with dragons
coming in and out of the central glitter
bazaar, which occupied the bottom 3
levels of the city.
All the windows were open to let in the
sun, and the streets and stalls ahead of
them shone like a shattered frozen
rainbow.
Behind her, sundew cleared her throat
meaningfully.
Cricket glanced around, and noticed the
hive wing guards posted on either side of
the doors.
They wore sleek black armor and helmets
that hid their faces, but Cricket guessed
that the eyes glaring through the little
slits would be dead white.
Cricket fell to shiver of terrified
despair.
Queen Wasp was watching.
Queen Wasp was everywhere.
At the entrance to every hive, flying
patrols over the savannah, inside every
hive wing if she wanted to be.
How could they possibly hope to sneak by
her?
How could they ever escape?
When her gaze and her fury, could follow
them wherever they went?
The closest guard turned his head sharply
toward them.
Chapter 7.
Don't look at them.
Don't react.
Sundew whispered fiercely, stepping on
Cricket's tail.
Cricket turned toward her with what she
hoped was a lofty hive wing expression.
This had the added benefit of curving her
head away from the guard who was staring
at them.
It's all so boring, Cricket said, in the
high, slow way that Jewel Hive Dragons
often talked.
I feel like I've seen everything a
1000000 times.
Where's the originality?
I mean, yawn.
You should try raindrop scales.
A hive wing beside her in the crowd
interjected unexpectedly.
They're only open during the rainy season
so everything feels brand new.
I love them.
Have you heard of Pinacache?
She's the owner and the designer.
She has a 100000000 innovative ideas
every year.
It's incredible.
I wish I were that creative.
Wow, really?
I don't think I've been there, Cricket
said, surprised into using her real
voice.
The stranger was a summer squash yellow
color.
With flecks of red and black scales and
black wings, but she had covered herself
with webs of garnets, and what cricket
guessed were fake diamonds, since there
were so many of them.
A long sea green silk scarf was wound
around her neck and body, all the way
down her tail, pinned together with an
enormous dragonfly brooch on her back.
It's right by the salvation statue.
The other dragon confided.
Very expensive though.
I must admit, I often go there for ideas
and then see if I can find someone to
imitate them.
Don't tell.
She giggled in a warm, friendly way.
Your secret is safe with me, Cricket said
smiling back at her.
But the reverse would not be true, she
thought, with a twinge of anxiety.
The hive wing was all smiles and stories
now.
But if this dragon discovered that
cricket was a fugitive, Wouldn't she turn
her in immediately?
Or, even if she understood and wanted to
help them, she wouldn't be able to
because at any moment, Queen Wasp could
steal her mind.
This other hive wing could never choose
to run away like cricket had.
She could never be free of the queen.
She didn't have the choice to thank for
herself.
She'd helped them inadvertently though.
Cricket snuck a sideways peak of the
guards, the one who'd looked over must
have seen 2 hive wings gossiping and lost
interest.
He was now staring attentively at the
movement of birds on the canopy.
Thank you very much, Cricket said to the
yellow dragon as they stepped inside.
I mean, um, for the recommendation.
Maybe I'll see you there.
The hive wing chirped.
She waved and bustled away.
The walls around them were weirdly, both
comforting and claustrophobic.
Cricket was so used to living in a hive
with walls around her all the time.
And yet she found her scales prickling
anxiously, her eyes wishing for the sky
overhead.
It's not the walls that are bothering
me.
She acknowledged to herself.
It's the dragons inside them.
She seemed really nice.
Blue whispered, as they wound their way
toward the center of the market.
For a hive wing.
Sundew scoffed.
She did seem nice.
Cricket agreed.
Keeping her voice low.
That's the kind of dragon I'm talking
about, sundew.
What would she do if the queen didn't
control her?
I mean, if she knew the truth about
everything.
The flame silks, the book of clear sight
and she didn't have the queen in her head
making her do things, and messing with
her thoughts.
Then could we trust her?
Maybe she would try to help us.
Like you.
Blue said.
Maybe she'd be like you.
Maybe a lot of them wish they could be
free.
Doubtful.
Sundew said.
Everything is easy for hive wings like
her.
Why would she risk her own happy life?
Yeah, Soritell said fervently.
Hive Wings don't care about anyone but
themselves.
Cricket flinched, and Blue frowned at
Swordtail.
That's really unfair, sword tail.
You don't know what's going on in their
hearts.
The only high wing you know is cricket
and she cares a lot.
But I care because of you, cricket
thought, watching him.
I might never have known any of this, if
it wasn't for you.
I know plenty.
Swordell grumbled under his breath.
I think cricket is different from all the
others, Sundoo said.
There was something in her voice, as
though she needed to convince herself
that was true.
Maybe not.
What do you think, cricket?
Are there any other hive wings who are?
Who can't be?
I mean, whose brains are like yours.
Blue asked Cricket, glancing around
nervously.
Not that I've ever met, cricket said.
But we wouldn't exactly introduce
ourselves that way, so how would I know?
She thought of that 1st day she'd seen
everyone's eyes go white.
There was one dragon?
long ago?
I think he was trying to fight it.
But the queen used everyone in the hive
to catch him and bring him to her.
I don't know what happened to him, but
I'd guess he's not available for
interviews.
Blue shivered.
And she brushed his wing, trying to be as
reassuring as she could be in public.
The dragons around them were so loud and
moving so quickly that she didn't think
they'd notice anything beyond the
bargains in their talons.
But still, they had to be careful, for
Blue's sake.
Is that the salvation statue?
Swordell whispered.
Cricket craned her neck up and spotted
the head of the dragon that loomed over
the center of the glitter bazaar.
It wasn't the real queen wasp, but the
details of the stone work were so
accurate, the cricket half expected the
statue to suddenly twist around and glare
at her.
But it didn't.
The stone queen stayed frozen in place
wings flung out triumphantly, one talon
holding up the book of clear sight.
Cricket stumbled, suddenly remembering
the rest of the statue that commemorated
the end of the war.
The marble dragon that lay dead below the
queen's other talons, with one of her
deadly wrist stingers plunged through his
heart.
She'd never stopped for a moment to think
about that dragon.
Because he wasn't anyone in particular.
He was just the enemy.
He was a blank nobody, representing the
tribe who'd been defeated, and
exterminated, when the hive wings saved
the silk wings from them.
He was a leaf wing.
She glanced back at sundew.
I should have warned you.
She said quietly, this could be
upsetting.
Don't worry, Hivewing, Sundew muttered
twitching her cape closer around her
shoulders.
I'm at full rage all the time.
It can't get worse.
All the time.
Blue said wonderingly.
Really?
Don't you get tired?
Yes, she growled.
And that makes me furious too.
They stepped out of the crowd into the
space around the statue.
Like the Salvation Mosaic and Cicada Hive
this monument was also set apart from its
surroundings.
A tranquil circle of grass surrounded it
strangely peaceful in the chaotic bustle
of the market.
Cricket noticed that most of the shopping
dragons carefully went around the circle
to avoid treading on the grass, unless
they were going up to admire the statue.
It was really extraordinary.
Twice the size of any actual dragons, and
carved from stone, cord in the northwest
mountains of Pantala.
An enormous ruby glinted from each of the
queen's eye sockets, and gold letters
were inlaid on the cover of the marble
book of Clearsight.
But the real book doesn't look anything
like that, Cricket thought.
Gazing up at the fake book.
It's not shiny or enormous.
It doesn't have a title emblazoned on
it.
It's not what's on the outside of the
book that counts.
It's what's on the inside.
And that's the part Queen Wasp has been
lying about to everyone.
She glanced at the outline of the heavy
pouch under sundew's cloak.
We should make a copy of it, in case
anything happens to it.
But if anything did happen to it, who
would believe us that the copy was real?
Sortail was circling the statue, frowning
and fiddling anxiously with his jeweled
mask.
Well, Sundu hissed as he returned to
them.
I don't know.
He confessed.
I don't see a place to leave a message
that wouldn't immediately be seen.
What would you do?
Knock it over, she muttered, smash it to
pieces with my bare talons, throw the
broken rock chunks at everyone in this
hive.
But she stalked forward, and studied the
statue with sharp eyes.
Are you all right?
Blue whispered to Cricket.
Me?
she said, startled.
Sure.
I don't know.
This statue makes me feel so guilty now.
And the book is all wrong.
I wish dragons could read the real
version.
He nodded.
I've been thinking about Clearsight, he
said softly.
She wouldn't want a war or this life for
her descendants.
Or for the other 2 tribes.
But I don't know how we're going to help
everyone.
We're just 4 normal little dragons.
I know, Cricket agreed.
Well, 3 normal little dragons, and one
vengeful warrior dragon with an arsenal
of terrifying bugs.
Sundew had paused near one corner of the
statue's base.
She turned casually and met Cricket's
eyes.
Swordtail stepped toward her, and she
poked him backward, tipping her head to
beckon cricket to her.
There were only 2 other dragons on the
grass circle with them.
A father with a small dragonette, who
were sitting on the far side of the
statue, sharing a lemon pastry and
talking about the story of the
salvation.
What is it?
Cricket whispered.
Sundew cut her gaze toward the very
bottom of the stone slab, where the
corner met the grass.
A tiny shard of stone was missing, leaving
a small gap between the base and the
ground.
Something pale green was shoved into the
gap.
Cricket realized that sundew had angled
herself to shield cricket from view of
anyone passing in the marketplace.
She reached down and quickly tugged the
something free.
It was a leaf, folded into a square.
Unfolded, a message was revealed, inked
across the veins on the inside.
Midnight, library, five.
Her heart thumping wildly.
Cricket refolded the leaf and slid it
back into place.
She didn't know what the 5 meant, but the
rest seemed pretty clear.
I think we have a way to find the
chrysalis, she said to sundo, under her
breath.
And I think, I know where we can hide
until then.
Chapter 8.
Cricket's mother, Cadell. lived about 8
levels above the glitter bazaar, in a
neighborhood of little residential
squares and parks that was respectable
but not the wealthiest part of the hive.
It looked fancy enough to cricket, but
she'd heard her mother complain for hours
about the classless neighbors, the long
climb to her job at the university, and
the shabby condition of the streets.
And one thing Cadell hated in particular
was the water tower that stood in the
center of the square, directly across
from her house.
It was ghastly.
It was covered in rust, there was nothing
more hideous in the world.
Why couldn't she have been given a house
on the sky view side instead?
Why did she have to look at it every
day?
Was this her punishment for the 2 little
monsters she'd loosed on the world?
Couldn't the hive do something to make it
more attractive?
Why didn't anyone else care?
If she'd been designing the hive?
She'd have put all the water tanks under
the street.
Or at least on a level where no one
important had to look at them.
But on their 1st visit to Jewel Hive, Katy
did and Cricket had decided that it would
make a perfect hiding spot.
Maybe not perfect, Katy did had conceded
testing the rickety, rusty iron legs that
held it up.
You'll probably get wet.
Not sure how you'll explain that.
I'll think of something if I need to
Cricket said.
She'd flown up to the top of the tower to
make sure she could open the hatch by
herself.
She was 4 then, but she had figured out
the complicated latch after studying it
for a moment.
This was where silkwing workers would
climb in and out to clean the tank, and
where they'd pour in the new water
gathered from sinkholes under the
savannah, or transported by air from Lake
Scorpion.
This was the 1st thing they did wherever
they went, Cricket and Katie did.
Cricket was already used to doing it on
her own too.
In every new place.
She looked for somewhere to hide.
She needed somewhere she could get to
quickly and quietly, in case Queen Wasp
suddenly brainwashed everyone with her
orders.
Or, as Katie did call them, whole hive
commands.
She needed to be ready to vanish at any
moment.
She'd never had to use the water tower
though.
Their 2 visits had been short, and there
hadn't been any all hive mind control
moments while they were in Jewel Hive.
So she just had to hope it was as good a
hiding place as they'd thought it would
be.
The streets around her mother's house
were mostly deserted.
It was still fairly early in the morning
so most dragons had either gone to work
already, or, more likely, were still
asleep after desperately trying to
outlast everyone else at the parties and
salons the night before.
But the posters of Queen Wasps' face
seemed to loom larger than ever. her eyes
glaring down at them around every turn.
Worse yet, new posters had sprung up on
several of the walls throughout the hive
wanted, wanted, for crimes against the
tribe and the sacred memory of clear
sight.
Extremely dangerous, approach with
caution, reward for any information or
identification that leads to an arrest.
And underneath all that, drawings of blue
sword tail, and cricket.
But not sundew, cricket noticed.
Queen Wasp doesn't want to admit that a
leaf wing got all the way inside her own
hive.
Even though 100s of dragons must have
seen her as we escaped with a book.
But if the queen says it didn't happen
that's the new truth.
Is there anyone who would dare to
disagree with her?
Her heart seized and jumped every time
they passed another dragon near one of
the posters.
Every time a hive wing glanced at them.
Every time she caught a glimpse of her
own face on a wall behind someone's
wings.
What will happen to us if we get caught?
What does Queen Wasp do with traitors?
I've never heard of one in my lifetime.
Is that because there haven't been any?
Or because she made them disappear?
I wonder what happened to that dragon who
tried to fight back against the mind
control.
The only thing I know for sure?
If we get caught.
I'll never see blue again.
He'll be thrown back in the flame silk
cavern.
And the rest of us?
Will we be executed publicly?
Or vanish without a trace?
She'd always lived with a quiet fear at
the back of her mind, that one day she'd
be found out, and the queen would be
furious.
But this new fear was like termites in
her skull, much more constant and present
and squirming through all of her
thoughts.
When they reached the square her mother
lived on, they had to wait out of sight
around a corner, until a pair of silk
wings finished polishing the arch around
the water tower.
Dragonfly Square was named for a hero of
the tree wars, as were many spots all
around the hives, and it was decorated
with sculptures of dragonflies in her
honor.
They ranged from tiny mobiles, each
dragonfly as long as one of cricket's
talons, to one the size of a dragon
perched on the side of the water tank.
Their shiny metallic blues and greens
gave the square the strange vibe of an
electrocuted garden.
Sundew peered around the square, as the 2
cleaners packed up their things and set
off down a side street.
What's the plan here?
She hissed.
We're hiding in one of the houses?
No.
Cricket pointed at the tower.
In there.
There's a hatch at the very top, near the
ceiling.
Sortail wrinkled his snout.
Um, isn't that full of water?
Not all the way.
Cricket said.
There's a ledge and room to breathe at
the top.
He still looked skeptical, but Sundew was
already striding toward the tallest
house.
Staying in its shadow.
She spread her wings, tossing back the
cape, and soared up the wall.
She was in the open for 2 heartbeats
hopping from the roof to the top of the
tower, and then she was hidden by the
curve of the tank.
Cricket followed her along the same
path.
With blue and swordtail behind her.
They all landed as quietly as they could
on the top of the tank, but the thunk of
their talons on the metal still echoed
enough to make cricket wince.
There was the hatch, and as before, she
was able to get it open quickly.
She slipped inside first.
Reaching down with her tail to see how
much space there was between the roof and
the water level.
It was higher than last time, just
covering the ledge that ran around the
inside at the top.
Cricket dropped onto the flat, latticed
surface, with a small splash, and edged
around to the other side, where she and
Katydid had stabbed one of 3 peep holes.
Through the hole in the metal, she could
see straight down to her mother's house.
Is she still in there?
Or did she leave for work already?
Has she seen my face on the posters?
Did she tell the queen I'm her daughter?
Is she disappointed in me?
Or did this just prove everything she
thought about me all along?
Cricket sighed.
It was dark in the tank, and a little
eerie, with a vast expanse of water
silent below them.
But she could feel the brush of Blue's
wings as he came and settled next to her
comforting her without saying a word.
Mother might be disappointed.
But being different from the other hive
wings?
I think that makes me lucky.
Sundew closed the hatch behind her.
And for a very long time, the 4 of them
sat quietly, each thinking their own
thoughts.
Sundew is dreaming of vengeance.
Sortell is worrying about Luna.
Blue is imagining being them, or me, or
any of the dragons who live in this
hive.
I wonder if he would understand my
mother.
If he met her.
Could he explain her to me?
Cricket could just picture her mother's
face if she ever brought Blue home for
dinner.
She tried to focus on the mind control.
Would the chrysalis know anything she
didn't?
If they combined their research, would it
reveal something new?
Was it possible they were working on a
way to free the hive wings?
Or at least Katie did, she thought.
If I could free Katy did?
I could stop worrying so much.
We're stuck in here until midnight?
Swordtail whispered.
Yes, Cricket whispered back, clearing the
fog from her glasses with one of the silk
scarves around her neck.
Whoa.
She felt the ledge vibrate as he shook
his head.
It's going to be a long day.
Sometime later.
Cricket discovered she had nodded off
when Blue nudged her awake.
She was disoriented by the darkness, so
it took her a moment to access her
natural sense of time.
Almost midday.
Her talons and tail were entwined with
blues. and she pulled them back and
adjusted her glasses, glad he couldn't
see her expression.
Cricket, he said softly.
Is that your mother?
She leaned up to the hole where he was
peering out.
Sure enough, down below, a dragon was
coming out of her mother's house.
A dragon the color of tangerines, with
black patterns, zigzagging along her
spine, and out to the edges of her
wings.
Yes, she said.
That's Cadell.
She hadn't seen her since the last rainy
season.
Katy did kept sending messages asking to
visit, and Cadell always said no.
Sometimes, she said no and strongly
worded letters about how annoying and
useless they were.
Why do I still want her to love me?
Cricket wondered.
Want me to drop a mango on her?
Sundew offered.
You have a mango?
Swordtail asked indignantly.
No, you acorn.
It's a metaphorical mango.
I don't see how metaphorical mangoes are
going to do us any good, Swartell
muttered.
Caddell hurried off toward the ramps that
led to the upper levels.
She taught history at Jewel Hive
University, which cricket had heard her
describe as a job where I teach my
replacements, because what else are they
going to do with this information?
She moved as purposefully and quickly as
she always did.
She didn't slow down, or glance sideways
as she passed the wanted posters of
cricket and her friends.
Has she even noticed it's me?
Maybe she doesn't care.
Cadell strode out of sight, down one of
the avenues, and Cricket side.
Her mother was a question that seemed as
though it would never have an answer.
She was about to lie down again, when she
spotted a flicker of movement from behind
one of the other houses.
Cricket paused, squinting toward it.
Was it a trick of the light?
Or was that shadow bigger than it should
be?
Something moved again?
And this time, she was sure it was a
dragon's head peeking out, glancing
furtively around, and then withdrawing
like a snail testing the open air with
its antennae, another few long moments
past, and then 2 dragons carefully
slipped out of the shadows.
They both wore half capes with hoods, of
pale silver embroidered with emerald
threads, and they kept their heads down
as they crossed the square toward
Caddell's house.
One turned to check up and down the
streets, as the other crouched and pulled
Caddell's spare key out from behind the
loose tile where she kept it.
Cricket gasped.
It wasn't just that the silver caped
dragon knew where the key was.
It was the way she moved.
The flick of her tail as she walked.
The tilt of her head as she unlocked the
door.
The dragon sneaking into her mother's
house right now was Cricket's sister, Katy
did.
Chapter 9.
That's my sister, Cricket whispered to
Blue, keeping her eye pressed to the
hole.
What is she doing here?
Why is she sneaking in instead of letting
our mother know she's here?
And who is she with?
The other dragon was a lot bigger than
Katy did.
But it was hard to see many details
through the tiny spy hole, and from such
a height.
The dragons' scales that cricket could
see were yellow, with black stripes on
the wings, but that didn't narrow it down
very much.
Katie did, got the door open, and turned
back to look at her partner.
The other dragon said something, and then
they split up.
Mystery Dragon went to the corner of the
avenue where Caddell had gone, presumably
to keep watch.
Katydid slipped inside and closed the
door behind her.
I have to talk to her, Cricket said
standing up.
What?
Sortell cried.
That's a terrible idea.
Sundu tell her that's a terrible idea.
She could turn into Queen Wasp at any
moment, Sundew pointed out.
Exactly.
Swordell agreed.
You heard the boss.
But as long as she's herself.
I know she's the one high wing I can
trust, Cricket said, and I need to make
sure she's all right.
I never said goodbye.
Her breath caught in her throat, and she
had to struggle for the next words.
Or explained, or told her I was going or
anything.
And now she's here, right where I can
talk to her.
I just have to.
Of course you should, Blue said.
She could hear a thread of guilt in his
voice.
She knew he was thinking about how she
had left her sister behind forever
because she'd been helping him.
He didn't have to feel bad about that.
It had been her choice.
But she didn't have time to reassure
him.
She had to hurry before Katy did slipped
through her claws.
I'll be back as soon as I can, she said
flying up to the hatch.
If you can, Swordtail said glumly.
If she doesn't lose her mind and go all
wide eyed and take you to the queen.
Well, Cricket said, shooting sundew a
grin as a beam of light lit the leaf
wings concerned face.
Get some vicious caterpillars ready for
me.
She hopped out onto the roof.
And as she pulled the hatch shut, she
heard Sundew's voice saying, They're
centipedes.
What is wrong with you dragons?
Cricket peaked over the edge?
at the dragon standing guard?
Whoever it was, did seem kind of
familiar.
But she couldn't risk them trying to stop
her, or deciding to turn her in.
She spread her wings and floated quietly
quietly down to the highest balcony of
her mother's house.
The door here was also locked.
Cadell was very careful.
But the balcony led to the least
welcoming guest room of all time, where
Katy did and Cricket had slept on their
visits.
The sisters had fiddled with the latch
until it was just broken enough not to be
noticed, so they could get in and out
secretly if they needed to.
Cricket slid her claw under the latch and
wiggled it up.
The doors swung open toward her, and she
quickly hopped inside and pulled them
shut again. across the room.
Katy did whirled around, clutching a
stack of papers to her chest.
Her face made Cricket feel as if a 1000
butterflies had just burst into the sky
at once.
Katy did.
Cricket leaped over the thin sleep
palettes, and threw her wings around her
sister.
No way.
Katy did breathed.
Cricket.
This can't be real.
She took Cricket's shoulders, and held
her out to study her face.
By the hives.
It's really you.
Are you all right?
I am, cricket said.
I'm so sorry, Katie did.
I know you must have been so worried.
Are you all right?
What are you doing here?
Your phase is on posters in every hive
her sister cried.
They're saying you tried to steal the
book of Clearsight. and that you're
running around with a pair of silk
wings.
Cricket, you have to turn yourself in and
tell them it's all lies.
I'm sure if we explain.
But it's not all lies.
Cricket interrupted her.
Katie did.
We did steal the Book of Clearsight.
The lie is everything Queen Wasp has ever
said about it.
Nothing she's told us is true.
Katie did sat down suddenly, as though
her legs had turned to sand.
Oh, cricket.
Why?
I don't know.
To keep power, maybe?
To make sure no one ever questioned her?
No.
Why?
Did you steal the book?
What were you thinking?
Cricket was thrown.
That's not the important part Katie did.
I was trying to help someone, but didn't
you hear what I said?
It's all lies.
Everything wasp said about the tree wars
about the silk wings joining our tribe
all of it.
I'm sure she had her reasons.
Katie did said.
But you're in so much trouble now
Cricket.
I don't know how to help.
I don't know how to fix it.
She pulled cricket into another hug, and
cricket felt how cold her sister's scales
were.
You don't have to fix it. cricket said
holding her tight.
I just came to tell you I'm all right, and
to make sure you are too.
Who's that dragon outside?
Why are you here?
Instead of cicada hive.
She glanced around the small bare room as
Katy did, leaned back.
And what are you doing in mom's house?
I came to get these.
Katie did said.
She picked up the pile of papers she'd
dropped, and Cricket realized it was
drawings of her.
Drawings her sister had done on their
last visit of cricket sleeping, laughing
rolling her eyes.
Katy did was a good artist.
They really looked like cricket.
Much more than the wanted posters did.
As far as we know, no one has told the
queen who you are yet, Katie did said.
Maybe they haven't recognized you, or
maybe they're afraid to admit they know
you.
I don't know why mother hasn't.
But I was worried that the queen would
see these drawings through her eyes and
realize she must know you.
But if you take them, Cricket said, then
isn't it possible she'll see them through
your eyes?
I'm going to destroy them.
Katy did said with a sigh.
The queen has been mind hopping all over
the hives, looking for clues about you.
I'm afraid she must have figured out she
can't get into your head.
She has, Cricket said sadly.
I'm sorry, Katie did.
I tried to be so careful.
But she was inside the librarian.
Did you know that?
She's always inside the librarian.
As soon as the dragon becomes the
librarian and joins the temple of
Clearsight, Queen Wasp takes over, and
never lets her control her own body ever
again.
Can you imagine how horrible that would
be?
But everyone wants to be the librarian
Katy did pointed out.
It's such an important position.
Only because everyone doesn't know about
this, Cricket cried.
If they knew it meant giving up your free
will forever, would anyone sign up for
that?
I think you're exaggerating a little.
Katie did said.
She started gathering all the drawings.
Let's talk about this somewhere safer.
Why isn't she listening to me?
Cricket watched her sister for a moment?
Puzzled.
These were huge world shifting facts, the
truth about the book, about Queen Wasp
and the librarian.
Why didn't Katy Did want to know more?
How could she brush that information
aside so easily?
If someone told cricket, she'd been lied
to her whole life, she'd want to grab the
truth and rub it into her eyeballs.
I can't go with you, Katy did.
Cricket took one of her sister's talents
and hers.
It's too dangerous.
You could be taken over by WASP at any
moment.
A fierce struggle crossed Katy did's
face.
That's true.
But maybe we should go to her and
confess.
I was wrong to help you hide it all these
years.
Perhaps she can do something to fix you
and make you like the rest of us.
No, Cricket said.
I don't want that.
I would never want that.
So what are you going to do?
Katie did said, exasperated.
Hide in a water tower forever?
I have friends, Cricket said.
We're looking for answers.
I'm going to finally find out the truth
about everything.
Katy did let out a short bark of a
laugh.
That really is what you want, isn't it?
The truth about everything, even if it
makes your life a 1000000 times harder.
Katie did.
Why are you really here?
Cricket asked.
I mean, in Jewel Hive.
You didn't come all this way for a few
drawings, did you?
Why aren't you home with father?
If you're so sure the queen is right
about everything.
Why haven't you told her about me
yourself?
Her sister stepped over to the balcony
and peered out through the slats in the
door.
Because I'd be in trouble too. she said
And Lady Scarab wouldn't let me.
Lady Scarab?
Cricket clambered over the sleep pallets
again, and peeked out the window next to
the balcony.
She could see the dragon waiting by the
corner, twitching her wings and tail
impatiently.
Holy mother of trees, that was Lady
Scarab.
Cricket had met the grouchy, majestic old
dragon a few times in her life, and it
had always been very mysterious and
alarming.
The other dragonettes at school whispered
all sorts of rumors about her.
They swore she was older than the hives
maybe as old as the book, which couldn't
possibly be true, but it sounded
dramatic.
They said she had once been so powerful
she could knock over a tree by breathing
on it.
They said she boiled silk wings in their
cocoons and ate them.
None of that was true.
But Lady Scarab never bothered correcting
the stories.
She didn't seem to care what anyone
thought of her.
Not even when 2 of cricket's schoolmates
saw her in the hall and screamed and flew
out the nearest windows.
What was true was that she was Lady
Jewel's mother and Queen Wasp's aunt.
She lived all alone in a giant mansion in
cicada hives, with no servants or anyone
else.
No one knew why she didn't live in the
same hive as her daughter, although she
also owned a mansion in Jewel Hives, which
she visited from time to time.
One day, soon after Cricket's mother left
Lady Scarab had appeared suddenly on
their doorstep, their father, bowing and
confused, led her in, and tried to offer
her tea in the parlor, but Lady Scarab
had announced that she wished to see Katy
did and Cricket.
So they lined up for her inspection, and
she studied them through her spectacles.
You look healthy, she said to Cricket.
Yes, ma'am, Cricket had answered, thinking
why are you here?
Aren't you the dragon with the
telescope?
How old are you really?
Do you ever eat little hive wings?
Is that why you're pleased that I look
healthy?
Terrarium Academy?
Lady Scarab demanded.
Really?
Um, Cricket said nervously.
My school?
I didn't choose it.
I did, their father interjected.
It's very practical, a down to earth
place.
No, pun intended.
Lady Scarab said, with a wintry smile.
But father just blinked in confusion.
Fine, but don't let them grow moss on
your brain, Dragonette.
I, I won't, Cricket stammered.
Although she had no idea how to stop her
teachers if they decided to do that, and
could they really do that?
Had anyone done that before?
What did they do?
Put moss seeds in students' ears?
Did it really work without any light in
there?
She'd only gotten rid of the ensuing
nightmares later by doing a lot of
research and figuring out that Lady
Scarab must have been joking, because
growing moss on a dragon's brain was
quite scientifically impossible.
I understand Cadell has left the family.
Lady Scarab went on, turning to Katy
did.
Are you managing without her?
Yes, your ladyship, Katy did said.
Thank you for asking.
Well, let me know if you need anything.
The old hive wing had said, in a
ferocious, you'd better tell me if
anything's wrong, sort of way.
I'm not far, and I'm not dead yet.
Don't be a proud, hungry fool.
And that dragonette needs new glasses.
She'd flecked a claw at cricket, and the
unsettling thing was, she'd been right.
Cricket had needed stronger glasses, but
she was still amazed that Lady Scarab had
figured that out just by looking at her.
Yes, your ladyship, Katy did said
bowing.
And then Lady Scarab had swept back out
of their lives.
But here she was, standing guard, while
Katy did stole from her mother's house.
Wait.
Why?
Cricket asked.
What does Lady Scarab care?
Did you say she won't let you turn me
in?
She came bursting into the house the day
the wanted posters went up?
Katie did said.
She made me pack a bag, and told father
not to tell Queen Wasp anything, about
you, or me, or her taking me away, and
then she brought me here, over the web
bridges.
I think she figures Lady Jewel can
protect us from the queen if necessary.
But I'm afraid she's wrong about that.
She is definitely wrong.
No one can protect anyone.
As long as Queen Wasp can take over Lady
Jewel or Scarab herself at any moment.
I don't understand, Cricket said, trying
to follow the threads.
Why would Lady Scarab have anything to do
with us?
We're just a pair of random hive wings to
her.
Aren't we?
Katydid started rubbing her face with a
miserable expression.
Katie did what?
What aren't you telling me?
Cricket?
Why do you always have to know
everything?
Katie did cried.
Your life would be so much easier if you
didn't, wondering about silk wings, asking
impertinent questions about the queen's
powers.
And then stealing the book of
Clearsight?
I was afraid you'd get in trouble one day
but I didn't think it would be this bad.
But wouldn't you rather know the truth
than live in a cloud of lies?
Cricket asked, confused.
I mean, wouldn't everyone?
No.
Katy did crushed the drawings between her
claws.
Everything was fine.
You were safe.
No one ever needed to know about you
especially you.
Cricket felt her wings trembling.
The way they sometimes did when she was
close to an answer she'd been looking
for.
Katie did.
Cadell is not your mother.
Katie did blurted.
And father is not your father either.
Cricket stared at her.
That was not what she'd expected to
hear.
Although, it explains a lot about the way
they acted around her.
But then who?
She started.
A loud pounding came from the door
downstairs, making them both jump.
They peeked out the window, and saw a
lady scarab the whacking it impatiently
with her tail.
She told me to be quick, Katie did said
Cricket, come with us.
I'll tell you everything if I have to.
Buy the hives.
Those were words cricket lived for.
Everything.
Mysteries explained, puzzles solved, the
whole truth finally revealed to her.
But her friends were waiting in the water
tower.
They didn't know how to get to the
library for the midnight meeting with a
chrysalis.
They wouldn't understand if she left with
Katy did.
And it really wasn't safe.
Queen Wasp could look out of her sister's
eyes at any moment.
Cricket had already stayed too long.
I can't go with you, she said.
Can't you tell me everything now?
Like, really quickly?
Katie did hugged her fiercely.
It's not that easy.
I just want you to be safe.
I can only be safe if I know the truth
Cricket said, pulling back.
Just like our tribe will only be safe if
they stop believing wasps lies.
Her sister sighed.
I don't see why.
They're perfectly safe now.
Whatever you think she's lying to them
about.
Oh, Cricket.
I have to go.
But I'm afraid I'll never see you again.
Can I find you?
Cricket asked.
Tomorrow, around dawn?
I'll be hiding at Lady Scarab's house
Katie did said.
Pressing cricket's front talons between
hers.
Please be careful.
You too.
Cricket hugged her again and let go.
Katie did hurried out of the room with
the drawings, and Cricket hurt her claws
on the stairs.
A few moments later.
She came out the front door and locked it
behind her, and then the 2 hive wings
flew away, with lady scarab scolding Katy
did in a furious undertone.
Cricket stood in the barren room, looking
at the empty walls and toilet shelves.
She had cried herself to sleep in this
room, wondering why Caddell had taken
Katydid to dinner and left her behind.
She had cried in other rooms like this
wondering what was wrong with her, that
her own mother didn't care about her.
She had stared across the breakfast table
at her blank faced father, who never
asked questions about school or her life
unless she got in trouble, and then it
was usually something like, you still
here?
How long until you graduate?
Quit bothering your teachers and stay out
of my way.
A part of her had always thought
everything would make sense.
Once she knew why she was different.
Once she had the whole truth in her
talents.
But this wasn't a truth she could get her
talons around.
They weren't her parents.
They never wanted her in the 1st place.
Someone gave me to them against their
will.
So now the question was, Who?
And why?
Part two.
A trail of silk.
Chapter 10.
Midnight, Library, 5.
Cricket tried all day to focus on what
that 5 meant, but she couldn't keep her
buzzing mind away from the mystery of her
parents.
She leaned over the ledge and trailed her
claws through the cold, dark water.
Beside her, Blue shivered, as though he
felt the chill traveling through her
bones into his.
Caddell is not your mother.
Father is not your father.
Dragonfly Square was busy in the early
evening. as everyone bustled home from
work to change into their nighttime
glamour before going out again.
Swordtail, watching through the spy hole
reported that Cadell had sailed off with
a very orange male dragon.
But Cricket couldn't bring herself to
watch.
Her whole life, she'd been waiting for
her mother to care about her.
She didn't know how to dig up those seeds
and replant them.
She'd wanted something true she could put
in front of her parents, so she could say
look, here's why I'm different.
Look, I found all the answers.
Look, here's why you should love me
anyway.
But they would never care.
She wasn't theirs.
So whose was she?
Where were her real parents?
It was also unsettling, as she thought
over their conversation, to realize that
nothing she'd said had made any
difference to Katy did, who is not
actually in my sister.
Cricket thought, before her brain shied
away from thinking about that.
Cricket rubbed her forehead, and tried to
pull her scarves closer, but they didn't
make her any warmer.
She'd tried to tell Katy did about wasps
lies, and Katy did had acted like the
truth was just another story, another
version of the world, instead of the only
real version.
Wouldn't you rather know the truth?
No.
I think you're exaggerating.
I'm sure she had her reasons.
How could Katie did say that?
Queen Wasp lied so that the high wings
could take over Pantala?
And she nearly wiped out the leaf wings
to do it.
She made them all think they were
following clear site's plan?
She convinced everyone she had the right
to rule over the silk wings, that the
hive wings were the strongest tribe, that
they deserved everything they wanted.
She turned her own dragons into murderers
and monsters.
Maybe that's what Katie did, didn't want
to see.
Maybe I just need to try again.
If I show her the book, if she meets blue
and sundew, and takes a moment to
understand them.
If I tell her everything and try harder
she'll have to see.
She'll have to hear me.
Are you all right?
Blue whispered, taking one of her talons
in his.
Oh, sort of.
Not really, she whispered back.
Cold.
Also, my whole life was a lie.
But mostly cold.
She nudged her glasses up and tried to
smile at him.
I can maybe help with that.
He said.
A softly glowing thread of flame silk
unfolded from his wrist, snaking out
toward her scales.
She started to pull away, but he held on
to her gently.
Wait, he said.
I've been experimenting.
This kind shouldn't burn you.
Cricket went still, realizing again how
much she trusted him.
The gold thread reached for her like a
vine growing too fast.
It wound around her claws and his, and
spiraled up toward her shoulder.
Everywhere the flame silk touched her
scales.
Warmth sank in, quietly spreading into
her bones.
Oh, wow.
She said softly.
It's like magic blue.
Right, he said.
I thought it would be much scarier, but I
kind of love my flame silk.
Is that weird?
She shook her head.
I love it too.
She glanced over to the other side of the
ledge, where Sortell had accidentally
fallen asleep on Sundew's cape.
The leaf wing sat pinned beside his
snoring head, glowering and tapping one
of her pouches with an ominous look in
her eyes.
I miss my mom's, Blue said softly.
Oh, Cricket said, I'm so sorry, Blue.
As I was coming out of the cocoon, he
said.
For a moment, I forgot everything that
had happened.
I thought I would open my eyes, and
mother and silver spot would be there
waiting for me, and smiling, and ready to
hug me and take me flying.
I've been trying not to think about them
too much.
But just for a moment, that felt so
real.
I hope they're all right.
They must be worried about me and Luna
especially with all those posters up.
Cricket leaned into him.
Queen Wasp won't hurt them, she said.
It wouldn't accomplish anything, and
she's very efficient.
Maybe there's a way to get a message to
them?
Let's think.
If we could find a silk wing going to
cicada hive.
She tried to think of silk wings who
traveled between the hives, traitors
messengers, You've been really quiet all
day, Blue said.
She sighed.
I know.
It's my sister told me that my parents
aren't my parents.
In the glow from the flame silk.
She saw his eyes widen.
Wow.
He thought about that for a moment.
So, who are your real parents?
I don't know.
And how was Lady Scarab connected?
She couldn't be Lady Scarab's daughter
could she?
But then why wouldn't Scarab have kept
her?
That was too weird to even brush with her
wings.
Scarab had had one daughter.
Lady Jewel, ages and ages ago.
Cricket couldn't fit into her brain the
possibility that scarab had had another
egg.
Decades later, with some mystery dragon
and then given it away to Cadell.
Katy Did didn't tell you anything else?
He asked.
She shook her head.
She really didn't want to.
Blue, this has to be connected to why I'm
different from the other hive wings
doesn't it?
Maybe one of my real parents is resistant
to the mind control too.
Maybe Queen Wasp found out, and that's
why they had to hide me with another
family.
He was silent, and she tipped her snout
toward him.
Blue?
I just can't imagine leaving my
dragonette with someone else.
He said.
That must have been so hard.
There must have been a really big reason
they couldn't keep you.
His eyes met hers again, and then dropped
away quickly.
Like, if they weren't supposed to be
together at all.
She gasped and covered her snout with her
talons.
Across the water tower.
Sundew twisted to look at them.
It would never have entered her head
before she met Blue.
She wouldn't have been able to imagine it
until it changed her own life.
You think one of my parents was a silk
wing?
she whispered.
Do you?
He whispered back.
It's not possible, is it?
Am I a hybrid?
Would hybrids be immune to the mind
control?
Silk wings are?
Is that why I am?
It seems like such an obvious possible
answer.
Why didn't I ever think of it before?
Because I thought I knew my parents.
Is that the answer?
But if that's the answer, how do we save
the other hive wings, we can't exactly
turn them all into hybrids.
I don't know.
She tried to think of all the silk wings
she'd ever met.
Had any of them acted strange, like maybe
they were secretly her mother or father?
Not that she could remember.
There was no science on potential silk
wing hive wing hybrids.
They were so forbidden.
It wasn't even conceivable to study the
idea.
Wouldn't there be something more?
More silkwing about her if she were a
hybrid?
Blue's antennae twitched?
It's almost midnight, he said.
Thank the trees, Sundoo responded.
She yanked her cape out from under sword
tail, dumping him into the vat of water.
When he came up, sputtering and indignant
she flung her tail around its snout.
Shush, you great screech owl.
It's time to go.
It'll be all right.
Blue said softly to Cricket.
Under the noise of swordtail hauling
himself out of the water.
I'm sure whatever happened.
Your real parents loved you, and wished
they could have kept you.
Cricket was not so sure, but she was
relieved to be moving again, out of the
tower, and on their way to the library, a
place that had always been full of
answers for her.
She hoped the chrysalis silk wings would
be like that too, full of answers.
If she could figure out what 5 meant and
find them.
The library was a few levels up from
Cadell's neighborhood, just above the
Jewel Hive Nest, and below several levels
of expensive ballrooms and wealthy
mansions.
It was one of cricket's favorite places
in all the hives, and she always wondered
why Jewel Hive was only famous for the
glitter bazaar.
Why didn't other dragons ever talk about
the library that took up an entire level
containing every book ever written by a
hive wing?
Perhaps because it didn't fit with the
image of Jewel Hive?
No one imagined the dragons here, choosing
reading over shopping, or jewelry
making.
And yet, for some reason, Lady Jewel
wanted this library, Cricket thought, as
they crept up to the enormous double
doors at the front entrance.
She made sure it was built into her hive
plans.
None of the other hives have one quite
this big, not even mantis hive, which is
supposed to be the smart hive, the
academic center of innovation.
Cricket looked up at the flying beetles
carved over the doors.
The joke in the other hives was that Lady
Jewel couldn't even read.
Although surely that wasn't really true.
Still, why did Jewel want a library that
she apparently never goes into?
Despite Joel Hive's reputation, the
library was never empty.
At least as far as cricket had seen.
There were always dragonettes everywhere
sprawled along the tops of bookshelves
curled in the window nooks, lying in the
hammocks, and reading, reading, reading.
But now, near midnight, it was closed and
deserted.
The front doors faced the entrance from
the ramps.
There was a small plaza here, outside the
library walls, with a circle of benches
arranged around a statue of clear sight.
Cricket loved this statue too.
Clearsight had her nose in a book, not
the book, just a book, and she was
reading.
She didn't look like an avenging prophet
announcing the doom of all the tribes.
She looked as though she might glance up
at any moment, see cricket and say, oh my
gosh, have you read this one?
It's amazing.
The entire library level was vibrating
from the shouts and music of a party
above them.
The flame silk globes overhead shook and
swayed, and sent shadows wobbling across
the front of the library.
Tiny flecks of tree stuff drifted down
making cricket sneeze.
Where's the chrysalis?
Sundew whispered to sword tail.
He spread his wings in a how would I know
gesture, and she rolled her eyes.
You're not the most useful revolutionary
she hissed.
Has anyone ever told you that?
I'm better with Luna around, he said
wistfully.
Sundu hopped up the library steps and
tried the doors, but they were locked.
So if we can't get in, she said.
Turning with a swirl of her cape.
The meeting must be out here in the plaza
right?
Cricket looked around.
It felt as if they were completely alone
on this level.
They'd passed other dragons on the ramps
up and down, but it was the glittering
hours of the night.
All of them were going past the library
to the gatherings above, to glitter and
sea and be seen glittering.
Have you ever noticed that glitter is a
word that quickly loses its meaning if
you say it too much?
she said to Blue.
Glitter, glitter, glittering.
Isn't it super weird now?
You're super weird, he said
affectionately.
Why isn't this library as sparkly as the
rest of the hive?
She glanced up at the towering walls of
tree stuff.
It was true.
Unlike most of the jewel hive, the
library wasn't shimmering with embedded
jewels and tiles and decorations.
It did have expensive wooden doors, saved
from some long ago building that must
also have been a library, because they
had books carved all over them.
Cricket remembered sundew slashing her
claws through the sculpted face of Queen
Wasp on the doors of Wasp Hive.
She wondered how long it had taken to
carve the doors there. and here, and
whether there was any way to repair the
damage, and who still knew the skills of
wood carving, and what kinds of tools
were required.
Blue climbed the steps, and touched the
wooden door lightly with his talons.
She saw a sad look cross his face as he
glanced over at sundew.
He's thinking about what she might be
feeling.
Cricket guessed.
That thing he does, where he's always in
someone else's head.
She thought it was fascinating.
She wished she could remember to do it
like he did.
I could try now.
He's thinking, hmm.
Maybe that thing wood used for doors must
make sundo sad.
Because she misses the trees?
Any ideas?
sundew barked, poking cricket's
shoulder.
You 3 look half asleep.
Do I need to bring up Belladonna's other
plan and our time limit?
You do want to find the chrysalis?
Don't you?
Cricket shivered at the reminder.
The chrysalis had to have answers for
them.
If they wanted to stop Belladonna and the
other leaf wings.
It doesn't seem like they're coming
Swordtell said.
He peered off along the walls in either
direction.
We are missing something, Cricket said.
Five.
That was the 3rd part of the message.
Doors of the library?
But there are only these, from the ramps
and another set at the back that open out
to the Savannah.
Those will be closed at night too.
She scanned the plaza.
There are only 4 benches.
Nothing with a 5 on it, right?
Blue squinted at the doors.
I don't see any 5s up here.
Maybe the statue.
Like where the message was hidden in the
glitter bazaar?
Cricket walked around the statue of
Clearsight, looking for tiny cracks where
another leaf might be stuffed.
Nothing in the base, nothing under clear
sight talons.
Her neck curved toward the book.
The row of spines spiraling along her
back down her tail.
The spines were the only thing cricket
could see where there were more than 5 of
them.
She hopped up onto the statue's base, and
reached up to the top of Clearsight's
head.
One, two, three, four, five spines down
her back.
And there was something lodged under the
5th one.
A key.
She tugged it out and studied it in the
light of the flickering flame silk
globes.
What is it?
sundew asked, resting her front talons on
the base of the statue and lifting her
neck to see.
Our way into the library, I think, Cricket
said.
Sure enough, the key fit the lock on the
doors.
Sortell heaved one side open and they
slipped inside, one by one, while Cricket
returned the key to its hiding spot, and
then followed them.
Inside, there was a bolt to lock the
doors again behind them.
A kind of peace settled over cricket as
she stepped into the library.
She always felt this way when she was
surrounded by books.
She belonged here, even if she didn't fit
anywhere else.
In here, there were answers and
information, and 1000s of stories waiting
for her to fold herself into them.
She was always safe inside a book.
And this was her favorite of all the
libraries she knew.
Shelves radiated out from the central
desk in every direction, like a sunburst
and more aisles with more books filled
the balconies overhead.
Beloved characters were painted on the
walls, golden glass, and copper wire
dragons holding books, hung from the
ceiling far overhead, and blue silk
tapestries filled the rest of the open
space, woven with quotes about reading.
Hmm, sundew said quietly, glancing
around.
There's a lot of dead trees in here.
Cricket was startled out of her peace.
They're not.
I mean, maybe, but they're books. books
are everything.
And they're not all made from trees
right?
Blue offered.
Right.
Cricket shook out her wings, taking a
calming breath.
We mostly make paper from silk now.
Oh, good, Sundu answered.
You used up our resources and moved on to
exploiting a different tribe.
But the books are for us too, Blue said
for everyone.
I'd give all my soak to help build a
place like this.
He ducked his head and looked at cricket
and she wished she could throw her wings
around him and tell him how wonderful he
was.
Sundew wasn't wrong.
She kept opening Cricket's eyes in
moments when Cricket hadn't realized they
were closed, but blue was the reason she
could keep them open and still feel all
the things she felt.
He saw cricket.
He understood completely what this place
meant to her.
Shh, Sundu said.
Flicking her tail in front of Swordtail's
face, even though he hadn't said anything
at all.
She pointed up, and gave cricket a
quizzical look.
She could hear it too.
Voices, arguing, somewhere upstairs.
They could have flown up to the balcony
that overlooked the 1st floor, but their
wing beats might have scared away the
other dragons.
If they can hear anything over their own
voices, that is, Cricket thought, as they
crept up the stairs instead.
This was certainly the loudest stealth
meeting of a secret rebellion she'd ever
heard.
No, you're doing it wrong.
One of them shouted.
It's like you don't even care about what
we're trying to do here.
I'm focusing on what's actually
important.
Another one yelled back.
Tearing apart other silk wings isn't
going to get us anywhere.
We have to fix the problems in our own
tribe before we can stand together.
The 1st voice insisted.
I mean, if I think Argus is a lazy
caterpillar who doesn't understand our
mission, then it's useful for me to yell
at him until he sorts himself out.
I think it's cowardly.
The 2nd voice snapped back.
It's easy to yell at Argus because he's
on our side.
It's a lot easier than standing out to
the dragons we're supposed to be
fighting.
I'm sure your intentions are good, Morpho
pleaded a 3rd voice, as Cricket and her
friends crept through the stacks.
But what if you've scared him away, and
he never comes back.
Then good riddance.
The 1st voice snapped.
No, shouted the second.
We need every dragon we can get on our
side.
I'd rather have 50 silk wings or at least
trying to do the right thing than 3 who
are perfect in every way by your
standards.
Sundew crouched and snuck a glance around
the last corner.
Through the bookshelves, Cricket could
see bright blue wings flashing open and
closed, and the pale yellow scales of
another dragon close by.
They were in the back corner of the
library, farthest from the front doors.
Near a wall of windows that looked out
onto the dark savannah.
Cricket remembered this reading nook with
its hammocks and pillows.
The flame silk lamps were covered for the
night, but their light still glowed dimly
through the dark silk shades, illuminating
the books scattered on the windowsills
and the floor.
They should be more careful, Cricket
thought nervously.
Dragons flew between the levels all night
in Jewel Hive, flitting from one party to
another.
Someone could easily fly past the library
windows, glance inside, and wonder why a
group of Silk Wings was in the library
after dark.
You go out there first, Sundew whispered
to SwordTail, make sure they don't freak
out when they see the rest of us.
Me?
Swordtail said.
I mean, right.
Me.
Introductions, no freaking out.
No problem.
He squared his shoulders and took a deep
breath.
What should I say?
Just figure it out, sundew hissed.
You'll be great, Blue added reassuringly
as sundew shoved sore tail toward the
squabbling dragons.
Right.
Soratell said.
He cleared his throat, and stepped
between the hammocks into the dim circle
of light.
Excuse me?
Hi.
The silk wings whirled around and stared
at him.
I'm looking for the chrysalis, said
Swordtail.
One of the dragons snorted and spread his
wings at the other 2 silk wings with
him.
Well, congratulations, he said.
You've found us.
Chapter 11.
Oh, good, Swordtell said.
Great.
Hello, Chrysalis.
What kind of secret organization?
Just admits who they are to any idiot who
walks in?
Sundew muttered.
She flicked her tail, swiping cricket
with a billow of her cape.
They have no idea who he is or who he's
with.
Cricket crouched to get a clearer view
through the shelves, but she could still
only see 3 dragons in the reading nook.
Was that it?
The whole Jewel Hive faction of the
secret Silkwing rebellion was 3 arguing
dragons.
Why were you looking for us?
demanded the dragon with bright blue
wings?
He was the owner of the 1st voice, Morpho
if cricket remembered right.
His torso was dappled with iridescent sea
green scales, and little patches of white
ran down his tail.
But he had clearly been named for the
color of his wings, which were nearly as
vibrant as blues.
Maybe he wants to join us, said the pale
yellow dragon, hopefully.
Do you dream of a better world, friend?
Do you agree that all silk wings should
refuse to serve any hive wings in the
glitter bazaar?
The blue dragon demanded, and that we
should make lists of all the silk wings
who do so we can go yell at them?
Oh, honestly, morpho. said the 3rd dragon
rolling her eyes.
Soartail cleared his throat nervously.
Um, my name is Swordtail.
I am part of the cicada hive chrysalis.
I mean, sort of.
I was about to be, me and Luna.
And now she's missing.
Have you heard anything about a dragon
named Luna recently?
Has she come to you for help, maybe?
The 3 dragons blanked at him in
confusion.
I don't know anyone named Luna, said the
Yellow Dragon.
I'm sorry, she added, as sore tails wings
drooped.
She's a flame silk, he said.
We rescued her, but she might have been
recaptured by Wasp Pive.
Have you heard anything like that?
A silk wing taken prisoner over Dragonfly
Bay in the last 5 days.
They all shook their heads, and
swordtail's wings drooped even more.
Are you sure?
he asked.
Maybe she's hiding with another wing of
the chrysalis?
Maybe, the yellow dragon said gently.
We haven't heard anything.
Cricket reached over and squeezed one of
Blue's talons.
He looked so worried and sad.
She wished she had a tiny fraction of
Clearsight's power, so she could have a
vision of Luna, and let Blue know his
sister was all right.
Is that why you're here?
asked Morpho.
Just looking for another silkwing.
Not just that.
My friends and I were hoping you could
help us.
Sortell said.
Morpho squinted at the shelves behind
Swordtail, while the other 2 dragons
exchanged a worried glance.
Your friend.
Who's with you?
Sortell turned and beckoned.
Sundew rolled her eyes at cricket.
Very thorough introduction, sworn tail
she whispered.
This is going to go great.
Blue stepped out first, sliding up beside
SwordTail.
Before he could speak, the yellow silk
wing jumped forward with a gasp.
You're the one from the wanted posters.
Her pale yellow antennae unfurled all the
way, and she stared at him as if he were
a tree who'd just sprouted illegally in
the middle of the library floor.
Hey, I was on the posters too, Sortell
pointed out.
Are you really a flame silk?
The 3rd dragon asked, reaching toward
Blue's talons and then catching herself
and pulling back.
Yes, he said, turning his wrists upward
so she could see the embers glowing under
his scales.
Oh, wow, she said.
That was the rumor, but no one will
officially confirm it.
How did you escape?
And wasn't there a hive wing on that
poster with you?
Morpho asked suspiciously.
That's how.
Blue said to the dark orange dragon who
was studying his wrists.
And that's why she's wanted by the queen
too.
She helped me escape.
He turned and held out one talent toward
cricket.
Cricket?
Cricket took a deep breath and stepped
out to stand beside him.
Morpho leaped back and hissed an alarm.
The other 2 seized blankets off the floor
and threw them over their heads with high
pitched yelps of terror.
It's too late.
Morvo snapped at them.
She's already seen your faces.
I told you this was a stupid meeting
place.
No, you didn't, cried the small, dark
orange dragon from under her blanket.
You suggested it.
Cinnabar's right, agreed the muffled
voice of the yellow dragon.
It's not important who's right.
Morphos shouted, although it was me.
But what's important is that there's a
hive wing right here.
And what are we going to do about it?
And also, it was your fault we couldn't
meet at my better suggestions.
So there.
The yellow dragon winced, and Cricket
noticed that one of her back wings
sticking out from under the blanket at an
awkward angle, was smaller than all the
others.
She wondered if the silk wing could fly
at all.
Wait, wait, Cricket said, as the yellow
dragon started edging toward the nearest
aisle, with a blanket still over her
head.
You don't have to hide.
I'm a friend, I promise.
Friends, don't let their brains get
invaded and betray the revolution, said
Cinnabar, pulling her wings and tail
under her blanket and huddling into a
small boulder, as if she hoped everyone
would forget she'd been there.
That won't happen, Cricket said.
The mind control doesn't work on me.
The Silkwings fell silent for a moment
even Morpho, with his mouth half open.
Then the yellow dragon threw her blanket
off and stared at cricket.
Her wings.
Well, 3 of them were long and narrow, and
her scales were a mix of pale yellow and
pale brown, like bananas and cashews
mashed together.
She had dark amber eyes, and gold stripes
painted on her claws.
What are you talking about?
she asked.
Nope, not possible, Morpho declared.
Hive wing lie.
But it is possible, because there's me
Cricket said.
I know.
It's weird, and I can't explain it.
The queen can't get into my head, I
promise you.
I wish I knew why.
I've been trying to figure it out my
whole life.
And the closest I've gotten is the theory
that I'm half Silkwing.
But nothing about me is very silkwing.
I mean, I think I look like a hive wing
from horns to claw tips.
I don't have a natural weapon, but
neither do a lot of hive wings.
I know I'm different somehow.
But I still feel like a hive wing.
She decided not to mention the silk wing
theory yet.
She needed more evidence first.
This seems like a trick, Morpho
muttered.
He stalked toward her and peered into her
eyes.
His were the same emerald green as his
antennae, which curled and waved, as
though he was trying to sense the
presence of Queen Wasp inside her.
It could be true, said the yellow
dragon.
She could be like the ones we heard
about.
Cricket felt her heart speed up.
Other dragons like me?
Who?
We don't know for sure.
Cinnabar, come out and tell her about the
story you heard.
The blanket boulder side enormously, and
then the small orange silk wing poked her
head out.
If you're going to keep using my name in
front of total strangers, you could at
least introduce yourself too, Tao.
Oh, sorry, said the yellow dragon
gently.
I'm Tao.
That's Cinnabar, and that's Morpho.
And I never said I believed that story.
Cinnabara pointed out.
Her scales were a burnt orange, with
glints of dark red under her wings and
along her spine, with a few black scales
slightly different wings, and a much
scarier expression, she could almost have
passed for a hive wing.
What story?
Cricket asked.
Cinnabar flicked the blanket off with her
wings and edged closer to Tao.
It's just a rumor.
I heard it from a silkwing, who heard it
from his cousin, who heard it from a
traveling theater performer.
The whisper is that there is a home for
old dragons in Setsy Hive where none of
them are allowed to leave ever, because
the queen can't mind control them.
Fairy tale nonsense, Morpho Spat.
She controls everyone.
Now, Morpho, you know that's not true, Tao
said, she doesn't hive mind her sisters
or Lady Jewel.
She doesn't?
Cricket tilted her head.
She had never heard that before.
But she could, if she wanted to, Morpho
insisted.
She just doesn't, because she likes to
give them the illusion of control.
As long as they think they have their own
hives to run, they'll bow and scrape and
let her be the one who's really in charge
of everything.
You've said that before, Tao said.
A tiny sliver of impatience slipping
through her peaceful mask.
But I am sure it doesn't work on Lady
Jewel.
I've been with her when the whole hive is
taken over, like when the entire tribe
was sent to find these two.
She gestured at blue and cricket.
Three, Sword Tow protested, finally
looking up from his talons.
They're hunting for me too.
She finds it very irritating.
Tao went on.
Her whole day is disrupted, and all jewel
hive business has to be put on hold, and
she has to sit for hours waiting for her
subjects to come back.
She can't even hide how annoyed she is
from the silk wings who work for her.
That's true, Cinnabar agreed, even in the
kitchen we can tell.
It's nonstop sugar orders all day.
That doesn't prove anything.
Morpho argued, WASP probably enjoys
knowing how annoyed Jewel is.
I don't believe there's a single hive
wing she can't control if she wants to.
Listen.
Cricket said reasonably.
If Queen Wasp could control me, would I
be on a wanted poster?
Wouldn't she just march me into her hive
from inside my brain and use me to catch
these two?
Morpho opened and closed his mouth a few
times.
Oh, wow.
Cinnabar said, you actually shut Morpho
up for a moment.
You can definitely be in my chrysalis.
This is a trap, Morpho exploded.
Hive Wings can't be trusted. of them.
You're just mad because this proves what
Tao and I have been saying, Cinnabar
snapped back.
We could get high wings on our side, if
they were allowed to think for
themselves.
I don't know about that, Swordtell said.
Cricket might be the only one.
Cricket's scarves felt too tight around
her neck.
He had to be wrong.
The other high wings couldn't be lost
forever.
She just had to find a way to set them
free.
I think you're right.
She said to Cinnabar.
I mean, I hope so.
Do you know anything else about Queen
Wasp's mind control?
Like how it works or whether anyone's
ever managed to break free from it?
Tao blinked and shook her head sadly.
Oh, I see, she said.
You're trying to free someone too.
I'm sorry.
I've never heard of anyone escaping the
mind control.
And even if they did, Morpho growled.
All the hive wings have had Queen Wasp in
their heads for so long.
They can't think for themselves anyway.
They'll keep believing her lies, no
matter how free you think they are.
Cricket shivered.
Remembering her conversation with Katy
did.
I will get through to her.
If I keep telling her the truth, She'll
have to hear me.
She'll have to believe me.
Something flashed outside the window, like
silver catching the moonlight, but when
cricket turned to look, it was gone.
The night beyond the glass was empty.
Only Savannah grasses waved in the
midnight breeze.
I am not interested in wasting time on
hive wings.
Morpho said firmly.
I want to save silk wings.
There are enough of us to win if we join
together and rise up.
Tao was shaking her head.
There aren't, she said.
It's too dangerous.
Too many silk wings would die.
I'm sorry, Morpho, but we have no weapons
and they have the queen's hive mind.
Also, Stingers, said Swordtell
helpfully.
And venom, and toxic paralysis stabber
bits.
Sounds like you need an army.
Sundew said, timing her dramatic entrance
perfectly.
She emerged from behind the bookshelves
and threw off her cape.
Her leaf shaped wings gleamed gold and
green in the lamplight.
The chrysalis silk wings all gasped.
Tao sat back, and pressed her front
talons to her heart.
Cinnabar crouched as though she didn't
know whether to fly or fight or scream.
Morpho's eyeballs looked like they were
full of sunbeams.
Luckily for you, said Sundew, we've got
one.
Wait, but you're not going to use it.
Blue interjected.
Right, sundo?
That's why we're here, because we're
looking for a better solution.
We're going to find an answer for your
parents so they don't restart the tree
wars.
You heard these dragons.
There isn't one, she said, tossing her
head.
There's no way to break the hive mind.
So, backup plan.
I'm here to make contact with the
chrysalis.
If the silk wings are ready to join the
leaf wings this time, maybe the new tree
wars will turn out the right way.
But Sundew, Cricket started, horrified.
The leaf wing brushed pastor and held out
one talent cinnabar.
What do you say?
Care to destroy the hive wings together?
Chapter 12.
Sundo, Blue cried.
Cricket felt as though the floor was
turning to glue, trapping her claws in
place.
Sundew couldn't give up so quickly.
There had to be something, some answer
they just hadn't found yet.
Some way to save my tribe, to save all
our tribes, from a new war.
Yes, Morpho shouted, elbowing cinnabar
out of the way.
He took sundew's talon between his and
pumped it up and down.
We're in.
You don't speak for the whole chrysalis
Tao said to him.
Cricket realized there were tears in her
eyes as she stepped toward sundew.
You're alive, she whispered.
I thought you were all dead.
I thought we'd lost your whole tribe
forever.
Sundew looked taken aback.
We had no idea any of you cowards cared
she said, a little awkwardly.
And no, we are not all dead.
I cared, Cricket thought.
I was so thrilled to find real, actual
alive, leaf wings, hiding in Queen Wasp's
greenhouse.
Didn't she see that I cared?
Sundu?
What about freeing the hive wings?
she said.
We wanted to give them a chance to make
the right choice, remember?
We agreed that breaking the mind control
would help everyone.
Sundu shrugged.
Cascades of reflected gold glittering
along her wings.
Like I suspected all along, it can't be
done.
The only option is to crush the hive
wings completely.
Yes!
Morvo shouted again.
Fine by me, said Swortail.
I'm with sundew.
Blue took a step closer to cricket so he
could brush her wings with his.
This isn't right, he said.
There are good hive wings.
I'm sure of it.
I don't think we can solve a tragedy of
the past by just repeating it in
reverse.
Well, I don't think we can solve a
current tragedy. by sitting around trying
to understand the bad guys.
Sundew snapped.
I don't want to hug a bunch of hive wings
and listen to their problems.
I want them all punished.
Cricket buried her face and her talons.
I would feel the same way in her place
wouldn't I?
But these were still her dragons.
She couldn't give up on her entire tribe
on Katy Did, and Lady Scarab, and the
librarian, and the little dragonettes on
her street, and her father, even if he
wasn't her real father, and the students
who'd shared books, and seeds with her at
school, she had to believe they were
better than what Queen Wasp had turned
them into, and that they could still be
saved.
Where do we start?
Morpho asked.
What do we have to do?
Cinnabar glanced at Tao.
Wait.
Not all of us want to kill all the hive
wings, she said.
Or any hive wings.
Blue interjected.
How many silk wings are in the
chrysalis?
Sundu asked, ignoring them.
Tell me there are more than 3 of you.
Oh yes, said Morpho.
In this hive, there are 7 of us.
Sundew did not look impressed.
Seven.
Yes, he said.
Well, maybe six.
If you scared Argus away forever, Cinnabar
added.
Why aren't the others here?
Sundu flict your gays over the 3 of them
and frowned slightly.
They couldn't make it tonight?
Tao said.
One had to make costumes for her
Dragonette's school play.
Another has an early morning meeting.
And what did Tamara say?
She asked Cenabar.
That she was too tired, Morpho answered
disapprovingly.
Really, Sundoo said.
Very dedicated to this rebellion, are
they?
To be fair, Cinnabar said, we haven't
exactly done much at the last few
meetings or ever.
Actually, ever.
I mean, how can 7 dragons change
anything?
We know there are more silk wings and
other hives who want to fight back too
but it's just, everyone's busy with their
lives, and no one knows what to do, and I
don't know.
It's overwhelming.
But now that you're here, Morvo said to
Sundu, it's very clear, right?
Bring in your army, violence everywhere.
Silk Wings help you, things get better.
How?
Sundu asked.
How exactly do the silk wings help us?
Morpho shifted his wings with a confused
expression.
By doing whatever you want us to do?
Maybe pointing to the worst hive wings?
Cheering when you kill them?
Sundew side and rubbed her forehead.
There was another flash outside the
window.
Again, Cricket only saw it out of the
corner of her eye, and when she turned
nothing was there.
Maybe it was distant lightning.
She pulled her scarves closer, and
stepped up to the dark glass.
For a moment, all she saw was her
reflection and the reflections of the
dragons behind her.
For a moment, she was inside a glass box
with strangers, the piece that didn't
fit.
And then her eyes adjusted, just in time
to see a pair of dragons swoop by right
below the level of the window.
A pair of hive wings, wearing armor and
carrying weapons, and heading around the
curve of the hive toward the back door of
the library.
She whirled around.
I think we've been seen.
Unlikely.
No one pays attention to the library
Morpho argued.
Shh.
Sundew commanded, raising one claw.
They all fell silent.
A soft, rattling sound came from the
front door of the library, as though
someone was trying a series of keys in
the lock.
Cinnabar and Tau exchanged wide eyed
looks.
They're at the back too.
Cricket whispered.
Do we fight our way out?
Soratel asked Sundoo.
We don't know how many there are, Cinnabar
said, and if any of them have Queen Wasp
in them, she can summon a whole lot more
in a heartbeat.
Can you do that?
Morpho asked Sundu.
Summon a whole bunch of ferocious leaf
wings.
Not with my mind, she said crossly.
Is there any other way out of the
library?
Tao shook her head.
Maybe if a couple of us attack them, the
others can escape.
She suggested, I don't want to leave
anyone in the claws of the hive wings
Blue said quietly.
Sundew whirled toward Cricket.
Your hiding place.
You must have one nearby.
Show us where you'd go if wasp hive
minded everyone while you're in here.
Cricket hesitated.
She didn't know of all 7 of them would
fit.
She also felt like there should be some
conversation about betrayal and broken
promises here, but there wasn't exactly
time.
This way.
She hurried through the aisles with all
of them wrestling behind her.
At the edge of the balcony, she vaulted
over without stopping, and sailed down to
the 1st floor.
When she looked back, she saw Cinnabar
throw Tao's weak pair of wings over one
of her shoulders, so she could support
the yellow dragon down to the next
level.
As soon as they landed, Tao's wings
folded back in, and she was running
again.
On either side of the front doors, and on
either side of the back doors, stood a
tall column, built into the wall and
stretching from floor to ceiling.
This was the book drop, with slots on the
outer walls, where dragons could slide in
their returned books.
On the inner walls, each column had a
door half as tall as a dragon, which the
librarians could open to pull out the
returned books.
Cricket tugged one open and pointed
inside.
Got it, Cinnabar whispered.
Come on, Tao.
The 2 of them ran off toward the back
doors.
To hide in one of the columns there.
I'm going with a leaf wing, Morpho
declared.
He ducked in through the door, Cricket
was holding open, scrunching himself
around the pile of books inside, and held
out one talon towards sundew.
I can see how I deserve that, Sundu
said.
But no, you get sword tail.
She bundled Swordtail into the cramped
space with Morpho and closed the door on
their protesting faces.
Don't you want to be with your new
chrysalis friends?
Cricket couldn't help asking.
Sundu hurried across to the other column
just as they all heard a click from the
front door.
Cricket's heart tried to hurl itself out
of her chest.
She scrambled inside the book drop
burrowing through and up the pile of
teetering library books inside.
A moment later, Blue squeezed in beside
her, and then the space went dark as
sundew leaped inside and shut the door
behind her.
Cricket braced herself against the walls
and edged upward a little, but her wings
were tangled with blues, and their scales
were pressed so close together that she
could feel his heart beating all the way
through her own chest.
He rested one talon on the wall behind
her, his cape drifting around them like
extra silken wings.
She tucked her head under his chin
breathing in the scent of old books, and
blue, who smelled a bit like fried
bananas.
Below them, she could sense the poised
still form of sundew, still half buried
in books.
The slide for the books from the upper
slot ended near Cricket's head, and the
edge dug into her neck, but she didn't
dare try to move away from it.
I hope everyone else can be quiet.
She thought anxiously.
If the soldiers found dragons in one book
drop, they'd check the rest and find all
of them.
This wasn't the smartest hiding place.
We should have spread out more.
Finally, said a voice outside the book
drop.
Blue tensed, sending little shivers
through cricket's scales.
Sorry that took so long.
Lady Jewel has a lot of keys.
And I suppose half of them are entirely
decorative, sneered another voice
unfamiliar, but also unmistakably in the
thrall of Queen Wasp.
Cricket had heard that sinister cadence
so many times in situations just like
this, hiding in the dark, while the queen
used her subjects as puppets.
Not just like this.
She felt Blue's shoulder, cool and smooth
against her neck.
This time, I'm not alone.
Open the back doors for the others, and
then search every corner.
The queen ordered through the hive wing's
mouth.
Cricket heard 2 sets of talons walking
away.
She wondered why the queen wasn't inside
them too.
Or if she was now.
She might have needed one of them inside
his own brain to get the library doors
open.
She guessed.
The hive wing would supposedly have a
better idea of which key would work than
the queen would.
It still took a while though, she thought
gratefully.
Was that on purpose?
Did that hive wing help us by taking
longer than he needed to?
Perhaps that was wishful thinking?
He didn't know who was in here, if
anyone.
Maybe he just wanted to annoy the queen.
Whatever his reasons, or even if he'd
done it by accident, she was thankful.
A long time seemed to pass.
They heard talon steps and thumps, as
though boxes were being overturned
somewhere.
No sign of anyone, your majesty, a voice
reported, after a long while.
I know I saw dragons in here.
The hive wing with the queen inside
hissed.
Find them, or you will die.
Blue flinched, and Cricket tensed for a
moment, wondering if she had accidentally
scratched him.
But then she realized.
Oh, he's worried about the hive wings out
there.
And what Queen Wasp will do to them if
they don't find us.
She didn't dare risk whispering.
But she wished she could tell him that
she'd never seen the queen force a dragon
to hurt himself while she was controlling
him.
As they'd seen in the Temple of
Clearsight, Wasp felt the same pain as
the dragons she was controlling, and she
would jump out of their minds if the pain
was too much.
But she could still force a dragon to
hurt someone else.
There was nothing they could do, though
except turn themselves in, and cricket
wasn't going to let Blue do that.
She was pretty sure Sundoo wouldn't let
him either.
Come out, you sniveling cowards.
Wasp's voice roared suddenly.
I know there are dragons hiding in this
library.
Show yourselves, or I will burn all the
books until you die choking on the
smoke.
Burn the books?
She can't.
She wouldn't.
Jewel wouldn't let her.
Could she stop the queen though?
Wouldn't burning the books put the rest
of the hive in danger too?
Maybe wasp doesn't care about that.
Maybe she'd burn down the whole hive to
smoke us out.
Cricket heard a soft hiss from sundew
below her.
Sundew couldn't give herself up.
She was the one holding the book of
Clearsight, and they needed that to prove
Queen Wasp was lying.
She wouldn't let Blue go either.
As long as his flame silk was part of the
leaf wing plan.
But Cricket.
She wasn't any use to the leaf wings
really.
What would happen to her if she turned
herself into the queen?
Would she kill me?
Her wings were trembling, and she
couldn't make them stop.
I am not brave.
I am not a warrior.
I don't want to put myself in Queen
Wasp's talents, not even to save all the
books.
But if I don't, what happens to blue and
sundo?
As if he could hear her thoughts, Blue
curled himself closer to her and held her
tightly, absorbing her trembling in his
own wings.
Very well, said the queen's voice, build
me a bonfire of books right here. she
ordered.
We'll use flame silk from the lanterns.
But, Your Majesty.
What if the fire spreads?
asked one of the hive wings.
Then we'll have to throw you into it to
slow the flames, the queen snarled.
You are a tedious talon ringer.
I'll do it myself.
Cricket heard the dragons snap suddenly
to attention, and run off toward the
stacks without any further argument.
She guessed that Queen Wasp had taken
them over as well.
Wait.
Below her.
Cricket heard a book slide down the
pile.
Sundew caught it deftly before it could
thunk against the side.
They all held their breaths, frozen in
place, caught by the sound of Cinnabar's
voice in the library.
We are sorry.
We're sorry, my queen.
Very sorry.
That was Tao.
What are they doing?
We were hiding from Lady Jewel, Cinnabar
said breathlessly.
She said we were spending too much time
reading, and not enough time on our work
for her.
So, we've been sneaking out at night to
read here, Tao said.
We didn't mean to anger you.
Please don't tell Lady Jewel.
She'll punish us terribly.
As she should.
The queen's voice snapped.
I told her this library would be
trouble.
I don't stand for disobedient silk wings
in my hive.
Who else is with you?
Cricket squeezed her eyes shut?
As though the darkness around her could
get any darker.
No one, your majesty, said Tao.
My cousin Morpho came to scold us earlier
Cinnabar offered, but he left a little
while ago.
Blue wings, said the queen suspiciously.
I thought I saw blue wings.
That would be Morpho, Cinnabar said, or
the blankets we sometimes use up there.
Do you want me to show those to you?
No.
The shell of the dragon that held the
queen hissed.
This is a waste of time.
You.
Take these 2 back to Lady Jewel and tell
her, I said, to punish them severely.
Sorry again, Your Majesty.
Tao said.
Cricket tried to figure out how many
talon steps were leaving the library.
How many were left?
Was the queen still inside all of them?
Would anyone lock the door again?
Would the queen leave guards on the
library?
How long do they have to wait before it
was safe to come out?
The tramping of most of the feet faded
away.
But she could still hear claws scraping
across the floor.
Someone was still out there.
It felt as though a long time passed, but
sundew didn't open the door of the book
drop, and Cricket figured she would know
when it was safe to do that.
She had just shifted to lean against
Blue's shoulder when she heard running
steps outside.
Your Majesty, are you still there?
said a voice.
Yes.
Wasp answered coldly. sounding as if she
was standing directly on the other side
of the wall from cricket.
What is it?
We've had a tip that Lady Scarab is here
in Dual Hive, and she may be hiding
another dragon in her mansion.
Lady scarab.
The queen's voice hissed, she would.
Let's go pay Lady Scarab a visit.
Their talent steps crashed out of the
library, and cricket looked up so quickly
her snout knocked into Blue's chin.
They're talking about Katy did, she
whispered.
They're going to arrest my sister.
Chapter 13.
Cricket tried to scramble downward, but
accidentally started a cascade of books.
Ow!
Sundew whispered from below her.
Quit that.
Stop moving right now.
I have to get to Katy did, Cricket
whispered back.
Her wings bent awkwardly against the
curving walls.
To do what?
Sundew demanded.
There's nothing you can do to help her.
I could try to warn her.
Won't Queen Wasp have jumped into Katy
did already, now that she knows where she
is?
Blue whispered.
Maybe not.
Cricket tried to edge down a bit
farther.
Sometimes it seems like she needs to know
who a dragon is or see her before she can
get inside her head.
So she'll jump into Scarab, Sundew
pointed out.
Take one look at your sister, jump into
her and off they go.
There's no way you can get there in
time.
Couldn't I try?
Cricket pleaded.
She thought for a moment.
Wait, I don't need your permission.
You've already decided you're not going
to help me.
So why should I listen to you?
She started scrambling down the column
again, kicking more books aside.
Ah, stop, Sundew said, squishing herself
to one side to get out of cricket's way.
Listen, I'm not going to help your try
because they're a lost cause, and they
deserve everything they get.
But you're not like them.
You can join our side and be safe.
As long as I forget about Katy did
Cricket said, and let you heart a whole
lot of dragons who never fought in any
war against you, no, thank you.
She wrestled Sunday's tale out of her way
and shoved the door open, tumbling out
into the library in a small avalanche of
books.
The front lobby of the library was
deserted, the main door is standing wide
open.
The door on the column opposite hers
snuck open a crack, and SwordTail's snout
poked out.
Oh, thank goodness, he said.
The sun do think it's safe to come out?
This guy is insufferable, even in total
silence.
Ow.
He twisted around to glare at the blue
tail point that was jabbing him in the
head.
I'm telling you, Sundew said.
Climbing out behind Cricket.
It's not going to do any good to go watch
your sister get arrested.
It'll just upset you, and you might get
caught.
I'm going anyway.
Cricket said, starting toward the
courtyard.
And I'm going with her, said Blue.
He clambered out of the book drop and
started shoveling books back into it.
I'm going wherever cricket goes.
Sundew stamped her foot in frustration.
All right, fine.
Let me get my stupid cape.
She stormed off to the upper level.
Cricket came back to help Blue shoulder
the door of the book drop closed with all
the books inside.
Good idea, she said to him, in case we
need these hiding spots again.
Oh, right, he said.
Yes, absolutely that.
She couldn't help smiling at him.
You were trying to save the librarians
some work, weren't you?
They have enough mess to clean up, he
said sheepishly, waving his wings at the
rest of the library.
Where boxes of books lay tumbled on their
sides.
A few shelves had been knocked completely
over, and it looked as if everything on
the desks that wasn't nailed down had
been thrown around.
Where are we going?
SwordTell asked, as Sundew came flying
back toward them.
Ow, again, he yelped, as Marfo fell out
of the book drop and squashed his tail.
To get cricket arrested as far as I can
tell, Sundu grumbled, throwing the
saffron colored silk cape over her
wings.
I have to get home, Morpo said.
My dad worries if I'm out too late.
I want to meet everyone in the Jewel Hive
Chrysalis today.
Sundew said to him, outside the hive, next
to the farthest stall of the glitter
bazaar, when the sun is at its highest
point.
He nodded, his eyes shining, and flew
off.
Cricket was already leading the way up to
the higher levels. thinking about
sunset.
That's how long we have until Bella Dawn
is deadline.
We have to bring her something real by
then, or hive wings will start to die.
Her heart thudded painfully in her
chest.
She liked sundew, most of the time, and
being with sundew had made her start
thinking all leaf wings were like that.
But when she stopped to remember Sundew's
parents, Belladonna and hemlock, she felt
an almost crushing fear for the rest of
her tribe.
The higher levels were the busiest at
this time of night, as hive wings swarmed
from one party to another, always rushing
to make sure they didn't miss anything, to
make sure they made at least an
appearance everywhere.
Many of them had their most beautiful
silk wings along with them, although at
this hour, Cricket could see that the
rules were more relaxed.
Silk Wings and Hive Wings chatted to one
another, as they walked or browsed the
appetizer tables.
Silkwings joined the dances in the
ballrooms, laughing and singing along.
There are hive wings here, who see the
silk wings as equals.
She was sure of it.
Hive wings who might be willing to join a
revolution to stop the queen and change
the rules of this world.
If they could.
If they were given a chance, before the
leaf wings started a new war.
Lady Scarab's mansion was one of the only
quiet ones up here.
No music rang from the windows, no
dragons fluttered in and out, but a squad
of hive wings were gathered on her front
steps, some of them tapping their claws
impatiently.
Open this door, scarab.
The queen roared from inside one of the
soldiers.
A short way down the street, Cricket
ducked into a party that overflowed the
edges of an elegant courtyard.
Nearly invisible strands of silk draped
from the hedges and arches and gazebo
hung with tiny firefly sculptures, each
one with a small dot of flame silk inside
so the party seemed to be dotted with
real fireflies.
A trio of silk wings played quiet string
instruments in a corner.
Several of the guests turned around with
disapproving looks when they heard the
shouting at scarab's house, then turned
back quickly, making their faces blank
when they realized who was doing the
shouting.
Cricket slipped through the crowd and
picked up a fizzy coconut scented drink
from one of the tables, trying to look as
though she went to parties all the time.
This was perfectly normal.
Parties were easy and fun.
Ha ha.
Yes.
Hooray for socializing.
That was absolutely a thing she liked to
do.
The other 3 stayed close to her. looking
possibly even more conspicuous than she
did. wide eyed blue, scowling sundew, and
twitchy sword tail.
But the crush of dragons made it unlikely
anyone would stop and examine them
closely.
Try this one.
Cricket heard his silkwing say, scooping
a glass of something fuchsia from one of
the many sparkling punch bowls scattered
on tables around the party.
The hive wing he handed it to tasted the
drink and made a face.
Scarab. bellowed the queen, and Cricket
saw everyone at the party trying to hide
their reactions. irritation here, fear
over there, that one perhaps glee.
Those 2 definitely curiosity.
The soldiers pounded on the door with
talons and tails and spiky clubs.
Open this door or I'll.
The door flew open.
And one of the soldiers nearly fell
inside.
Lady Scarab glared out at the knot of
dragons on her doorstep.
Cricket had to crane her neck to see the
elderly dragon around a few other party
goers.
She wasn't the only one.
Now, several guests were staring openly
down the street at a commotion.
Or you'll what?
Lady Scarab demanded.
Oh no, whispered a hive wing standing
near cricket.
Do you think she's going to do that smell
thing?
whispered another.
Her friend nodded.
Come on, let's sneak out before it
becomes unbearable up here.
The 2 hive wings wove away toward the
ramps in a hurry.
Cricket saw a crimson dragon by the food
table, probably the host, glanced
despairingly around as a few others
sidled off too.
Who else is here?
The queen demanded.
A young friend of mine?
Lady Scarab snapped.
She's asleep, like a sensible dragon.
So take your goons and shut up and go
away.
Small gasps sounded from around the
party.
And cricket saw one silk wing
accidentally drop her glass with a tiny
smash.
Bring her out.
Wasp.
She's none of your concern.
Surely you have more important things to
do.
Just leave her be.
The wide-eyed soldier hissed and lashed
his tail.
Prove to me she's not the traitor we're
looking for.
She is not.
Scarab snapped exasperated.
Haven't you taken enough from me, WASP?
This dragon has done you no harm.
Scarab is arguing with her.
Cricket suddenly realized with a jolt.
She's arguing with Queen Wasp.
She's saying no to her.
Queen Wasp wouldn't cause a scene like
this if she could avoid it.
That must mean, she can't control Lady
Scarab.
Scarab is like me.
She's free from the mind control.
Who is in there, scarab?
The queen demanded.
All of the soldiers' eyes turned white.
The party suddenly went very quiet behind
cricket.
Uh-oh.
She darted a glance sideways.
The hive wing beside her had white eyes
as well.
Cricket guessed everyone at the party had
been taken over.
The silkwings were still murmuring to one
another, but their voices slowly faded to
silence.
Cricket kept her head down, hoping her
eyes were hidden by the folds of the blue
veil around her horns.
All the hive wings had their heads turned
toward scarab's house, alert, and coiled
like angry snakes.
So far, they were a threat, not yet a
weapon.
As long as she stayed still, with luck, no
one would look closer at her.
Her heart constricted, eating all the air
in her chest.
You stay out of my house, wasp.
Lady Scarab said furiously.
You have no right to poke your snout in.
I have every right.
I am your queen.
The voice came from all the hive wings on
the street now.
It was chilling to hear it so close.
The breath of all the stolen guests
shivering across cricket's wings.
On scarab's steps, 2 of the hive wings
stepped forward, and menacing stingers
slid out from under their claws.
You're a creepy old bat.
Scarab shouted.
Your mother would hate to see what you've
done with her tribe.
Lucky for us that she's dead then.
Scarab hissed at the stingers reaching
toward her.
Suddenly, the soldiers staggered back
their eyes watering.
All the dragons on her front steps
covered their snouts.
A moment later.
The smell rolled over the party.
Cricket had heard of dragons with
scarab's power, and she'd even smelled a
fraction of it once, when Scarab was
annoyed by some dragonettes in her way at
the market.
But this had to be the full force
weaponized version of it, like dead
rotting things pickled in sulfur.
It made her want to claw off her own
nose.
She saw the white eyes flicker out of the
faces around her.
She guessed the queen couldn't stand to
experience it through so many dragons.
Several of the party guests dropped their
drinks and ran for the stairs.
I will come here and kill you myself if I
have to.
Wasp snarled from one of the soldiers
mouths.
Ha, said Lady Scarab, doing your own
dirty work.
Doesn't sound like you wasp.
Lady scarab.
Cricket felt cracked shiver across her
heart.
Katy did had appeared beside scarab
touching the older dragon's shoulder
gently.
Scarab's wings drooped.
Idiot child.
I could have kept you safe.
I don't want you to get in trouble for me
Katie did said.
There's no reason to.
I haven't done anything wrong.
I'll come with you willingly, she said to
the guards.
Hmm.
Familiar, but not the dragon I'm looking
for.
What an interesting mystery, said the
queen.
Some relation to my missing friend, I'm
guessing.
Lady Scarab only glared at her, but Katy
did dropped her gaze to her feet.
Well, said the queen, perhaps we can find
a use for her.
Katy did, looked up again, and her eyes
were blank as the faces of the moon's
empty, like the husks of spider eaten
grubs.
Nice try, lady scarab, the queen said
with Katy did's mouth, Katy did's voice
Katy did's mind.
I'm sure I'll be seeing you again soon.
And then Katy did stepped out of the
house, joined the group of high wing
soldiers, and marched away.
Chapter 14.
Lady Scarab slammed the door of her
mansion hard enough to make the firefly
lanterns rattle all over the courtyard
down the street.
The trio of Silk Wings quickly started
the music again, and the babble of
conversation rose, a little strained, and
a little higher pitched than before.
A few more guests made excuses to the
host, who was stirring a pale green tea
dejectedly, and vanished toward the ramps
to find safer, better smelling parties.
Sundew came up beside cricket, twitching
her cape a little closer around her.
I don't understand how you all live like
this, she whispered.
We don't have a choice, Cricket whispered
back.
But did you see Scarab fighting back?
Don't you think she must be like me?
Maybe she knows how the mind control
works.
And if she does.
Maybe she can help me save Katy did.
That's the only thing I can do.
There's no way to rescue Katie did, unless
I can free her from the mind control.
Oh no.
Sundew muttered, you want to go over
there, to the house your queen literally
just rated.
So she's hardly likely to come back right
away, right?
Cricket said.
Sundoo shook her head and moved to one of
the bowls, scooping a dark purple liquid
out of it, and sniffing it suspiciously.
I should go find my parents.
I have to tell them that our plan didn't
work.
She sighed.
The chrysalis knew nothing helpful about
the mind control, nor did they seem like
particularly useful allies, but I'll ask
Belladonna what she wants me to do with
them.
Wait, Cricket said, feeling a surge of
panic.
Send you, please, we still have until
sunset.
Don't go yet.
Give me the rest of today to try to find
some answers.
The party host advanced and perfume, and
was wandering the courtyard, trying to
inconspicuously spritz it everywhere.
Sundew wrinkled her snout at him.
Fine.
You can try, she whispered, but don't get
your hopes up.
And you can't take Blue to Scarab's house
with you.
We don't know if we can trust that old
hive wing, and he's too valuable to
risk.
Blue protested, but Cricket agreed with
her.
She didn't know how Lady Scarab would
react to blue. or how she felt about silk
wings in general.
She was the only wealthy high wing
cricket knew of who had no silk wing
servants.
Cricket got the impression she disliked
them only about as much as she disliked
all dragons, but Lady Scarab was very
unpredictable, and Cricket didn't want to
put blue in any danger.
All right, she whispered.
If I don't come back before the party
ends.
Meet me at the statue in the glitter
bazaar.
She turned and touched one of Blue's
talons lightly with hers, wishing she
could hug him, but not sure whether the
rules could bend quite that far.
Be careful, he said softly, as she
slipped away.
The guests who remained were valiantly
trying to ignore Lady Scarab's residence
and the odor that still lingered around
it.
Still, Cricket was afraid that knocking
on the front door might catch the
attention of the more gossipy dragons, so
she tried walking in the opposite
direction, and circling through the
streets until she reached the side of the
mansion, where a smaller door was set
into the wall.
She knocked nervously, and stood for a
long, anxious moment, gazing up at the
weathered tree stuff that formed the
outside of the mansion.
Most wealthy dragons, kept their homes
neatly maintained, and constantly updated
with new features.
But the green jade beetles inlaid in even
rows, looked as though they had been put
in decades ago.
Maybe when the house was 1st built.
Some of them were even missing.
Although Cricket couldn't tell whether
they'd been pried loose and stolen, or
whether they had fallen out, and nobody
cared.
The door swung open abruptly, making
cricket jump.
No, Lady Scarab barked. and slammed the
door shut again.
Wait.
Cricket knocked more firmly.
Lady Scarab, wait.
The door flew open mid knock, and Cricket
nearly wrapped the elderly dragon on the
nose.
Go away.
Lady Scarab shouted.
It's me.
Cricket said quickly, shoving her veil
aside to reveal her face.
Please, lady scarab.
Oh, by all the stupid moons, scarab
growled.
She grabbed Cricket by one of the scarves
and yanked her inside, almost throttling
her in the process.
Cricket stumbled into a poorly lit
kitchen, bare and cold.
One flame silk lamp sat alone on the
central table, its light dim, as though
the thread had almost faded completely.
Next to it were 2 plates, neatly stacked
and a small glass jar of pale lavender
sugar cubes.
In the sink, she spotted the bones of a
bird, but there was no other food in
sight.
The walls were empty.
Except for 2 small paintings on either
side of the stove, one, a lemon tree, the
other, an orange tree, trees?
Cricket thought, startled.
No one was allowed to make art with trees
in it, no one was allowed to have art
with trees in it.
She squinted at them and saw the spidery
cracks in the canvas.
Maybe they were quite old, from before
the laws about trees and art.
Still, it was bold of scarab to have kept
them.
Come on, you nuisance.
Scarab muttered, grabbing the lamp and
stomping past cricket into the next
room.
This one was much bigger, reaching all
the way to the back wall of the mansion
where tall sliding glass doors led to a
balcony, overlooking the moonlit
savannah.
Perhaps it had been a ballroom once, or
at least intended for hosting grand
parties.
But now it felt like a giant empty
terrarium, with only one seed rattling
around inside it.
It was also cold and sparsely decorated
especially for a dragon who seemed as
rich as Lady Scarab.
A polished old wood bookcase filled the
opposite wall, lined with books that
looked as though they might crumble if
you actually touched them.
One dark green floor pillow was set by
the balcony doors, as though the only
place she wanted to sit was near the exit
with a view of the stars.
Lady Scarab set the lamp on the low table
and sat down on the pillow, leaving
Cricket standing awkwardly in the middle
of the room.
Well, the old dragon demanded.
After all this trouble, at least tell me
you brought the book.
Surprised, cricket said.
My friend has it.
What do you know about the book?
Not enough, Lady Scarab growled.
I wanted to get my claws on it for
years.
I assume you read it.
What happens next?
Say the words, wasp dies slowly and
horribly, and I'll make you my heir.
Cricket was startled into almost
laughing.
No, no, she said, recovering quickly.
It's not like that.
That's the thing.
There are no more predictions in it.
Clearside only saw a few 100 years into
the future.
There's nothing about now.
Nothing about the last 1000 years.
Queen Wasp has been lying to us.
Lady Scarab's eyes were like small, dark
coals, with flickers of dark red in their
depths.
Those eyes pinned cricket to the bare
floor for a long, agonizing moment.
What?
Scarab spat.
The tree wars were all a lie.
Clearsight never saw that.
The silkwing queen giving up her throne
so her tribe would bow to Queen Wasp.
That wasn't in there either.
Scarab breathed deeply in and out through
her nose.
I suppose, she said icily.
There wasn't a list of the hive wing
queen succession line either.
No, Cricket said.
What's that?
A list.
Allegedly?
Of who should be queen, and who should
succeed her?
From Clearside's time all the way until
now.
Lady Scarab let out her breath again in a
long hiss through her teeth.
So my mother was lying about the book
too.
And so was my sister.
Both lying, in fact, about the fact that
my sister cochineal had to be queen.
I suppose mother realized she was always
a much better liar than I was.
The most essential quality for a queen
who had to rule by deceiving her entire
tribe about their most sacred artifact.
What a lovely, lovely royal family we
are.
She picked up a paintbrush from a tray
beside the pillow, and Cricket realized
there was a small easel there as well.
The half finished painting, as far as she
could see, was of a wasp, being eaten by
ants.
She shivered.
Lady Scarab shoved her spectacles higher
up her nose and squinted at cricket.
The queen would very much like to kill
you, you know.
Tell me.
Why aren't you hiding in some distant
corner of the continent?
I have some questions, Cricket said.
Ah.
Lady Scarab interrupted.
Curiosity.
That never ends badly.
Carry on.
The queen can't mind control me, Cricket
blurted.
Yes, said Lady Scarab.
I gathered that from the you not marching
yourself off to jail right now.
But why?
Why can't the queen mind control you?
Cricket asked.
Or me?
I have no idea.
Lady Scarab waved the paintbrush at
cricket.
Next question.
How can you have no idea?
Cricket asked.
Don't you know how it works?
Apparently, I am not among those blessed
with the secrets of my noble family.
Lady Scarab snarked.
In any case, nobody knows why WASP can do
what she does.
No other dragon has ever done it before.
Ever?
Cricket echoed.
In all of Penthalen history?
Are you sure?
Of course, I'm sure.
The Royal Hivewing stabbed her paintbrush
into a puddle of red paint and started
adding thin lines of blood coming out of
the wasp in her painting.
Cricket had a feeling this particular
piece of art might be even more poorly
received than the trees in the kitchen.
I've got history books going back
centuries.
I've traced the family trees as far out
as I can.
Not a single hive wing with mind control
powers, all the way back to Clearsight, as
far as I could find.
And it certainly didn't come from her
silk wing husband's.
Silkwing?
Cricket said, extremely startled.
Husbands?
Yes, of course.
Lady Scarab snapped.
Maybe they weren't called silk wings back
then.
Shimmer Wings, or Flibberty Gibbets, or
something in the old language.
I don't know.
But Clearsight married one.
And then another one when the 1st one
died, and had an alarming number of
dragonettes with each one, and then their
dragonettes, dragonettes kept going
marrying ye old silk wings, or what have
you, until there was enough of them to be
considered their own tribe.
Hive wings.
Stupid, menacing name, if you ask me.
It was only about 500 years ago that we
officially split into 2 separate tribes
you know.
My charming great great grandmother was
the queen who ordered no more mingling of
the bloodlines.
She was a nightmare.
We're related to Silk Wings?
Cricket said again.
Really?
Mighty scarab squinted at her with
concern.
Oh, dear.
Are you thick?
she asked.
I thought Katie did, said you were rather
clever.
It is perfectly obvious that hive wings
must have started with clear sight
marrying a silk wing.
Cricket did feel like rather an idiot.
In her defense, history was the most
neglected subject at Terrarium Academy.
Well, she said indignantly, it is also
perfectly obvious that hive wing books
leave that out on purpose because they
don't want any of us to know that.
True, said Lady Scarab, settling back to
her painting, which was getting Gorier by
the moment.
That was probably also my great great
grandmother's idea.
Ooh, she was a whore show.
Did any of Clearsight's children inherit
her prophecy powers?
Cricket asked.
She'd always wondered about that.
Hivewings had all sorts of weird powers
pop up throughout the tribe, but nothing
like clear sights.
The mind control had seemed the closest
to her, being at least kind of mental.
Not according to the records.
Scarab coughed violently.
But then, if I were clear sight, I tell
my kids to keep that information to
themselves.
If you know the future, but no one else
knows you know the future, you've got an
advantage.
See?
Ha!
She started coughing again, finally
sputtering to a wheezing stop.
Maybe I am related to my family after
all.
Crickets started to pace up and down the
long empty room.
Through the haze of drizzling rain
outside.
She thought she could see a faint line of
gray along the horizon, which meant
sunrise was coming, which meant sunset
was getting ever closer.
So why doesn't the mind control work on
us, she said.
Let's think.
Do we have anything in common?
Is there anyone else who's free of it?
Wasps sisters, answered Lady Scarab.
And Jewel, although a wasp has threatened
her with it a few times.
Threatened her with it?
Cricket echoed, pausing for a moment.
Like, she could mind control her, if she
wanted to?
Lady Scarab shrugged helpfully.
Hmm, Cricket went back to pacing.
Do you know anything about a home for old
dragons in Setsy Hive, where they're kept
because none of them are controllable?
No, Lady Scarab said, narrowing her
eyes.
But I have noticed that I am the oldest
dragon I know.
All of my friends started dying off, or
vanishing during the tree wars.
Most of them were loudly against the war
so I wasn't too surprised.
But some of them went funny before they
went, saying weird things that weren't
like themselves.
Strange flutters, like curtains in their
eyes.
Cricket tipped her head to the side.
As though their eyes were flashing white
then back to normal.
Scarab nodded.
I saw that happen to a dragon too.
She described the dragon she'd seen out
the window when she was two.
Charming story, said Lady Scarab.
She added some more red paint fountaining
out of the wasp's head.
Maybe what we saw, were wasps' experiments
Crickets said slowly.
Maybe she was testing out whether she
could control those dragons, but she
couldn't for some reason, or maybe she
couldn't yet.
Maybe her power was still getting
stronger at that point.
Makes no sense.
Scarab jabbed the paintbrush at cricket
again.
Hive wings are born with their powers.
They don't wander in 50 years later.
Why couldn't she do any of this when she
was younger?
Those 40 or so blissful years before she
became queen.
Not that my sister was any picnic as a
ruler.
But at least she wasn't a dictatorial
zombie making maniac.
And why doesn't it work on us?
Cricket said again.
She sat down opposite Lady Scarab, and
tried not to look at the painting of the
dying wasp, which now looked as though it
might drown in blood before the ants
could eat it.
I, I have one theory.
About me anyway.
I don't know if it's possible, but I
wondered maybe.
Spit it out?
Lady Scarab ordered.
Could I be half silkwing?
Cricket asked.
Katy did said my parents aren't my real
parents, and so I thought, maybe one of
my parents was a silk wing, and his blood
or her blood, is why the mind control
doesn't, no, Lady Scarab said, with a
bitter little laugh.
No?
No, you're not half Silkwing.
Cricket blinked.
How do you know?
Maybe you are too.
Maybe that's, I am getting worried about
your brain, Dragonette.
I knew that school would be worthless for
you.
But I didn't think all your mental
functions would atrophy so quickly.
Lady Scarab set down the paintbrush, and
clasped her front talons together, leaning
toward cricket.
I know you are not half Silkwing, because
I know both your parents.
And they are hive wings through and
through, zombie eyes and all.
You know them?
Cricket cried, leaping to her feet.
They're still alive?
Who are they?
Why didn't they keep me?
One of them did, said Lady Scarab.
She just couldn't tell anyone you were
hers.
I can't believe you haven't figured it
out before now.
Cricket felt as if the hive was falling
in on her slowly, level by level, like in
a dream.
Katie did isn't your sister, little
snail.
She's your mother.
Chapter 15.
It felt like the entire world flipped
over.
It felt like someone picked up the hive
turned it over, and shook it really hard
until all the pieces fell out, except one
and that one was the heart of
everything.
Haiti did.
She said softly.
My mother.
Katy did is my mother.
Katie did.
I gather this is going to go on for a
while.
Scarab muttered, producing a new easel
from behind the pillow.
On this one, a horde of shiny green
beetles was dragging a dying wasp into a
dark hole, where little eyes and teeth
glinted from the shadows.
I wish she had told me.
Why didn't she tell me?
She knew I could keep a secret.
Cricket flicked her tail back and forth.
She just lied to me.
Was she planning to hide the truth from
me my whole life?
Would it have made any difference, knowing
the truth?
Scarab asked sharply.
Yes, Cricket said.
It would have made everything make more
sense.
Well, all right, I would have had a few
questions.
Really?
You.
Ladies Scara raised her eyebrows.
But at least it would have explained a
whole lot of things.
Oh.
That's why mom, not mom.
Cadell hates me, Cricket said.
There were answers to all her
unanswerable questions, the way her
parents fought, why they barely looked at
her.
The reason Katy did always looked sad.
That's why Katie did always took care of
me.
Oh my goodness.
That's what Cadell meant whenever she
said, you're no daughter of mine.
It was true.
Lucky for you, Scarab snorted.
That one has a personality like
sandpaper.
Cricket thought this was rather funny
coming from Lady Scarab, but she didn't
point that out.
How did they keep it a secret?
She wondered.
She tried to puzzle through what they
would have had to do.
It was possible no one had noticed that
Katy did was with egg.
Many dragons grew plumper in the rainy
months, when there was more food, unless
opportunity for outdoor flying.
And Katy did was good at keeping secrets
obviously.
But what did she do once she had the
egg?
All high wing eggs in each hive were kept
in a central nest until they hatched.
Maybe Cadell simply had to present
herself at the nest with Katy did's egg
claiming it was hers, it would be marked
as hers, protected as the dragonette
inside grew, and then returned to Cadell
a day before it was due to hatch.
It's so hard to imagine Caddell agreeing
to a lie like that.
Cricket said aloud.
She didn't want to, said Lady Scarab.
There was an enormous fight when she
found out Katy did was hiding your egg.
If it was up to your delightful
grandmother, they would have taken it out
to the ocean and dropped you on a rock
somewhere.
This cricket could imagine very easily.
Although it was so strange to hear a
Cadell referred to as her grandmother.
I was still her family.
Even if I wasn't her daughter.
But my existence was against the rules.
I represented Katy did lying to her, and
Queen Wasp being furious if she found
out.
Having me around put Cadal at risk.
She must have seen danger and crime and
disorder, and lies that could ruin her
every time she looked at me.
In the end, Katie did agreed to sneak the
egg into the cicada hive nest, so it
could come back official and approved
instead of you being a secret forever.
And Cadell agreed to pretend it was
hers.
Lady Scarab grinned with all of her
teeth.
I might have helped with that little
compromise.
Cricket wondered whether Lady Scarab's
help came in the form of threats, or
offers to help Cadell's social climb.
Weren't there official records, though?
She asked.
I helped with those too.
Lady Scarab looked extremely pleased with
herself.
A little bribery, a little distraction, a
forged document, and then you were
Cadell's, and everything was in order.
But why would you help my assist?
I mean, Katie did, at all, Cricket asked
guessing part of the answer already.
Did you?
Did you know my dad?
Lady scarab's grin disappeared, like
waves pulling back off the beach before a
tsunami.
She stared down at her painting for a
long moment, then set down the paintbrush
and heaved herself upright with a growl.
Cricket moved out of the way as the old
dragon stomped over to the bookshelf.
Lady Scarab pulled out an old, dark green
book, and flipped it open.
Inside, the pages have been carved away
to leave a hollow for a small painting.
The dragon and the portrait had kind
eyes.
That was the 1st thing cricket noticed.
He wore glasses, just like her.
His scales were a warm orange color
except for his wings, which were dark red
with spots of black scales here and
there.
Some of them even looked like ink blots
like hers did.
He was holding a book, which made cricket
want to cry.
Who is he?
she whispered, touching the painting
lightly with one claw.
Definitely a hive wing.
So I'm really not a hybrid.
Malachite, said Lady Scarab.
My secretary.
Back when I was still allegedly, the
Minister of Education, brilliant, talented
made excellent coffee, full of exciting
ideas.
The 1st dragon in years, who gave me hope
for the future of our tribe.
She sighed.
It was my fault, really.
Queen Wasp has always hated me.
I should have known better than to let
her see there was a dragon I cared
about.
To spite me.
She forbade his marriage to the dragon he
fell in love with.
Katie did, Cricket said.
Yes.
And then she took him away from me.
Before he even knew you existed.
He works for her now.
He's really still alive, Cricket
whispered, looking up at her.
In a sense.
Scarab said bitterly.
She parades him past me whenever she
can.
Always with those hateful white eyes.
I don't know if he ever gets to be
himself.
I haven't seen him with his own eyes
since the day she took him over, and
summoned him to Wasp Hive.
She hissed.
I have to pretend like I don't care.
If she doesn't get a reaction from me
maybe one day she'll lose interest and
let him go.
That's why Lady Scarab has no servants
Cricket realized.
That's why she's always alone.
So there's no one wasp can hurt to get to
her.
Is that what's going to happen to Katy
did?
She asked.
I hope not, said Scarab.
Queen Wasp usually gets bored rather
quickly.
If Katie did, can't lead her to you.
She won't have much use for her.
I wish I could rescue them.
Cricket said, twisting her talons
together.
Well, you can't, Lady Scarab pointed
out.
Because WASP can control them any time
she wants, and she'll just march them
right back to prison.
A wave of anger rushed through cricket
strong and sudden.
There has to be a way to stop her.
Scarab snapped the cover closed over the
portrait of Malachite.
I was hoping you'd found one in the
book.
But if there are no more predictions, then
it's all chaos.
She waved her talons in the air.
Anything could happen.
She doesn't have secret knowledge of the
future after all.
Scarab chuckled.
No wonder she wants you dead.
Cricket ran her claws along the bookshelf
thinking.
She still didn't have an answer to the
mind control question.
She didn't know if the hive wings could
be saved from it.
But she did have one thing.
The truth about the book.
Katy did should have trusted me with the
truth about her and Malachite.
My tribe deserves the truth too.
They need to know that Queen Wasp has
been lying to them.
Cricket looked around the room.
If this was her last day in the hives, she
had to use it well.
She couldn't just look for answers
anymore.
She had to make sure other dragons also
knew them.
Lady Scarab, she said.
Can I borrow a paintbrush?
Part three.
The Queen's Secrets.
Chapter 16.
Sundude didn't like it.
And so Sortell didn't like it either.
Although Cricket suspected he would have
been all for it otherwise.
Blue loved the idea though, and that was
what she cared about.
This is way too dangerous, Sundew
protested.
Exactly, said Sword Tail.
Queen Wasp may already suspect we're in
Jewel Hive.
This will just prove it to her, Sundew
pointed out.
It'll be snake eyes and everyone talking
at the same time again in a heartbeat, and
then we'll be surrounded, and then we'll
be caught, and then none of our plans
will have a chance.
None of them, Swordell said, waving his
wings around dramatically, because we'll
be in the clutches of zombie hive wings.
All right, simmer down, Sundew said
rolling her eyes.
They were huddled inside one of the
indoor stalls of the glitter bazaar, not
far from the salvation statue.
This one sold books.
Wonderful, beautiful books, with gold
leaf on the spines and feathery edges to
the silk pages.
Cricket couldn't stop picking them up
just to feel something safe and beloved
in her talents again.
A part of her wish she could abandon this
plan. crawl under one of the tables and
read all the books in this stall for the
rest of her life instead.
Hanging from the top of the doorway?
Wind chimes with little hummingbirds
dangling from them sounded in the
breeze.
Dawn was coming, and the market was
virtually empty.
Even on the upper levels, most of the
dragons they'd seen had been dragging
themselves sleepily off to bed.
I know, Cricket said.
But I have to do something.
It's no use knowing the truth, if
everyone else still believes the lies.
My tribe needs to know that Queen Wasp is
lying to them.
Maybe I can't set them free from the mind
control yet, but knowing the truth about
the book.
She looked down at the scarf she'd been
twisting between her claws.
I think knowing the truth is the 1st step
toward their freedom.
I hope.
I hope so too.
Blue agreed.
I mean, imagine you've only been told one
thing your whole life.
Imagine you don't even know it could be a
lie.
He hesitated.
This is going to be hard for dragons to
hear.
What are we supposed to do with all
this?
Sundew asked.
Flicking her claws at the stacks of silk
paper that cricket had taken from a
nearby stationery stall.
We're going to write out clear site's
letter from the end of her book, Cricket
said.
Over and over again, as many copies as we
can make.
At the top, right, this is what the book
really says, and at the bottom, right
there are no more predictions, Queen Wasp
is lying.
Sortell groaned and flopped his head down
onto his talons.
Riding, he whined.
That sounds like homework.
Nobody said the revolution would involve
homework.
Sundu whacked him on the head with one of
her wings.
You are lucky that you can write, she
said.
We were told that silk wings weren't
allowed to go to school.
What?
Cricket yelped.
She couldn't imagine being forbidden to
go to school.
That would be cruel and awful and
barbaric.
The leaf wing shot her an amused look.
Well, exactly, she said.
Sounds all right to me, Swordell muttered
but he accepted the inkwell and chief of
papers with only a little more
grumbling.
Cricket made the 1st copies, as she was
the fastest rider, and then they all
copied from those, working as quickly as
they could.
When they had well over 100, and the sun
was starting to sidle in through the far
windows, she stopped them and collected
the papers.
Now you have to go, she said.
Go where?
Blue asked.
To hide for the day, Cricket answered.
Somewhere far away from Jewel Hive.
I'm doing the next part by myself.
Then I'm going back out to look for Luna
Swartel said.
Well, I get to meet with a chrysalis
sundew side.
Blue took one of Cricket's talons in
his.
No way.
I got you into this mess.
I'm not leaving you alone to deal with
it.
She shook her head.
You didn't get me into this mess, Blue.
Queen Wasp did this.
She kept my parents apart, and she stole
my father.
She used the book to make herself
powerful. and lied to the entire tribe to
do it.
You helped me find the truth.
And now I have to help my tribe the same
way.
Technically, I helped you find the truth
Sundu observed, since it was my idea to
steal the book in the 1st place.
I, too, have been important to this whole
everything.
Sort tell chimed in.
Cricket put her wings around blue.
Awkwardly, now that his own wings were in
the way, and hugged him close, you have
to stay safe to help the silk wings and
the leaf wings, she said.
But the hive wings are my
responsibility.
All right?
Also, Sundew said, it's better if only
one of us gets caught, then the others
can maybe rescue her.
Maybe, she repeated, wagging one claw in
cricket's face, but also, maybe not, so
don't get caught.
I won't, cricket said.
I'll try.
Go hide.
I'll meet you by the last stall outside
before sunset.
We can go look for Luna together, Sortell
said, nudging Blue's side.
We can split up and cover a lot more of
the bay with 2 of us.
Three if sundew helps.
Maybe she's hurt and stuck on an island.
We're in a cave and can't find us.
Please help me, Blue.
Luna and I need your help.
Cricket guessed that SwordTell meant it
but daddy was also trying to give Blue a
way to be able to leave her.
By reminding him of another dragon who
needed his help, even more than she did.
Blue opened and closed his talons, looking
at them as if he was hoping they'd tell
him what to do.
I will, but.
Cricket, Blue said woefully.
I don't want to leave you.
I know, she said, her voice catching in
her throat, but you can understand what
I'm feeling, right?
You can imagine how important this is to
me and and how important you are to me.
He blinked back tears, and leaned closer
so their noses touched, and then Sortail
dragged him away, and the 3 of them were
gone.
Blue still looking over his shoulder the
last moment.
It was hard to watch them hurry away
through the displays of the glitter
bazaar.
It was really hard to stop herself from
shouting, wait, come back.
I don't want to do this by myself.
I'm actually terrified.
But she took deep breaths and stayed
quiet.
And as soon as they were out of sight.
She set out to complete the next part of
her plan.
She knew the queen would tear down
anything she put up as fast as possible
so she focused on quantity.
As many messages in as many places as she
could.
Lady Scarab's largest pot of paint was
the bright pink color of hibiscus flowers
so that was what she used on every
poster.
Every open surface, every blank unguarded
wall.
She especially enjoyed painting over the
wanted posters, covering her own face
with tall pink letters.
The queen is lying to you.
Clear sight never predicted the tree
wars.
Clear sight never said the other tribes
should bow to the hive wings.
Everything Queen Wasp says about the book
is a lie.
Clear Sight's predictions ended a 1000
years ago.
The queen is lying to you.
She slid the paper with Clearsight's
letter on it under doors and scattered
them through the parks.
She left one on top of the book, The
Clear Site Statue was reading outside the
library.
She couldn't bring herself to do anything
else to that statue, but she had no
trouble defacing the salvation statue in
the glitter bazaar, scrawling, liar, in
enormous pink letters all over the
queen's face and wings, and then WASP is
lying around the base.
The sun was well above the horizon, and
the streets were starting to fill when
she ran out of paint.
A few dragonettes on their way to school
saw her slipping the papers under doors
and asked what they were, so she gave
them one.
This is the truth, she said.
I've seen the book of Clear Sight.
They gazed up at her, wide eyed, 3 tiny
hive wings and 2 wingless silk wings.
Really?
said one of them.
Is it amazing?
It is amazing, but not the way you'd
think, she said.
She tapped the paper.
This is what it really says.
They all gathered around to sound out the
words together, and she hurried away to
the next level, wondering how long she
had before Queen Wasp saw the messages
through someone's eyes.
Two levels up, a door opened just as she
slipped the paper underneath.
A startled hive wing stood there on her
way out to work.
Hey, said the strange dragon.
Who are you?
What's this?
It's Cricket took a deep breath.
Be brave.
It's the truth, she said.
She picked up the paper and held it out
to the dragon.
I thought everyone should know what the
book of Clear Sight really says.
The dragon's jaw dropped open.
You're the one from the wanted posters.
She seized the paper from Cricket's
Talons.
You really did read the book?
By the stars.
I've always wanted to know what it says.
Me too, Cricket said.
And now I think everyone should know.
She left the hive wing standing there.
Reading with shining eyes.
They are listening.
They want the truth.
Maybe this will work.
But her luck ran out on the way to the
water tower. where she had hoped to hide
for the day.
She was hurrying through the streets
ducking her head to avoid meeting
anyone's eyes when she turned a corner
and ran into Cadell.
Oh, Cricket yelped, looking straight into
her mother.
No, her grandmother's face.
I mean, sorry, sorry, ma'am.
She tried to cover her confusion, to bow
and turn away and continue on like any
other stranger in a hurry.
But Cadal seized her arm in an iron
grip.
You, she snarled.
What are you doing here?
In my hive.
Are you trying to get me arrested?
She dragged Cricket through the dragonfly
square to her house and threw her inside
slamming the door behind them.
Cricket stumbled on the gray silk carpet
trying to put some distance between
herself and Cadell.
There was so much in this living room
that reminded Cricket of her childhood.
The square black marble side tables her
mother had taken with her.
The ivory reproduction of the salvation
statue, with tiny garnet eyes, the smell
of chamomile tea, and boiled rabbits
coming from the kitchen.
Everything in the house was exactly the
same as it had been a year ago.
Every book exactly even with the edge of
the shelf, every painting perfectly
aligned with the next, Queen Wasp glaring
at Lady Jewel, who stared blankly at the
most boring clear sight and portrait
history.
Even the terror wasn't entirely new.
She'd never been able to predict what
Cadell would do next.
She'd always been afraid of something
sudden and terrible striking out of the
blue.
But this time, the room felt colder, the
smell of meat stronger.
And this time, the threat of Queen Wasp
poisoned everything.
This time, instead of yelling or throwing
things, Cadell might deliver cricket
right into the queen's waiting claws.
I kept my mouth shut.
Caddell hissed.
I didn't want anyone to know I had
anything to do with you.
And then you show up here.
Did you think I would help you?
No.
Cricket rubbed her scales where Cadell
had dug her claws in.
I didn't want to see you at all.
Caddell's wings flared.
Then why here?
Why this hive?
Why so close to my house?
I came here to get away from you.
I know, Cricket said.
And I know why.
Don't worry, I want to get away from you
too.
She took a step toward the door, but
Caddell blocked her path, bearing the
venomous teeth that neither her child nor
grandchild had inherited.
Cricket had seen her use them a few times
to bring down prey, especially larger
animals, like antelopes or water buffalo
but she'd also once seen Cadell bite a
dragon.
A new silkwing cook who had accidentally
burned Cadell's favorite meal on a bad
day.
The venom had spread quickly from the
wound on his neck, and there had been
screaming, and he'd only survived because
father, grandfather, got him to the
hospital in time.
Cricket mostly remembered the screaming.
That, and the realization that Cadell was
even more dangerous than she'd thought.
Would she do that to me?
Just let me go.
Pretend you didn't see me, Cricket said.
If we're both lucky, you'll never see me
again.
Caddell frowned.
She's not used to me talking back, Cricket
thought.
She's never seen me try to push her
away.
She's always been the one doing the
pushing.
Do you have the book?
Cadell asked, her tail lashing.
No, cricket answered.
But I've seen it.
I've read it, and I know Queen Wasp has
been lying to everyone about it.
Caddell brought her wings in close, and
squinted at cricket with her professor
face.
Is that so?
I must say, teaching the history of
Pantala feels quite incomplete without a
resource like the book.
I've always thought it should be
available for study.
Me too, Cricket said.
Maybe we do have something in common
after all.
You could give me the book.
Cadell said, advancing toward cricket.
Her teeth seemed to grow longer and
sharper as she smiled.
I am actually qualified enough to know
what to do with it.
It shouldn't be in the talons of some
grubby silk wings.
I told you, I don't have it.
Cricket said, backing up until her tail
hit the wall behind her, and her wings
nearly knocked down a map of Pantala.
And I wouldn't give it to you even if I
did.
You'd probably give it back to Queen Wasp
in exchange for an invitation to a
party.
Caddell hissed furiously.
Maybe, but I'd read it first, she
snapped.
Well, there's a copy of a piece of it on
the statue outside the library, Cricket
said.
Let me go, and you can go read it
yourself.
Cadell suddenly went very still.
Outside.
Cricket could hear running talon steps
and dragons shouting.
Among the clamor of words, she heard one
dragon call to another.
It says the queen is lying.
And someone else yell, I found another
one.
Her messages were getting the attention
she'd hoped for.
But she'd also hoped she'd be hidden away
inside the water tower by now.
Because if the news was spreading through
the hive, WASP only needed to be inside
one listening soldier, and then she'd
realize, cricket must be here somewhere.
And then she'd, Cadell's eyes flicked
over to white, as though all the color
had suddenly been leached out of her
eyeballs.
Aha, said the queen of the hive wings
tipping Cadell's head toward cricket.
There you are.
Chapter 17.
Cricket whirled and bolted up the
stairs.
Behind her, the queen laughed and laughed
an eerie, awful cackle that was like
something else trying to crawl out
through Caddell's normal laugh.
She made it to the next floor, just as 3
more white eyed hive wings burst through
the windows, shattering the shutters, and
ripping down the dark gray curtains.
Cricket threw the empty paint pot and
paintbrush at them, splattering bright
pink droplets everywhere, and hurtled up
to the top level, across the guest room
and out onto the balcony.
Hive wings were swarming toward Caddell's
house.
She could see dragons on every street
running or flying in her direction.
The queen had watched cricket slipped
through her claws at the temple of
Clearsight.
She wasn't going to let her escape
again.
Cricket threw herself off the balcony. and
flew as hard as she could toward the open
ledges that led to the savannah.
I escaped the temple.
I can do it again.
If I fly and fly.
But this time, she didn't have sun do
with her, and the sky was too far away
and there were too many hive wings, and
the queen controlled them all.
They came from everywhere, boiling up
from the ground, and the windows and the
ceilings, like an explosion of fire ants
they were tiny dragonettes, and hulking
soldiers. and glittering socialites in
their jewels and sparkles and finery, but
none of them were themselves anymore.
They were a swarm.
They were the 1000 claws of Queen Wasp.
They had become mindless weapons.
Cricket had been terrified of the white
eyed dragons ever since that morning when
she was 2 years old.
Now she was the dragon they hunted.
The dragon who didn't move in unison with
everyone else, the dragon who couldn't
escape.
She felt talons slam into her back and
throw her to the ground.
A red striped hive wing shot a blast of
acid that just missed her shoulder, and
hissed into the tree stuff beside her
head.
As she tried to roll away, another drove
his wrist stingers into the edge of her
wings, pinning her to the ground.
Cricket shrieked with pain as Caddell
landed on her chest.
Her grandmother did not look triumphant
or enraged, or even interested.
Her face was entirely blank, while she
held down her granddaughter, so a black
hive wing with yellow spots could shoot
something painful and paralyzing into
cricket's wings.
Cricket turned her head away from
Caddell's empty face, and saw silk wings
watching from the windows and the
sidewalks.
Last chance.
Through the haze of pain, she yelled, The
queen is lying to you.
The book never said she should rule you.
It was all a lie.
And she thought she saw something.
Sympathy, confusion, surprise, flicker in
their faces.
And then the yellow spotted hive wing
shoved his stinger into her neck.
Her throat closed over the words she
still wanted to say.
Her vocal cords radiated with agony, and
her head flopped over, her neck muscles
refusing to work for her anymore.
The hive wings seized her frozen wings
and dragged her away. away from the
frightened silk wing faces, and up the
ramps, up and up and up, to the prison at
the center of Lady Jules' palace.
Every time Cricket thought about the
library in Jewel Hive and thought, Maybe
Lady Jewel isn't so bad after all, She
always made herself remember the prison.
Which Jewel had insisted on building
within her own palace walls, instead of
somewhere a civilized distance away.
No one knew why she wanted her prison so
close, or what happened to the dragons
that disappeared inside it.
I guess I'm about to find out.
Cricket thought bleakly.
As they passed through the blue and gold
and beetle green, silk spangled gates of
Jules Palace.
All the walls inside seemed to be full of
windows.
So the gray afternoon light, and the
sound of raindrops, and the scent of a
storm carried through the entire palace.
For a moment, the breeze brushed
Cricket's face, whispering of the freedom
outside.
And then the hive wings descended a
staircase, and crickets' wings scraped
over the black stone threshold that
marked the end of Jewel's public palace
and the beginning of the secret prison.
She wished she could lift her head to see
where she was being taken, but all she
could do was watch the scuffed floor pass
below her.
Scarred with long trails of desperate
claw marks.
Down here, there were no windows, and the
flame silk lanterns were few and far
between, leaving patches of darkness
between dim pools of light.
Cricket could hear mournful singing
coming from one of the cells as they
passed by.
Another prisoner called to her, hey, what
did you do?
What did she do?
Come on, tell me something.
But she couldn't answer, and her guards
ignored him.
At the end of an interminable corridor
the dragons holding her finally stopped
and unlocked a cell.
They tossed her inside and she fell face
first, barely catching herself on numb
talons before the weight of her paralyzed
wings knocked her down.
With an enormous effort.
She rolled onto her back to see her
captors.
That was easier than I expected, said the
Queen, as one of the hive wings locked
the door.
Another hive wing leaned against the bars
grinning at her.
The queen's voice came from both of them
at once, which was still immensely
creepy.
You really were a fool to come back into
a hive.
And for what?
A little bit of graffiti.
A few pamphlets that will be ash by
evening.
Poor, naive little dragonette, as though
anyone would believe you over their
queen.
Cricket couldn't speak.
She wasn't sure she would have been able
to, even if her throat hadn't been
paralyzed.
She'd never been so scared in her entire
life.
Except maybe the moment when the queen
had seen her through the librarian's eyes
and she'd realized her secret was lost
forever.
It must have been so hard for you.
The queen went on, making one of the
dragons run his claws along the bars.
Feeling so different, so alone, watching
everyone else come together in my hive
mind, but always left out.
The 2 hive wings leaned closer, and
pressed their faces to the bars, as
though she might force them to squeeze
through.
But I have good news for you, little
dragon.
You don't have to be different anymore.
Their tongues flickered out and in and
out in terrifying unison.
I can fix you, hissed the queen.
I'm on my way right now.
And when I get there, I can make you just
like everybody else.
Aren't you lucky?
The hive wings stepped back, their pale
eyes still fixed on cricket.
She felt a tear run down her face and
couldn't do anything to stop it.
See you soon, little problem dragon.
The sound of their tails slithering away
seemed to last forever, as cricket lay
there, alone in the near dark.
Sundew and blue weren't expecting her
until sunset.
They wouldn't even look for her until
after the queen had already come and done
whatever she was going to do.
No one is coming to rescue me.
They'll never find me in time.
The queen is going to take my mind and
make it hers.
Cricket covered her ears and closed her
eyes, and prayed to the only dragon who
could possibly hear her.
Clear sight.
Please be listening.
Please, please save me.
Chapter 18.
When cricket opened her eyes again, a
long time later, almost midday, she
sensed.
There was an entirely new dragon standing
outside the door of her cell. looking in
with thoughtful curiosity.
Seated next to her, with an enormously
grumpy expression, was Lady Scarab.
The new dragon was tall and angular, and
her scales were a bright golden color
that almost looked green in the low flame
silk light.
Thin lines of black scales outlined her
iridescent green eyes, and dotted her
cheekbones.
More black lines traced the veins in her
wings.
Gold earrings shaped like beetles hung
from her ears.
A necklace of onyx stingers rested on her
collarbone, and her claws were each
painted with perfect lines of black and
gold.
Cricket had only seen her once before
across a crowded ballroom, but it was not
hard to guess that this was Lady Jewel
ruler of Jewel Hive, daughter of Lady
Scarab, and cousin to Queen Wasp.
The way she held herself was all regal
elegance, as if she were being painted.
The only crack in her facade was that she
winced a little every time her mother
moved, and she seemed to be keeping half
an eye on Lady Scarab at all times.
Hmm, said Lady Jewel.
So this is the dragon who's thrown my
hive into such a tizzy.
She tapped her chin with one long
glittering claw.
You're quite small to cause so much
trouble.
Small and brainless, Scarab snapped.
Mother, Jules said in a warning tone.
You promised you'd be quiet.
Scarab growled.
Cricket tried to sit up and discovered
that the paralysis had worn off her wings
and neck, although they still ached, and
she had to move slowly.
Lady Jewel, she said in a creaky voice.
No need to bow, Jules said. waving her
talons.
Cricket settled back gratefully.
Standing would have been a challenge, to
say the least.
What are you going to do to me?
she whispered.
That's a fine question to ask now.
Scarab bellowed.
Mother, Jules said, giving her a quelling
look.
Scarab glared at both of them and
subsided, muttering.
Jules smiled back at cricket.
You mean the torture, the experiments, the
vanishing prisoners?
Jules sat down, coiling her long, shining
tail around her legs.
Not for you.
The queen wants to handle you herself.
She shrugged, with a faintly disappointed
look.
But if they were real, I would say you
deserve them.
Scarab interjected.
Mother!
Joel barked, as a prisoner a few doors
down called, eh?
Not real?
What's that?
Jewel did something carefully to her face
like smoothing away the cross expression
and replacing it with everlasting
patience.
My mother, she said to Cricket, is not
normally allowed in my palace, for
reasons that become clearer each time she
does visit.
She has no idea what I actually do with
dragons in my prison.
Right, snorted Lady Scarab.
I'm sure my daughter, who once hid all
mine knives because they scared her, has
grown up to become a master torturer.
What?
Really?
Called the nosy prisoner.
Fain to the side of blood, this one
Scarab added, jerking her head at her
daughter.
I was five.
Lady Jewel closed her eyes and took a
deep, calming breath.
Let's talk about you, she said.
Opening them again and looking at
cricket.
Do you know how hard it is to get paint
out of tree stuff?
I'm going to have pink smudges all over
my hive forever now.
And you lost my best paint brush, didn't
you?
Scarab said, lashing her tail.
Not that my mother had anything to do
with this.
Jewel added quickly.
Should have given you an old one.
Scarab growled.
But you weren't supposed to get caught
you idiot.
Oh my gosh, mom, seriously.
Joel flapped her wings.
The royal stands entirely collapsing.
I am trying to be menacing and
mysterious.
Could you be quiet for 12nd while I
handle this?
With what?
A new necklace and a party?
Scarab grumbled.
You may not have noticed, but somehow I
managed to be a very good hive ruler, even
I would say, especially, when you and
your advice are on the other side of the
continent.
Hmm, Scarab said disapprovingly.
The glitter bazaar would be better if
you'd listened to me.
The glitter bazaar is fine.
And your schools have absolutely rubbish
history programs.
That's not up to me.
Queen Wasp sets the curriculums.
Why do you think I have a giant library
full of history books for my subjects?
And that table in the front hall?
is still in the wrong place.
Scarab went on.
It would be much more useful as a
sideboard in the dining room.
Joel pressed her claws to her forehead.
Mother, she said.
Maybe you should go visit with your
grandchildren.
Not on your life.
Scarab said promptly.
Those brats are very loud, and I will not
be tricked into dragonette sitting.
Stop distracting me and get on with
interrogating this nitwit.
That's what I'm trying to.
Jules stopped and took another deep
breath.
She turned toward Cricket with a
resolutely serene expression.
You.
Cricket, right?
Yes, that's me, Cricket said.
Did you read my messages?
I'm telling the truth.
Queen Wasp is lying about the book of
Clearsight.
I've always suspected that, Jules said.
Some of our great, great, great, great
grandmothers were not as quick and clever
with their lies as WASP has been.
There were hints in the history books, if
anyone looked carefully.
The books?
I do read.
Jules smiled, more or less a tiny quirk
of her mouth, despite the rumors to the
contrary.
I'd be quite interested to read the Book
of Clearsight.
I don't have it, Cricket confessed.
Loved it with someone smart enough not to
get caught.
I hope.
Scarab chimed in again.
She says, there's no line of hive wing
succession in there, sparkles.
You know what that means.
That you could have been queen, Joel said
with a sigh.
That you could still be queen, Scarab
said fiercely.
With my help, of course, or else you'd
probably do it all wrong.
Paint all the hives rainbow colors or
something.
Oh, for the mother, you can't say things
like that.
Jewel leaned back to check up and down
the corridor.
The guards are all the way back of the
entrance, Scarab said, flipping her tail
from side to side.
They can't hear us.
I can, called the prisoner.
You're a silkwing, Scarab called back.
True, he answered.
True.
Lady Joel.
Cricket said hesitantly.
May I ask, is my sister all right?
She caught herself, remembering.
It still felt too strange to call Katy
did her mother.
Katie did.
She was brought in last night before me.
She'll be fine, Joel said. with
surprising gentleness.
The queen is less interested in her now
that we have you.
I will find out what she knows, which I
assume is nothing, and release her before
Wasp arrives.
And that will be when, Scarab demanded.
Very soon, Jewel answered, which, thank
you so much for that.
I was supposed to have another 3 days to
prepare before her usual nest to visit.
She...
She said she's coming to fix me, Cricket
said, to make me like everyone else.
Can she do that?
Joel glanced at her mother, pausing for a
moment.
Yes.
She's done it before.
What?
Lady Scarab spat.
You never told me that.
It doesn't always work, Jules said, and I
don't know how she does it.
But we had a pair of dragons in here a
few years ago, who'd been preparing a
case for flame silk rights.
They were pretty old, nearly as old as
you mother.
So, perhaps not total idiots then, Scarab
snapped.
Sure, Jules said.
They said they remembered a time when
flame silks were treated like normal
members of the community, selling their
flame silk and living like anyone else.
Anyway, Wasp didn't like that very much.
So she made my guard to drag them in, and
she came by and took them into a closed
room for a while.
And when they came back out, their eyes
were white.
And they never argued against the queen
again.
I take it back.
Scarab huffed.
Total idiots after all.
So, every time she threatens to add you
to her hive mind.
She might actually be able to.
Jules said.
But you don't know how, Cricket said, or
what she does to them.
Jewel shook her head.
I know it doesn't work if they have
silkwing ancestors in the last 3
generations though.
She keeps all those old dragons penned up
together in Setsy Hive.
You didn't tell me that either, Scara
barked.
Of course I didn't, Jules said, flicking
her wings at her mother.
I was afraid you'd go over there and
storm around with a protest sign and get
yourself thrown in with them.
To right, said Scarab.
Someone needs to give my niece a good
thumping.
Well, I would like you to stay in control
of your own brain.
As annoying as that brain is, mother, so
I would appreciate it if you could not go
thumping the queen of our tribe anytime
soon.
If someone doesn't thump her soon.
We won't have any dragons left who can.
Scarab growled softly to herself, and
paced off down the corridor.
Cricket tried to stretch the pain out of
her wings and neck as she thought.
The queen could do something to dragons
behind closed doors to make them part of
her hive mind.
But surely she hadn't gone to every
dragon in every hive to do it, one at a
time, 1000s of dragons over 50 years.
For one thing, dragons would remember
that happening, so everyone would know
how she did it.
Katydid would have remembered surely.
And dragons would slip through the cracks
and Queen Wasp just couldn't possibly
have time to get to every hive wing that
way.
Wait.
Lady Jewel, Cricket said.
Did you say something about the queen
coming for a nest visit?
Yes.
Jewel tipped her head, studying cricket.
She visits the hive nests twice a year.
Once in the dry season, once in the rainy
season.
To ensure that they're clean and safe and
full of eggs, according to her rules.
Do you go into the nest with her?
Cricket asked.
No.
She always goes alone.
Jewel tapped her claws on the floor.
Hmm.
Scarab reappeared at the bars.
I'm sensing the development of another
completely stupid plan.
Cricket got herself to stand. and stepped
toward the leader of the hive.
Lady Jewel, she said, please let me out
of here, and I promise I'll find out what
she does in the nests.
If I'm right, and it has something to do
with the mind control, maybe we can
figure out a way to stop her.
I can't let you out, little Dragonette
Jules said.
As much as I might be tempted to.
Queen Wasp would punish my guards most
severely, and they are loyal to me when
their minds are their own.
They don't deserve that.
So put those 2 you don't like on duty
Scarab suggested.
The oily ones, who are probably spying on
you for the queen.
Joel narrowed her eyes at her mother for
a long moment.
Hmm, she said at length.
That might actually work.
See?
Scarab said triumphantly.
I am full of good advice, if you actually
listen.
By the book, mother.
I listen to you all the time.
Not about those dragonettes of yours, you
don't.
Oof, they are a disaster.
They are not.
This is not productive.
Jewel closed her eyes and robbed her
temples for a moment.
You can only control yourself.
She murmured.
All right.
Let's say I do put those sneaks on guard
duty.
How would we get her past them?
Cricket glanced around her cell.
Could I go out another way instead of
through the prison gate?
Up or down maybe?
She scratched the tree stuff below her.
Down would drop you into root worms
ballroom, and she would not be pleased
about that.
Lady Jewel looked up at the ceiling, her
eyes darting around as though she was
measuring the space in her head.
Up. I think you'd end up in my kitchens
or close to them.
I don't really want a hole in my kitchen
floor that looks down into a prison cell
but I suppose there are dragons up there
who could help you get out of the
palace.
She tapped her claws again.
How can I make a hole in tree stuff?
Cricket said thoughtfully.
A hammer, or something heavy would do it
but it would take a while, and the noise
would bring the guards.
She studied the walls, the bars, the
corridor outside.
Flame silk, flame silk might work.
Or it might burn down my palace, Joel
pointed out.
I'd be careful, Cricket promised.
And, Scarab observed, with unusual
cheerfulness, then Wasp would think her
flame silk friend broke in to get her
out.
Can't hardly blame you for that.
After she lost them twice in her own
hive.
I suspect Wasp can find a way to blame me
no matter what, Jules said.
Isn't this why you act like such a vapid
banana slog around her?
Scarab asked, flapping her wings, so
she'll think you're a harmless idiot, and
leave you in peace.
I do not, Joel protested.
Ah said Scarab.
So you actually are a harmless idiot.
Joel shot her mother a cross look.
The point is, yes.
Wasp would not be at all surprised if I
lost a dragon from my prisons, because
she thinks I have nothing but pollen
between my ears.
That doesn't mean she won't be furious
and perfectly nasty to me.
Perfectly nasty, is Wasp's natural
resting state, Scarab observed.
You'll survive it.
I say it's worth it to keep one more hive
wing free.
She nodded at cricket.
Sneaking into the nest and spying on the
queen, on the other talon, sounds like
the height of stupid.
That's the deal, Jules said firmly.
I want to follow this theory, and I can't
do it myself.
She'll have eyes on me.
I want to know the truth too, Cricket
said, wrapping her talons around the
bars.
It's all right, Lady Scarab.
I want to do this.
I think we'll find answers in there.
I really do.
Scarab looked from her daughter to
cricket and back, then flung her wings up
with a snort.
Fine.
Let's get this daft dragonette, some
flame silk.
Chapter 19.
Cricket waited, as she'd been instructed
until Lady Jewel and Scarab were long
gone.
Long enough for Jewel to have replaced
the guards at the front entrance of the
prison.
Then she took out the little stone pot of
flame silk that Jewel had left with her.
The golden thread inside glowed bright
and hot.
She guessed it was very new.
Maybe it's even blues, she thought.
Maybe one of the dragons in the market
traded it up through the hive yesterday
so it wound up here in Jules' palace.
She liked that thought, that maybe a
little piece of blue was going to help
her escape.
She still had the flame silk tweezers
she'd taken from her school library the
night she ran away with Blue.
Carefully.
She used them to twist the thread of
flame silk until it was straight and taut
like a wire, and then she lifted the
thread out, and flew up to the ceiling.
It was very awkward, trying to keep
herself in the air, nearly upside down
and work on the ceiling without dropping
the flame silk thread.
She traced out a circle big enough for
her to fit through, leaving a black
smoking line, with small flickers of
flame curling from a few of the edges.
Then she traced it again, and again
pressing the flame silk farther into the
tree stuff.
She knew tree stuff was made of bits of
wood pulp, silk, and clay, and she
guessed that how quickly it burned would
depend on how much of each was in this
section of the ceiling.
Tracing the lines seemed to take forever
around and around, over and over again.
Her wings started to ache, and she had to
land back on the floor for a little while
to rest them.
Psst, called a voice from the hallway.
Cricket edged over to the bars and tried
to peer out.
She could see light purple talons waving
from a cell a few doors away.
Yes, she whispered back.
I didn't catch all that, said the
prisoner, but if I want to stay on Lady
Jules good side, and I fervently do, what
should I say to the queen when she asks
me how you escaped?
Cricket was silent for a moment
worrying.
Why wouldn't you tell the queen what you
heard?
she asked.
Because Lady Jewel is the only ruler in
the hives who can be trusted, the
Silkwing whispered back.
Queen Wasp has no sense of mercy or
justice.
I'm due to be released tomorrow, and I
think Lady Jewel will be fair with me.
I think so too, Cricket said.
Wondering now about the stories of Jules
prison.
What if the dragons who disappeared in
here were actually spirited away to
safety by Jewel, to keep them out of the
queen's talons?
She led the queen and everyone else think
that cruel, secretive things went on
behind the prison doors, but perhaps that
was a clever way to conceal what she
really did for dragons in trouble.
What are you in here for?
Cricket asked.
Not paying my library fines, the dragon
answered ruefully.
Cricket wished he could see her smile.
If you could tell the queen, she said
that you think you heard a dragon burn a
hole in my ceiling from the other side
that would be very helpful.
I could do that, he said.
And when you saw this dragon, you shouted
Blue, Cricket said.
She'll expect it was him.
Good luck, the prisoner said, waving his
talent through the bars again.
Cricket returned to the scorched line in
the ceiling, burning it again and again.
She didn't know how long it took to fly
from Wasp Hive to Jewel Hive, but she
felt the queen drawing closer with every
heartbeat.
She had to hurry.
Finally, she felt that thread
breakthrough into open space on the other
side of the ceiling.
The circle of tree stuff trembled above
her, barely hanging in place, and she
shoved it hard with her shoulder.
Stand back, someone called from above.
Startled.
Cricket flew to the side.
She heard a thump, and then another.
And then the circle fell out of the
ceiling in a crash of tree stuffed dust.
That'll bring the guards, the other
prisoner called.
Better hurry and go.
Come on. cried the voice from the next
level up.
Cricket saw dark orange claws beckoning
through the hole in the ceiling.
She darted over, and squeezed herself
through, folding her wings in as tight as
they'd go, and losing a few scarves in
the process.
Talons reached for her, tugging her
upward until she tumbled free onto the
floor of Jewel's palace kitchen.
Five silk wing servants were scattered
around the room, staring at her with wide
eyes, frozen in the middle of chopping, or
stirring, or roasting, or whatever they'd
been doing, but standing by the hole were
cinnabar and tow, the silk wings from the
chrysalis, they were the ones who'd
helped her climb through.
You're all right, Cricket gasped.
I thought Lady Jewel was going to punish
you.
Not much, Tao said.
She likes me.
She likes me too, Cinnabar huffed. taking
the stone jar from cricket.
Cricket dropped the flame silk into it
and Cinnabar neatly capped the jar and
slotted it onto a high shelf between
glass jars labeled basil and ginger.
Not as much as she likes me.
Tao said serenely.
Also, whenever the queen says to punish
us severely, Jewel gives us a medal.
She clapped at a few of the watching silk
wings.
Pour some water over this hole to make
sure it doesn't burn further, and you
were all in the pantry and saw nothing.
Yes, Tao, one of them answered.
The others bowed their heads in
agreement.
Follow us, Cinnabar said to Cricket
turning and sprinting out of the
kitchen.
Cricket followed, with Tao at her side.
They ran through the winding back
passages of the palace, narrow halls that
cricket guests were intended for servants
to keep them out of sight of Jules' hive
wing guests.
She caught glimpses of jeweled toned
ballrooms as they flew by, ruby red walls
and yellow silk banners, and emerald
patterns in the floors.
She could still hear the rain and feel
the breeze from outside in almost every
room.
At last they came to a small nondescript
door.
Cinnabar opened it and peeked outside.
A gust of wind came through, carrying the
savannah ascents of sunlight and rain and
grass.
She closed it again quickly, and looked
back at Tao.
Tree hoppers out there, she said softly.
Cricket wondered if Blue could have read
Tao's expression, because she couldn't at
all.
The gentle silk wing was either
smothering a smile, or trying not to bite
something.
Is he himself?
She asked.
I couldn't tell, Cinnabar said.
His back is to the door.
I'll talk to him.
Tal stepped forward, brushing past
cricket in the dim hallway.
Is that a good idea?
Cinnabar asked, with the queen so close?
I am Lady Jules, chief steward, Tao said
austerely, and he is her treasurer.
We are allowed to have an ordinary
everyday conversation.
Cinnabar querked an eyebrow at her.
I promise we won't be obvious, Tao said
in her normal voice, really, Cinnabar.
You're obvious, every time you even look
at each other, Cinnabar grumbled.
Just get away from him quick, if his eyes
go white.
Tao shuddered.
I always do.
She slipped out through the door, and
Cricket nudged up to peek through the
crack with cinnabar.
Outside, a wide balcony garden overlooked
the savannah covered in plants of all
shapes and sizes.
Raspberry bushes lined the paths, and
white honeysuckle climbed the gazebos.
Cricket spotted pale pink lotus flowers
drifting across the ponds, and clusters
of forget me nots everywhere.
The way most of the plans spilled over
their borders made her miss her little
terrarium back at school, even though
she'd always found the endless botany
classes rather boring.
It was raining, a quiet, gentle rainfall
but a roof extended over part of the
gardens, and underneath it, a plump
worried looking hive wing sat by one of
the pools, reading, his scales were a
dark greenish black, with pale orange
stripes along his wings, tail, and face.
He turned to look up as Tao approached
and Cricket saw what Cinnabar meant.
His whole face lit up, as though he'd
just discovered sunshine.
By the hive, Cinnabar muttered.
They're terrible at this.
He's a hive wing, Cricket whispered, and
she's a silk wing.
Yep, said Cinnabar.
Extra very forbidden.
It's a problem, and we all know it.
Even Lady Jewel, but no one can do
anything about it.
Seeing the 2 dragons laughing, their
wings brushing accidentally, Cricket knew
she wouldn't have been able to do
anything about it either.
Even if she were their queen, she'd never
be able to separate 2 dragons who looked
so happy together.
Oh, right.
Stop being cute and get him out of there
Cinnabar grumbled between her teeth.
Tal gestured toward a door on the other
side of the garden, and they both started
walking in that direction.
Cinnabar poked her nose out a little
farther, watching them go.
And then, Tree Hopper froze in place for
a moment.
Tao stumbled beside him, glanced at him
quickly, and ducked her head, her whole
posture changing instantly into that of a
dutiful servant.
The hive wing turned his head in a slow
eerie twist to scan the garden.
Cricket and cinnabar jumped back behind
the door before the wide eyes got to
them.
I have arrived, said the queen's chilly
voice.
Cricket felt a spasm of fear shoot
through her from snout to tail.
Jewel, meet me in the prison.
There was a pause, and then Tree Hoppers
shook himself with a hiss.
Sorry, he said, in a low voice to Tao
looking down at his talons, as though he
couldn't bear to meet her eyes.
It's not your fault, she said softly.
Cricket's heart was thundering in her
ears.
She was sure she could hear talon steps
coming along the corridor.
Any moment, the queen would step into the
prison and see her empty cell, unless she
knew already.
Maybe she'd seen it through her spies.
Any moment, the queen would take over the
entire hive again, and cricket would be
surrounded by her.
The 2 dragons in the garden went through
the far door at last.
Cinnabar and Cricket leaped out of their
hiding spot and ran for the edge.
If you were smart, Cinnabar said.
You'd fly out that way and never stop.
She pointed out at the ocean beyond
Dragonfly Bay.
I wish I could.
Cricket thought of her dream of the
distant kingdoms, where Clearsight had
come from.
She and Blue could be safe over there, out
of reach of Queen Wasp's claws.
I promised Lady Jewel I'd find some
answers for her first, she told
Cinnabar.
Thank you for your help.
The dark orange dragon waved.
As Cricket dove into the air and twisted
her wings to spiral down the side of the
hive.
Other dragons were out despite the rain
flitting from one ledge to another, or
venturing into the wet savannah for prey
she wove through them, keeping an eye on
the hive wings, until she found an open
ledge on the nest level and could duck
inside.
The walkways around the nest were little
pebbled paths, dotted with benches, where
dragons could meet and make plans for
their future offspring.
The paths circled the giant dome, which
was painted smooth and white, like an
eggshell.
Cricket had visited the cicada hive nest
once, and it looked a lot like this.
She'd seen parents meeting with
administrators to decide what schools
their dragonettes would attend.
She'd even seen some discussing arranged
marriage plans.
But the walkways around the Jewel Hive
Nest were empty.
She crept up to the snowy walls of the
dome and around to the main door, which
was opposite the entrance to the ramps.
A sign was posted on the door of the dome
closed for inspection by the queen.
Oh, moons, Cricket thought.
Please don't be in there already.
She glanced around, and spotted 2 guards
pacing up and down the ramps.
Quickly, she dove behind a bench and
peered at them through the slats.
Their attention was focused outward
staring dragons away from the nest.
They didn't look back at the dome.
They could, any second.
But while she was watching, they didn't
and she had to hope she'd be lucky.
Taking a deep breath, she darted to the
door, pulled it open. and ducked inside.
It swung shut behind her, and she caught
it with her tail so it wouldn't thud.
The inside of the dome was very dark.
For a moment, Cricket was afraid that
there was no light in there at all, and
for a moment, with a shiver of fear, she
wondered whether Queen Wasp could see in
the dark.
She could be in here, watching me right
now.
Cricket stood petrified by the door
trying to breathe quietly, and slowly she
realized that her eyes were adjusting, and
the nest was not completely dark after
all.
It was not lit by flame silk, though.
The glowing green light came from small
clouds of bioluminescent mushrooms
gathered in clumps all around the room, at
the base of the walls and along the paths
between the eggs.
There was something weird and haunted and
beautiful about the scene, as though
cricket had wandered onto the surface of
one of the moons.
The nest was full of eggs, cradled in
small hollows in the floor, 10 apiece.
Cricket shivered again, thinking of all
the tiny heartbeats under the shells, all
the little dragons waiting to hatch.
She stepped onto one of the paths and
studied the closest egg.
A name was written on the shell in ink
the mother's name cricket guest, and
below that, scored into the shell.
There was something else, some kind of
symbol.
Cricket bent closer.
It looked like a pair of stingers, arcing
sharply away from each other, like the
antennae of a wasp.
She checked the next egg and the next.
They all bore the same marking, until she
came around to a group of newer eggs.
These had only half the marking, one
sharp line, traced ominously along the
curve of the shells.
The very newest ones had no marks on them
at all.
Cricket's mind was buzzing with questions
but she knew she'd already spent too long
gazing at the eggs.
She needed to find a place to hide, which
would be nearly impossible in a room that
contained nothing but eggs and glowing
toadstools.
She turned, searching the shadows, and
her tail bumped one of the larger eggs in
the last hollow.
It rocked slightly in its crevice, and
she jumped forward to catch it.
She could feel the vibrations of the
dragonette moving under the shell.
This egg had only one mark on it, and
instead of a name, the word written on
the shell was Orphanage.
Poor little dragonette, crooked thought.
He or she won't even have a katydid.
Yesterday, I thought for a while that I'd
never known my parents.
But this one really never will, and Queen
Wasp will be able to control this
dragonette whenever she wants.
They'll never have a chance to be free.
A strange instinct seized her, and she
wrapped the egg in one of her scarves
tying it to her chest.
Then she looked up, blinking back tears
and saw the rafters.
The nest was not a perfect dome.
It had cracked and shifted over the years
since it was built.
Four tall columns and a pair of
crossbeams had been added at some point
to keep the structure stable.
Up there, in the shadow where the support
beams met, maybe she could hide up
there.
Cricket spread her wings and flew up to
the crossbeams.
She crept cautiously along them, finally
settling in what seemed to be the darkest
corner, right above the door.
She might kill me for this.
Cricket didn't know where the line of
treason was for the queen.
Would she be content to take cricket's
brain and freedom from her?
Or would spying on her secrets mean
certain death?
If so, knowing about the book was cause
enough to kill her, surely.
I think it's safe to say that if the
queen catches me, I'm in enormous trouble
no matter what she decides to do.
Cricket wrapped her wings around the egg
and curled into the smallest ball she
could make, she thought about blue, and
sundew, and sore tail, hiding somewhere
there was still time before sunset.
If the answer to the mind control
question was here, She had to hope Sundu
could get the message to her parents
before they did something terrible and
irreversible.
But sunset crept closer and closer, and
nobody came into the dome.
Cricket began to worry that the queen
wasn't coming.
What if she was so furious about cricket
escaping, that she'd decided to skip the
nest visit in favor of taking over the
whole tribe to search for her.
Or what if she was busy punishing the
dragons in Jules' palace for letting
cricket escape?
I hope Lady Jewel is all right.
And Cinnabar, and Tao, and Lady Scarab.
She hoped Jewel had had time to free Katy
did, as she'd promised before the queen
arrived.
She could feel the sun sinking down the
sky, and she was beginning to imagine the
most terrible scenes happening back of
the palace.
When suddenly, she heard a soft creak, and
a bar of light lanced across the eggs.
It was Queen Wasp, at last.
Chapter 20.
The queen stalked forward into the nest
on soundless talons.
The door snicked shut behind her, and
cricket watched the queen pause, surveying
the eggs.
Or letting her eyes adjust, Cricket
thought.
Maybe she can't see in the dark after
all.
That thought did not make the queen any
less terrifying.
Queen Wasp was enormous, even from
Cricket's vantage point up by the dome
ceiling.
Cricket knew, logically, that Wasp was
probably smaller than Lady Scarab, as
Scarab was older than her, but there was
something about the way Queen Wasp stood
and held her wings and radiated menace
that made her seem quite possibly the
largest dragon in the entire world.
Her name was well chosen too.
From above, cricket had a perfect view of
the yellow and black stripes and black
horns that made the queen look so much
like one of the Pantalan wasps that could
kill an elephant with its venom.
Cricket breathed as lightly, softly as
she could, trying not to move, or shift
or twitch.
The queen stepped between the eggs.
Her head twisting abruptly to one side
then to the other, her tongue flicking in
and out.
She passed the hollows of eggs with the
double marks.
Her tail slid behind her, like a cobra
stalking its prey.
She reached the 1st group of newer eggs
those with only one stinger marked on
them.
Here she stopped, hissing for a long
terrifying moment.
Queen Wasp picked up one of the eggs.
Her tail rose behind her, and a long
needle sharp stinger slid out of the
tip.
Cricket fought back a gasp.
Everyone knew about the stingers and
queen wasp's claws and how much pain they
could inject.
She'd never heard anyone mention a
stinger in the queen's tail as well.
In a move like a flash of lightning, the
queen struck, plunging her tail stinger
into the eggshell.
A pulse of something bright green seemed
to move through the stinger into the egg
into the dragonette inside, Cricket
thought, with mute horror.
And then the queen drew her stinger out
and dropped the egg back into place.
With one claw, she sketched the 2nd half
of the marking on the shell, and then she
picked up the next egg.
Cricket could only watch a few more
before she had to close her eyes and bury
her face in the egg she held.
The queen moved quickly, efficiently
ruthlessly, and Cricket knew what she was
saying.
This is how she does it.
She poisons her dragons before they're
even hatched.
They come into the world already linked
to her by whatever that is she's
injecting into the eggs, the moment they
open their eyes.
She can be there, inside their heads.
Does it take 2 injections to work?
Or is one for backup?
She glanced down at the orphaned egg she
was cradling in the scarf.
Would this dragon belong to the queen
already?
Or could it be free if the queen never
stabbed it a 2nd time?
I came from a nest too.
So why not me?
She thought for a while, trying to ignore
the soft, chilling noises from below
her.
Scarab said Katy did was trying to hide
my egg at first.
She smuggled me into a nest later, after
I'd been an egg for a while.
She must have seen the marks too, and not
known what they meant.
I bet she marked my egg herself, so later
the queen thought she'd already stabbed
me.
That's how I escaped.
She brushed her talons gently over the
single mark on the egg.
Which marking had Katy did put on the
egg?
Maybe cricket had been injected, but only
once instead of twice.
She tightened her grip on the scarf.
It was nauseating to think of the queen
plunging her poison into cricket.
Still worse to know she was doing it now
to all these baby dragons.
I wish I could stop her.
I wish I could fly down there, and drop a
deadly centipede on her head, or drown
her inflame silk.
I wish I were brave or fierce or
dangerous.
But she couldn't do anything.
Not here, not now.
She had only one weapon.
She knew the truth about the queen.
And right now, she was the only one who
knew.
She had to stay safe to make sure she
could get that information to Lady Jewel
and maybe to the whole tribe, if she
could.
So she stayed in the rafters, as still as
a mouse with hawks overhead while the
queen finished her gruesome work.
The last egg was set down, the last shell
marked, and Queen Wasp slithered out the
door, as silently as she'd arrived.
Cricket checked her internal sense of
time, and felt a spasm of panic.
It was almost sunset.
She wanted to leap off her perch and race
down to the glitter bazaar, but she
needed to wait long enough for the queen
to be definitely gone.
Now?
Is it safe?
Can I go now?
She wondered if something about her
humming anxiety, translated through the
eggshell in her arms, because she felt
the dragonette inside move again, rolling
and scrunching around.
Finally, she'd waited as long as she
could, and she flew back down to the
ground.
She glanced around to the eggs, feeling
her wings droop to either side of her.
I'm sorry, little dragons, she
whispered.
I wish I could save you all.
Cricket pressed her ear to the door, and
listened for a long time, but heard
nothing outside, pulling her scarves
closer.
She opened the door a crack and peeked
out.
The guards were gone.
She could see dragons moving up and down
the ramps, but she couldn't tell if they
were mind controlled or not.
It felt horribly likely that the queen
would have the whole hive on alert
looking for her.
She slipped out and around the curve of
the dome, back toward the sky ledge.
It would be safer to fly than to try
creeping down all the levels inside the
hive, past the 100s of eyes that could be
looking for her.
Or perhaps not.
Cricket hesitated on the ledge.
The light drizzle from earlier had
strengthened into a driving storm.
Rain poured down with a vengeance.
Lightning crackled on the horizon, and
the wind was strong enough to shake the
hive.
Even standing inside the hive.
Cricket felt the spray of raindrops on
her face, as though the entire sea was
throwing itself around in fury.
Still safer than the zombie eyes, Cricket
told herself.
She didn't want to get caught again.
She would not get caught again, especially
with this egg, and a dragonette inside
who had a chance to be free, like her.
She took a deep breath and plunged into
the storm.
The wind howled furiously and tried to
smash her against the hive walls, but she
folded her wings and dropped, plummeting
toward the earth.
Rain battered her face, nearly blinding
her, but she managed to pull up just
before she hit the outer glitter bazaar
canopy.
Below it, she could see the shapes of
dragons rushing to fix the leaks and
protect their wares.
Her scarves felt like wet seaweed
clinging to her neck and legs.
She landed in a mud puddle outside the
market, and squelched toward the end of
the stalls.
The egg vibrated in its soaking wet
makeshift sling, nearly slipping away
from her a couple of times.
She had her head down and eyes nearly
closed against the downpour.
So when a dragon ducked under the canopy
and stepped in front of her, she almost
ran straight into him.
Cricket, he yelled over the rush of the
wind.
Blue, she cried joyfully, you're all
right.
You're all right, he shouted back
beaming.
He swept her up in his wings.
As your warmth surrounding her, she felt
safe for the 1st time all day.
I worried about you so much.
Any luck searching for Luna?
she asked.
No, he said, into her shoulder with a
sigh.
Sundu thinks we should ask the leaf wings
if they've seen her.
Whoa, why do you have an egg with you?
I saved it from the queen, Cricket said
pulling back a little so he could see the
smooth white shell.
Where's sundew?
Has she sent a message to the other leaf
wings yet?
I don't think so.
They both glanced up at the dark clouds
overhead.
Raindrops cascaded down Blue's face like
tiny sapphires.
It was impossible to see the sun, but
Cricket knew it was sinking.
Am I too late?
What are the leaf wings planning?
Can I still stop them?
I have to talk to her, quickly, Cricket
said.
This way.
Blue guided her to the canopy and lifted
an edge so she could slide underneath.
Cricket found herself in a small, rickety
looking stall, with rain dripping through
a tear in the web overhead.
A silk wing was hovering by the hole
trying to patch it with his silk.
Swordtail was up there too, helping to
hold it together.
She couldn't identify right away what was
for sale in here.
The shelves seemed to hold a mishmash of
items.
From little pots of blackberries to damp
silk pillows, a few cracked mirrors, a
very unfortunate smelling pile of
wildebeest pelts, and a barrel labeled
seeds.
There was not much room to maneuver
between the tent walls.
Cricket felt oversized and wet and very
muddy.
She started unwinding all the wet scarves
around her.
Tao appeared from under one of the
tables.
I can't believe you made it here, she
said.
The queen is livid.
Everyone in the hive is supposed to be
looking for you.
She followed Cricket's glands up to the
silk wing on the ceiling.
That's my stepbrother.
Don't worry, he's in the chrysalis.
We can trust him Is Lady Jewel all
right?
Cricket asked.
She will be, I think.
She's made the queen this mad before and
survived, mostly because the queen thinks
she's a butterfly brain, who could never
execute an actual plan.
Can you take her a message for me?
I found out what the queen is doing in
the nest.
But I have to tell Sundu first.
I'm here, Sundoo said, pushing her way
through a curtain from the next room.
Her silkwing disguise had been
abandoned.
She looked like herself again.
Cricket felt a surge of relief at the
side of her serious green face.
Sundew, she cried.
We can tell your parents I know how the
queen does it.
She's poisoning dragons when they're
still in their eggs.
I saw her stabbing them with her tail
stinger.
She goes to every nest in all the hives
to do it.
That way, when they hatch.
She can mind control them right away.
Apparently she can inject grown dragons
too, but it must be faster to do all the
eggs at once.
To grown dragons?
Blue echoed.
You mean, could she do it to you?
Cricket tried not to let it show on her
face how scared she'd been, or how close
she'd come to that exact fate today.
Yes, I think so, she said.
I think she missed stabbing my egg
because Katie did snuck me into the nest
late, but if she got her claws on me
now.
She could force me into the hive mind.
No.
Blue said passionately.
That is never, never going to happen.
Cricket brushed his wings with hers.
We can save other eggs like I was saved.
Sundo, don't you see?
What Queen Wasp can do.
It's not a power.
I mean, it is, but it doesn't have to
be.
Hive wings could be free.
This one will be free.
She held out the egg. and Sundew touched
it lightly, as though she wasn't entirely
convinced it was safe to have around.
Wow, said the leaf wing.
That is a lot of information.
We have to tell your parents to call off
their other plan, Cricket said
breathlessly.
It's sunset.
We have to do it now.
How do we get to them?
Sundew made a face.
Her trying not to make a face, face.
Cricket?
It's amazing and insane and creepy what
you found, but it doesn't change
anything.
Of course it does.
Cricket pulled the egg back into her
chest.
We can stop her from stabbing any more
eggs.
Once I tell Lady Jewel, I know she'll
come up with some way to protect them.
Maybe the other hive rulers will too.
But even if they can, and I don't see how
with Queen Wasp still in charge.
But even if we could save the eggs, we
can't save the dragons who are already in
her hive mind, can we?
Sundew asked, we still have an entire
tribe of wasp brains to deal with, right?
There's no way to shut it down.
Cricket glanced around as Blue wove his
tail through hers.
There might be, he said.
Ask your parents for more time.
Maybe we can find out more.
They are really not going to like that
Sundew said.
Our dragons want vengeance, Hivewing.
The last time I saw my parents, they
barely listened to my report at all.
But nobody wants another war, do they?
Cricket brushed rain and tears off her
face.
Don't they remember how terrible the tree
wars were?
Of course they do, said Sundew.
That's exactly why they're doing this.
The hive wings started it.
The leaf wings are going to end it.
It must be awful, Blue said, thinking
that war is the only solution.
He lifted the egg gently out of cricket's
talons and dried it with his cape.
Isn't there something we can do?
Cricket said again.
There must be something.
We know Queen Wasp's secrets now.
If we tell everyone, if dragons knew the
truth, They still couldn't stop her, Sundu
said.
She controls them completely.
Not the silk wings, Tao said.
This information could make a big
difference to the chrysalis, and Lady
Jewel.
You should tell them then, Sandu said, but
I don't think my parents will care.
Would they listen to us?
Blue asked.
Could we try talking to them?
What if, what if I offered to give them
some of my flame silk in exchange for
more time?
Cricket?
Maybe we could negotiate with them.
You don't have to do that.
Cricket said, taking one of his talons
and brushing her claws over the glowing
scales.
I would though.
Blue said.
I want to stop this war too.
Sundo.
Can we please try?
The leaf wings spread her gold dappled
green wings and sighed.
We can try, she said.
I'll take you to them.
They're waiting for me right now.
Can we also ask them to leave Jewel Hive
out of it?
Cricket asked.
For as long as possible anyway?
Lady Jewel would be on your side if you
don't hurt her dragons.
I really think she would.
I agree, Tao said.
We'll ask, Sundoo said, looking torn, but
Tao, if you can find a reason to get all
the silkwing dragonettes out of the hive
to somewhere safe, that might be a good
idea is all I can say.
She looked up at the ceiling.
Sore tail, we're leaving.
Sortell hopped down to the ground and
gave Cricket a nudge.
Glad you're all right, he said gruffly.
Cricket told Tao everything she'd seen
inside the nest while her friends
gathered their things.
Tao pressed her talons together, looking
worried.
Are you sure that dragonette won't have
the queen in its head too?
She asked. nodding at the egg.
That's what I want to find out.
Cricket said.
Seems like a risky experiment.
I am a scientist, Cricket said.
Sometimes risks are necessary.
She'd said those words many times in her
life, although they had never gotten her
out of any of the trouble her experiment
had gotten her into, but it felt
different now, real and serious.
She wrung out her scarves and wrapped up
the egg again, tying it to her even more
securely.
She guessed they'd be flying all night in
a thunderstorm, and she wanted to keep it
warm and safe.
The truth was, the dragonette in the egg
wasn't just an experiment.
It was someone who could be free of the
hive mind.
The 1st dragon she could save from Queen
Wasp.
Hopefully, the 1st of many.
If this works, if we get away from here
without being caught.
If we make it to the leaf wings, and
convince them to give us more time, and
find a way to stop the mind control.
If nothing went wrong.
This dragonette might have a chance at a
better life, and all the tribes might
have a chance at peace.
Chapter 21.
Cricket woke up the next morning into a
feeling of lingering dread.
She had dreamed about losing the orphan
egg, about Queen Wasp, stabbing her in
the heart with her mind control poison
about sundew, opening her palms, and
unleashing an army of swarming black
insects that covered Pantala from coast
to coast.
She opened her eyes, and found herself
curled tight around the egg.
Cool scales rested against her back, and
when she peeked over her shoulder, she
found Blue asleep with one wing tented
over hers.
Sundew had brought them to a peninsula
northeast of Jewel Hive, to a cave at the
bottom of the seaside cliffs, but when
they arrived late the night before, there
was no sign of Belladonna or hemlock.
It had still been raining when they crept
into the shallow nook and curled up on
the damp rocks, but sometime in the night
the rain must have stopped.
There was no more thunder.
The howling wind had finally dozed off.
She could see the waters of Dragonfly Bay
outside, leaden and gray, like the clouds
above them.
Carefully, Cricket slid herself up to
sitting and checked the egg.
There was a crack along the top of the
shell.
Her heart stopped, and she touched it
gently with one claw, then held the egg
up to listen to it.
Is the dragonnet all right?
Did I crack the egg?
As soon as she lifted it, a brisk tapping
sound came from inside the shell
something poked to the crack from the
other side.
Is it hatching?
Cricket knew she shouldn't be quite so
alarmed.
Hatching was, in fact, what eggs did.
This one had to hatch at some point.
But she'd really thought she'd have a few
more days first.
How could she possibly have grabbed an
egg that close to hatching?
The queen had originally planned to visit
3 days later.
Surely she timed her visit to catch all
the eggs before their hatching times.
No, Cricket said firmly to the egg.
It is not time to hatch yet.
The tapping paused, and then picked up
speed.
Stop that, Cricket said. are you doing?
You're not ready to hatch.
You can't come out?
She put one talon over the crack, covering
it up.
The dragonette inside jabbed her palm
with one of its claws.
Stay, cricket ordered.
Stay in there.
That sounds like it's going well, Sundew
commented from across the cave. opening
one bleary eye to glare at her.
It cannot possibly be time for this egg
to hatch, Cricket said.
I think it disagrees with you, Sandu
observed.
Blue sat up, yawning, and looked over
Cricket's shoulder.
Maybe it thinks it's time to hatch
because it's not in the nest anymore.
Oh, my stars, cricket said.
Is that a thing?
A real thing?
Can it really tell it's not in the nest?
Well, the light is different, and the
noise is outside the shell, and it's
being moved around a lot more.
So, maybe, Blue Guest.
I thought you were the one who knew
things.
Sundew said to Cricket.
Not about eggs and dragonettes and
hatching, Cricket said.
I've never studied those.
I know about seeds, and dirt, and plants
and oh, no, blue.
You might be right, are eggs like seeds?
Like, if you put them in the right
conditions, they grow.
He spread his wings with an, I have no
idea expression.
Baby, Cricket said to the egg.
Small dragon, this would be a very silly
place and time to hatch.
Do not do it.
A claw poked straight through the crack
and wiggled gleefully at her.
Cricket gave Sun to a helpless look.
This was your brilliant idea.
Sundew said, don't look at me.
I don't want anything to do with any
dragonettes, especially a hive wing
dragonette.
She jumped to her feet.
I'll go get us something to eat.
Yes, that's what I should do.
She hurried out of the cave, casting the
egg a suspicious look as she went by.
It's going to be very confused, Blue
said.
Don't you think?
Or maybe not.
I guess it probably doesn't have any
expectations about what hatching will be
like.
I wonder if it's scared.
The egg was rocking merrily back and
forth, emitting tiny squeaks.
Somehow, I think not, Cricket said.
More cracks spidered out from the 1st
one.
Delighted with its success, the
dragonette kicked harder, finally sending
a fragment of eggshell flying off to whap
into Cricket's nose.
I'm serious.
Cricket yelped at it, stop hatching right
now.
The eggshell cracked in half in her
talons.
The pieces fell away, leaving a small
black and yellow dragonette sitting
between her claws, happily shaking bits
of eggshell and goop off her wings.
Whoa.
Blue leaned closer and blinked at it.
Oh no, said Cricket.
Yim declared the dragonette. accidentally
whacking blue in the snout with her
tail.
Aw, Swordtail said from across the cave.
Look how cute she is.
Ripped?
the dragonette agreed.
She seized one of Cricket's claws and
started chewing on it.
No, thank you, ow, Cricket said.
Tugging her off and lifting her up so
they were eye to eye.
Ow!
The dragonette mimicked solemnly.
Ow.
She reached for Cricket's ear with a
hungry expression.
She is cute.
Blue said, smiling.
She is trying to eat me, Cricket pointed
out.
Sundo.
I know you can hear me.
Did you find any food?
Sundu poked her head into the cave.
I perhaps should have mentioned this
sooner, she said, but I rather intensely
dislike small dragonettes.
Gorb, the dragonette said sternly.
Ow.
Here, Sundu said, tossing a fish across
the cave to cricket, Blue jumped forward
and caught it for her.
But don't you dare let it think food
comes from me.
Cricket gave the fish to the dragonette
and set her down in a small hollow in the
rocks.
The baby stuck the fish in her mouth
chewed vigorously for a moment, and then
keeled over and fell asleep.
So cute, Swordtail said again. inching
closer to grin at her.
She needs a name, Blue said.
They all looked down at her black scales
striped with wide, fuzzy swaths of bright
yellow.
She looks kind of like a bumblebee.
Cricket said.
Bumblebee, swordtail echoed.
I like that.
Me too.
Blue agreed.
I have no opinion.
Sundu offered, from her spot halfway out
the door.
Come peek at her, Swartell said.
It's safe while she's sleeping.
Not interested, Sundew said firmly.
Cricket leaned down and picked up the 2
halves of the eggshell.
The dragonette seemed normal, as far as
she could tell, if perhaps a little noisy
and hyper, and ravenous, although she
really had no idea what a normal
dragonette should be like.
Bumblebee hadn't gone wide eyed in the 20
heartbeats she'd been awake anyhow.
Cricket wasn't quite sure what the next
step of this experiment was.
Wait until Queen Wasp did look out of her
eyes?
If that happened, what would they do with
Bumblebee?
Abandon her somewhere?
I won't ever do that.
But it's not going to happen.
She was only injected once.
Like me, probably.
She'll be free.
Something caught her attention, and she
squinted at the eggshells for a moment.
Blue, she said.
Do you see this?
He leaned over and looked.
That's the inside of Bumblebee's shell.
It looks kind of greenish.
Let me see.
Sundew crossed the cave, and Cricket held
the shells up to the light.
There was definitely some kind of green
residue, dusting the inside of the
shells.
Sundew took one shell and poked the green
part, but it didn't brush off.
It looked like a thin green crust, almost
baked onto the shell.
She found at it for a moment, then lifted
it to her snout and sniffed it.
Yuck, Swordell declared.
I know this smell, Sundoo said.
She stared out at the bay for a moment
then sniffed it again.
Cricket sniffed the one she was holding.
It had a dark, leaf rot scent with
something unpleasantly peppery lurking
inside it.
There was something a little familiar
about it, but nothing she could
identify.
I spent 4 days surrounded by this smell
Sundew said.
What?
Cricket said, startled.
Where?
It comes from a plant, sundew said.
And Queen Wasp's private greenhouse is
full of it.
Chapter 22.
Cricket gasped.
The greenhouse where we met you, where we
captured you, Sundu corrected her.
The one that says, Queen Wasp's top
secret greenhouse, keep out, or I will
dismember you, and then kill you some
more.
Blue asked.
That's the one, Sundew said.
There were other plans in it too.
But that's the main one.
It's everywhere in there, and it smells
terrible.
Send you.
Is that what she's using?
Cricket asked.
Could a plant give her mind control
powers?
Maybe for instance, if she ate a lot of
it, and then injected it into her
victims?
I don't know, Sundew snapped.
I've never heard of a plant like that, but
I'd call this a clue, don't you think?
She waved the eggshell at them.
Blue said, wrinkling his snout at the
green stuff.
I wonder if it tastes as bad as it
smells.
I certainly hope so, Swartell said.
I hope she has to eat hive loads of it.
This could be the way to save the
dragonettes, Cricket said, meeting
sundew's eyes.
Right?
Couldn't we destroy her supply?
And then she won't be able to eat it, or
inject it into them.
Or do it to any grown up dragons, like
Lady Jewel either.
Like you, Blue said.
He sat up with an alert expression.
Then you'd be safe from her.
Let's do it.
You had me at Destroy, Sword Tell
offered.
I'm up for it, Sundu said, spreading her
wings, but it's not that easy.
Wasp Hive is swarming with soldiers since
we stole the Book of Clearsight and broke
into the flame silk cavern.
There are guards patrolling the
greenhouses all the time.
Queen Wasp is in their heads more than
half the day, keeping watch.
I don't see how we'll get anywhere near
it without getting caught.
They sat in silence for a moment.
Cricket's mind was spinning through
possibilities.
If this was the answer, if they could
take the queen's power away, it was a
start, at least, it might not stop the
leaf wing's plans for war, but it would
give the next generation a chance against
Queen Wasp, if they survived that war.
We'll tell my parents, Sundew said.
Belladonna will know what to do with this
information.
Maybe they can take a pot of leaf wings
to attack the greenhouse.
Oh, what?
Cricket asked.
A pod, Sundu repeated, like a small group
part of the warrior force.
Are you part of the warrior force?
SwordTell asked.
Sundew made one of her inscrutable
faces.
Sort of.
I'm kind of my own pod.
Where are your parents?
Cricket asked.
Why aren't they here?
She glanced over to make sure that
Bumblebee was still sleeping and saw that
she'd flopped over on her back, with the
fish still hanging out of her mouth.
Tiny snores emitted from her snout.
I don't know.
They should be.
Sundew went back to the mouth of the cave
looking out at the bay.
I hope nothing went wrong, she said
quietly.
Um, what's that?
Blue asked, pointing south across the
water.
Cricket joined them on the edge of the
rocks, followed by SwordTail.
All 4 dragons squinted out into the gray
morning.
A column of black smoke rose into the sky
on the southern horizon.
Her heart pounding.
Cricket turned to sundew.
What is that?
she asked.
Did the leaf wings do that?
I don't know, Sundew said.
And for once her frown looked worried
instead of angry.
They didn't tell me they, I mean, they
weren't supposed to.
Cricket threw open her wings and flew to
the top of the cliff, high above the
sea.
From here, on a clear day, you could
almost see to the far end of the
continent.
This was not a clear day, but she could
still see the spire of wasp hive to the
west and jewel hive in the southwest.
The column of smoke came from beyond
Jewel Hive, farther south.
It's not Jewel Hive, Sundew said, landing
beside her.
Bloodworm hive, cricket said.
Yes.
The leaf wing stared out at the smoke, as
though it was something she'd ordered at
a cafe, but it had come in the wrong
color, and covered with maggots.
They went ahead and did it.
Without waiting for me.
She blew out a long exhale.
All those dragonettes, Cricket said
feeling as if her roots had been sliced
off.
The eggs in their nest, the silk wings
who can't fly.
She closed her eyes.
Could I have saved them?
If I'd been faster and smarter and found
the answers sooner?
They said they would wait for my report.
But I guess they were lying about that.
Sundu looked sincerely angry in a
different way than usual, Cricket
thought.
Maybe they didn't care what I was doing.
Maybe they were just planting their seeds
for the last 6 days, moving all the
pieces into place.
Did you know all the pieces?
Cricket asked numbly.
Did you know what they were planning?
Sundew hesitated.
I knew most of it.
This plan was in motion before we met you
but I thought, I really thought they'd
wait for me.
She ducked her head to look sideways at
cricket.
One thing changed, though.
Because of you three, we learned about
the chrysalis.
I wouldn't have believed they existed
before.
I mean, that Silk Wings could even think
about fighting back.
We found bloodworm hives chrysalis, and
gave them a message to evacuate their
dragonettes from the hive, and to stay
out of the webs last night.
Cricket shot her look.
I'm sure that didn't arouse suspicion at
all.
You'd be surprised how little attention
your tribe pays to what silk wings do
Sundew said pointedly.
They were silent for another moment.
I'm sure they'll get the eggs out too
Sundew offered.
Shifting uncomfortably on her talons.
Once they realize they can't save the
hive.
That's the 1st thing the hive wings will
do.
I hope you're right, Cricket said.
I hope someone remembers the silk wings
in their cocoons too.
Something swooped across the sky to her
right, and Sundew tugged her down
throwing her wing over Cricket's back, so
they were both flat to the earth, and
partly camouflaged by sundew's green
scales.
Hive wings were swarming toward bloodworm
hive, 100s of them rising from wasp hive
and jewel hive, and somewhere farther
north, Yellow Jacket hive, cricket
guest.
They flew like a cloud of bats across the
sky, south to the burning city.
Queen Wasp was sending her hive mind to
try to save it.
Cricket clutched Sundu's arm.
Right now, she said.
Right now what?
Now is the time to burn her greenhouse.
Cricket pointed at the dragons
disappearing into the distance.
Everyone's flying to bloodworm hive.
It's the perfect distraction.
It's not a distraction, Sandu objected.
It's a blow for justice.
Well, we can use it as a distraction
Cricket said, to do something that might
actually help dragons instead of hurting
anyone if we go right now.
My parents, Sundew said, glancing at the
smoke again.
I'm supposed to wait for them.
I'm not authorized for another mission.
Seriously?
Cricket arched her eyebrows at the leaf
wing.
You need to wait for permission?
You?
No, Sundew barked.
I'm just wondering where they are, that's
all.
I don't need them.
Let's go kill some plants.
Oof.
No, I don't like the sound of that at
all.
Let's go destroy some hive wing stuff.
That's much better.
Bumblebee did not wake up as Cricket
wrapped her in her scarf sling and tucked
her into her chest.
She snorted and gruffled, and stuck sharp
little claws into her, but Cricket poked
the fish back into her mouth, and
bumblebee dozed off again.
They flew along the south coast of the
peninsula, staying below the level of the
cliffs to avoid being spotted.
Cricket noticed that Swordell couldn't
keep his eyes off the bay.
He kept turning to search the beach below
them.
The 5th time he crashed into sundew by
accident, she nearly threw him into the
ocean.
She glanced at Blue, and saw him turning
to look out at the islands too.
Oh, she realized, they're looking for
Luna.
I hope she's all right.
I hope her flame silk is helping to keep
her safe.
There were no more hive wings in the sky
when they reached the grassland on the
outskirts of wasp hives.
They landed and slipped into the shadow
of one of the greenhouses.
Cricket could still see the smoke in the
distance.
Now, with small figures wheeling around
it.
If bloodworm high falls, Blue said
leaning against her side.
So do the webs between it and Mantis Hive
and Jewel Hive.
That's a lot of silkwing homes.
Sundew hunched her shoulders and dug her
claws into the ground.
I'll go scout ahead.
She hurried off between the glass walls.
It's weird, Blue said, watching her go.
The posters always said, the leaf wings
were going to do something terrible to
the hives, and I always believed it, until
we met Sundew.
And then the more I knew her.
I guess I started thinking the leaf wings
would all be like her.
Mad on the outside, but kind on the
inside, right?
Like, of course, she could blow up the
whole hive, and maybe she'd even want to
but she wouldn't actually do it.
So I thought none of them would actually
do it.
But now they have.
So with Queen Wasp right and I was
wrong.
I don't know what to think.
I think you're still right, Cricket
said.
I mean, that Sundew wouldn't have done it
herself.
And I hope there are other leaf wings
like her.
She looked south again at the smoke that
seemed to be painted onto the clouds
forever now.
Did this mean the hive wings and leaf
wings were at war again?
It felt so clear to her that they
shouldn't be.
They all had one enemy, the same enemy.
Queen Wasp.
If only she could get them to see that.
But she was just one little dragon.
How could she get anyone to listen to
her?
Sundu appeared around a corner of a
greenhouse and beckoned to them.
They hurried to her on silent talons
through the wet grass.
Just 2 guards patrolling the greenhouses
as far as I can see, she said in a low
voice, hard to tell from a distance, but
they seem to have their own eyes.
If we keep quiet, I think we can sneak
past them.
Florable, announced Bumblebee, popping
her head out of the sling around cricket
Sundew gave her a steely look.
Don't even think about it, Dragonette.
Blean Mark!
Bumblebee retorted at top volume.
She squirmed around in the sling, pulled
out the fish, which had not improved in
smell over the course of the morning, and
flung it at sundew's head.
I beg your pardon, Sundu said, catching
the fish and waving it at bumblebee.
This was a perfectly good breakfast, and
at your own fault you're hungry if you
don't want to eat it.
It's mebo, smebo, smebo, bumblebee said
in the same tone, wagging her claw at
sundew.
Listen here, Sundew said with a scowl.
We are on a stealth horticultural mission
and you are going to be absolutely silent
until we are done.
Do you understand?
Looble, fooble, gooble.
Bumblebee burbled.
Reaching towards sundew with her front
talons.
Herkle, turkle, miss you.
Nope, no, no, sir.
Cricket, control your tiny monster.
I think she wants you, Cricket admitted.
The dragonette was vigorously wiggling
her way out of the sling, no matter how
cricket tried to pin her down.
Well, too bad.
Sundew snapped.
Boo bah.
Bumblebee shouted enthusiastically.
Shh.
Swordell tried, flapping his wings at
her.
Cricket hadn't realized a dragonette that
small could laugh already.
Bumblebee's whole face wrinkled up, and
she fell back into the sling, giggling
hysterically.
So, Sundew said to Cricket, this is
officially the worst idea you've ever
had.
She might be quieter if you take her
Cricket suggested.
I'm not sure, Blue said.
I think she likes it when you yell at
her.
Here, Sundew said, digging into one of
her pouches.
Give her this.
I'm not sticking a sleep flower up a baby
dragonette's nose, cricket said
protectively, or a centipede, or a
paralysis dart, or whatever else you have
in there.
It's just dried mango.
Sundew said.
Even I have yet to use a paralysis toxin
on a baby dragonette.
She scowled at Bumblebee.
The key word there is yet, howler
monkey.
Yum, yum, yum.
Bumblebee agreed cheerfully, snatching
the mango out of sundew's talons and
stuffing it in her mouth.
Her eyes went wide, and she gave Sundew a
worshipful look.
Yum.
What is this feeling of doom that just
settled on me?
sundew asked the sky.
You did have mango.
Swordtel said to her accusingly.
Can we please get on with bringing down
the hive wing queen now?
Sundu said to Bumblebee.
The dragonette ignored her, snuggled into
cricket. and went to work on the mango.
Sortail and Sundew went first, padding
swiftly through the aisles.
Cricket felt a weird shiver of déjà vu
remembering the last time they were
sneaking through these same greenhouses
early in the morning.
That was before the queen knew cricket
secret, when cricket still had the option
of going home.
That was before I knew her secrets too
but now I do.
I have the truth in my talons, and I'm
going to do something with it.
The Queen's greenhouse loomed up before
them. crowded with dark green leaves that
pressed against the glass windows.
Cricket couldn't believe they'd been here
before, standing in the middle of the
queen's secret and hadn't even realized
it.
One guard stood outside the door.
Idly reading the warning sign.
His tail flicked back and forth across
the grass, leaving a silvery trail
through the wet blades.
He didn't look very worried about anyone
coming to do battle with the plants.
Sunder reached into one of her pouches
and softly drew out a tiny hollow tube.
She slipped something sharp into one end
raised the other to her mouth, and blew
the dart at the guard.
His tail went still on the grass.
His wings stopped mid flutter.
His whole body was frozen in place.
Florb.
Bumblebee said approvingly around the
mango.
Drag him away from the greenhouse, sundew
said to sore tell.
He doesn't need to go up in flames with
it.
Cricket and Blue exchanged glances.
She's saving a random hive wing.
She's making sure he doesn't die.
Cricket didn't think Sundew would have
done that before she knew them.
If we could change her mind.
Maybe we can change others.
Thortell grappled with a paralyzed dragon
while the other 3 sliced away the webs
covering the greenhouse door and stepped
inside.
The heat and humidity swamped cricket
just as it had before.
And now she recognized the smell too.
Sharp and unpleasant amid the other
scents of the plants around them.
It's this one, Sundew said, lifting a
leaf on one of the vines that thronged
the greenhouse, circling and choking the
other plants.
The stem of the vine was dark red, with
veins of bright green, and the leaves
were the same in reverse, bright green
with veins of red, like streams of
blood.
Each was the size of a dragon talon with
jagged tough edges.
It would have been perfectly
appropriately creepy, if it weren't for
the clusters of tiny white flowers
nestled between the leaves.
Sundew rubbed the leaf between her claws
for a moment, frowning at it.
I don't know what it is, she said at
length.
Me neither, Cricket offered.
I don't remember seeing it in any of my
botany books, and I think I would.
I know someone who might know.
Sundew used her claws to slice through
the vine in 2 spots, making a cutting as
long as her arm.
She rolled it into a loose ball, and
tucked it into an empty pouch.
Is that a good idea?
Blue asked.
Shouldn't we destroy all of it so it can
never grow again, and no one can ever use
it like she has.
I think we need to know what it is, Sundew
said to him.
Me too, Cricket agreed, and maybe.
She hesitated, afraid to say it out
loud.
Maybe there's an antidote.
Sundew finished for her.
Blue's eyes widened.
Smorg Bamfibo, Bumblebee declared, in
Sundoo's solemnest voice.
I feel like you're mocking me, Sundu said
to the dragonette.
Smink smock smackie fee.
The dragonhead answered with enormous
gravity, copying sundew's frown.
Sundew raised one eyebrow at cricket.
I swear I did not teach her to do that.
Cricket promised.
All right, Sundew said, turning to sweep
the greenhouse with her gaze.
Who wants to burn it all down?
There was a pause before she turned and
leveled her gaze on Blue.
Oh, right, me, Blue said.
He stepped to the nearest cluster of
vines and set his front talons on them.
Fiery silk erupted from his wrists
catching and tangling through the
leaves.
Everywhere it touched, blades of flame
flickered, smoked, curled into black ash
or brightened into orange blossoms of
fire.
Heavy, reddish green smoke rose from the
vines, and Cricket covered her snout with
one of her scarves.
Don't breathe it in, she shouted at the
others.
She wrapped another scarf around
bumblebee's indignant face.
Blue, let's go.
She tugged on his arm, and turned to run
to the door with Sundew.
Blue followed them, pausing every few
steps to shoot more fountains of flame
over the vines.
Cricket could hear the crackling fire
building and spreading.
The heat shot past tolerable and pressed
against her scales.
And she thought of the dragons and
bloodworm hive, and wondered if this was
what they'd felt as they fled their
burning city.
They threw open the door, and tumbled
onto the wet grass outside.
Blue leaped out after them, and slammed
the door behind him.
But it splintered into a 1000000 pieces
as it hit the frame.
Glass fragments exploded outward, along
with tongues of fire, roaring like angry
dragons.
Cricket curled her body around bumblebee
and ran to escape the flames and smoke.
She nearly collided head on with a 2nd
hive wing guard, who started to grab her
and then froze, staring open mouthed at
the burning greenhouse.
That one is lost, Cricket said. shaking
her.
Get water, and you can save the others.
Make sure your friend is safe too.
She turned to look around and saw the
paralyzed guard lying a few greenhouses
away.
Sortail was still trying to drag him a
little farther.
The grass was wet enough that cricket
hoped the fire wouldn't spread.
But she wasn't sure.
She didn't want the other greenhouses to
burn.
They held the food and other resources
for 100s of dragons.
Sundew's parents might have been willing
to burn them, but she thought sundew
wouldn't.
The guard pointed at the greenhouse.
The queen, she stammered.
She, that's her.
Cricket gripped her shoulders to get her
attention.
That is where she kept the plant that
lets her control us, she said.
I saw her stabbing eggs in the jewel hive
nest.
She injects us before we've even
hatched.
Do you understand?
That plant gave her the hive mind power.
And we burned it to take it away from
her.
What?
The guard shook her head, confused.
No, the queen, she has that power because
she's our queen.
She had it because of a plant, Cricket
said.
She's been poisoning us, our whole tribe
ever since the tree wars, maybe longer.
You have to tell everyone.
The guard looked terrified.
Me?
Yes, Cricket said.
Knowing the truth isn't enough if you
don't share it, everyone needs to know.
I have to save the greenhouses, the guard
said, pulling out of cricket's grip.
She turned and ran toward the hive.
She will be back with help soon.
Blue said at Cricket's shoulder.
Sortell, are you napping?
Sundew shouted.
Let's go.
Sortell leaped away from the guard and
into the sky.
The others spread their wings and joined
him, and Cricket swerved around a plume
of smoke as it erupted from the
greenhouse roof.
They soared away, toward a looming bank
of dark clouds in the north.
Cricket beat her wings as hard as she
could, and glanced down at Bumblebee, who
had somehow managed to fall asleep again
despite all the commotion.
They flew and flew, following sundew
until Wasp Hive was far behind them.
There was no sign of any pursuers.
Cricket hoped that all of Queen Wasp's
attention was on Bloodworm Hive, and that
she wouldn't even discover the fire in
her greenhouse until she returned home.
Home.
There's a thing I don't have anymore.
Send do, she called.
Where are we going?
Shouldn't we go back to the cave to find
your parents?
Sundew glanced over her shoulder.
Her green and gold scales somehow still
shining even in the grayest sky.
I'm not waiting around for them, she
called back.
They'll expect to meet me back home.
Where's that?
Cricket asked, catching up to her.
Are we going to where the other leaf
wings are?
Her pulse sped up.
Despite her worries and her sadness over
bloodworm hive.
At last, she was going to find out how
the leaf wings had survived the tree wars
and where they'd been hiding all this
time.
Has anyone ever told you that you ask a
lot of questions?
Sundew said wryly.
All the time, cricket said, smiling
back.
Well, I'm surprised you haven't guessed
this answer by now.
Sundew pointed her snout north, closing
her eyes as a gust of wind and rain
rippled over their scales.
That way?
Cricket said.
You mean, all the way that way?
Are you saying the leaf wings are in?
She trailed off, remembering the stories
she'd read about carnivorous plants, 10
times the size of a dragon, of toxins, and
snakes, and quicksand, and deadly vines
and venomous wasps, and all the many, many
ways a dragon could die up there.
Yes, said sundew, smiling a real smile
now.
We're going home to the poison jungle.
Epilogue.
I'm not sure this was a good idea, Tsunami
said to Turtle.
She wasn't sure why she was whispering.
They appeared to be alone in the jungle
and yet it also felt as if there were
100s of eyes watching their every move.
The tangled trees seemed to be reaching
for them, with long trailing roots and
branches, like skeletal fingers slid into
the water.
The sand under them had become oozing mud
and she couldn't see anything through the
silt and foggy green haze in the river.
At least, she'd thought it was a river, a
river they could follow into the interior
of the continent.
But as the banks closed in.
And the jutting rocks got sharper.
She was getting the distinct sensation of
swimming into a very large shark like
mouth.
She paused, treading water for a moment
and turning in a circle.
Something enormously long and scaly broke
the surface of the river for a moment, and
tsunami readied her claws.
But the snake only lifted its head to
study them with cold eyes, then rippled
away.
Turtle, luckily had not seen it.
He had found a boulder to clutch
panting.
She kept forgetting to set her pace
slower for him, although she'd been doing
it for days.
Somewhere in the middle of the vast
ocean.
They'd both had a small panic attack
wondering if there was really anything
out there, or whether they'd missed it, or
whether they were going in the wrong
direction, and would end up swimming for
a 1000 years without ever seeing land
again.
That was when tsunami had realized why
Sea Wings had never made this journey
before.
They might be creatures of the sea, but
they needed land too.
They would not swim for days with no end
in sight, with no certainty that they
would ever find anything.
Let's go back.
Tsunami said to her brother.
Let's find another place to land, more
like what Luna described.
Yeah, he gasped.
I thought she said there weren't any
trees.
Maybe she meant only terrifying trees
tsunami said, looking up at the vines
oozing off the branches overhead.
Don't move.
The voice that suddenly spoke from the
bank had an odd accent, and a note of
authority that made tsunami freeze
obediently before her ears had even
caught up to the instructions.
Um, turtles started.
Don't speak either, said the voice.
One, two.
A dark green shape hurdled past tsunami's
head and smashed into the snake as it
lunged out of the water at them.
All tsunami could see for a moment, was a
blur of claws and fangs and scales
thrashing.
She had to close her eyes against the
waves kicked violently into her face.
Finally, the river went still, and she
dared to open her eyes again.
A green dragon with brown eyes hovered
overhead, clutching the dead snake in her
talons.
Her wings were paler green that her body
and shaped like leaves, and her under
scales were dappled with dark green leaf
shapes, like shadows.
Three moons, Turtle said.
Thank you.
Really, really, really, thank you, tsunami
echoed.
Almost too bewildered to speak.
What kind of dragons are you?
The stranger asked, flinging the snake
back into the river.
We are sea wings, tsunami answered, trying
to recover her equilibrium.
I'm tsunami, and this is turtle.
We're from the other side of the ocean.
I'm Willow, said the green dragon.
And if you want to live, you should turn
around and go back there right now.
Moon found Luna sitting on the farthest
edge of the beach again, staring out
toward Pantala, with the ocean whispering
over her claws.
Luna twisted toward the little black
dragon as she approached, and was
startled by the grim look on Moon's
face.
She'd started to think Moon only ever
looked either perfectly serene or mildly
concerned.
What is it?
Luna asked.
A vision?
Yes.
Moon said, her gaze shifting toward the
horizon.
A vision.
Cities burning, dragons hurting one
another.
More dragons being terrible just because
other dragons are different from them.
Just like all my visions.
She stopped for a moment and rubbed her
forehead.
Does that mean we're going there?
You've thought of a way to get to
Pantala?
Moon shook her head.
No.
She looked out at Luna's distant home
again.
And Luna imagined she could almost see
the flames and screaming dragons
reflected in moon's dark green eyes.
We don't need to, Moon said.
They're coming to us.
A guide to the dragons of Pentala.
Hive wings.
Description, red, yellow, and or orange
but always mixed with some black scales, 4
wings, abilities, vary from dragon to
dragon.
Examples include deadly stingers that can
extend from their wrists to stab their
enemies, venom in their teeth or claws, a
paralyzing toxin that can immobilize
their prey.
Or boiling acid, sprayed from a stinger
on their tails.
Queen, queen wasp.
Silk wings, description.
Silkwing dragonettes are born wingless
but go through a metamorphosis at age 6
when they develop 4 huge wings and silk
spinning abilities, as beautiful and
gentle as butterflies, with scales in any
color under the sun, except black.
Abilities, can spin silk from glands on
their wrists to create webs or other
woven articles, can detect vibrations
with their antennae to assess threats.
Queen, Queen Wasp.
The last Silkwing Queen, before the tree
wars, was Queen Monarch.
Leaf wings.
Description.
Wiped out during the tree wars with the
hive wings, but while they lived, this
tribe had green and brown scales, and
wings shaped like leaves.
Abilities, could absorb energy from
sunlight and were accomplished
gardeners.
Some were rumored to have unusual control
over plants.
Queen.
Last known queen of the leaf wings was
Queen Sequoia, about 50 years ago, at the
time of the tree wars.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, book 12, The
Hive Queen, by 2ET Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by James Barish.
Executive producer Melanie Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text copyright 2019 by 2ET Sutherland.
Production copyright, 2019, by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.